and I just don't see anybody going in
and taking that risk the only way people
are going to build offshore wind of any
type is the only way they've only done
it every place that's been built and
that's with a government edict for
example in Massachusetts they would put
into Vineyard one well the utilities in
Massachusetts were told you will bid you
will get a purchase power agreement with
vineyard one you don't have any option
go negotiate your best deal but you're
buying their power and sure if not
having that government mandate no one's
willing to invest their own money in
offshore wind and I think it's a pretty
good rule of thumb when you say if
people aren't willing to invest their
own money in an idea it's probably not a
very good idea so I think having this
office is Superfluous nothing's
happening if for some reason I'm 100%
wrong and five years from now people
decide to invest their own money in
offshore wind which I highly doubt will
happen but if it did we can bring the
office back no sense in wasting money on
it now because it's accomplishing
nothing and I'll take any
questions thank you representative
Harrington for introducing House Bill
682 now I know you have served on the
offshore wind commission for the last
couple of years and you follow the
developments in offshore wind
closely I noticed that uh the CEO of
orad which is the biggest wind turbine
developer in the world was fired a
couple of days ago and their stock has
fallen by like 80% and they're taking uh
huge losses what impact do you think
that will have on the offshore wind
industry well I I I think the losses
were something like if I read it
correctly $ 1.7 billion doar and
obviously it's going to have a negative
effect because this is the company
that's the Forefront they've got not
only do they have have invested in it
but they also have all the equipment
they have the Jones act compliant ships
and they have all the equipment to you
know to build offsh a wind turbance uh
having them back off like that sends a
strong message to anybody else don't get
in this business because you're going to
lose money if you
do can you tell us who builds floating
wind turbines right now I'm not that
familiar I think there's some uh built
off the coast of Japan but it's very
limited it's not the the fixed platform
wind turbines all over the world and
they've been up especially over in
Europe uh for for many many many years
and there's a there's a known technology
there but there's a lot of new variables
that come in with floating because
obviously you got to look at I mean I
think everyone's probably saw the movie
The Perfect Storm you're looking at the
potential of 50 60 foot waves that
platform's got to go up 50 or 60 feet
and come back down now they're designed
the last I saw was designed to withstand
110 mph winds which is probably not
going to be exceeded unless there's a
very rare hurricane off the coast of uh
New Hampshire but they don't operate at
over 50 m an hour so I mean every winter
we get one or two or three nor easers
that come up the coast where we have
sustained winds of 60 70 M an hour for a
couple of days and not only that you
combine that with the fact that snowing
out which there goes your solar now you
got your wind offshore wind shut down I
mean this really sets us up and I think
if you look at the scenario put forward
by ISO New England on their October 24th
report they're saying that with a I
think it's I know it's a 20 megawatt 20
gaw pardon me of offshore wind we will
still require 12 gaw of dispatchable
power that only runs less than 1% of the
time now to put that in perspective
that's five seab Brook stations of
course it won't be CBR stations because
they can't fluctuate up and down it'll
be gas turbines because that's the
cheapest because we're going to make the
cheapest one you can build because
you're not going to run very often and I
asked well how are we going to pay for
this if they only run less than 1% of
the time I was told by ISO that we'll
pay for it by putting them in the
capacity Market which means these plants
that run less than 1% of the time are
going to set the price for the for Ford
capacity Market which means every
generator in New England is going to get
paid an astronomical price this is cost
this would cost billions of dollars and
that's a direct result of having this
offshore win which is unreliable and you
can't depend on it when it's when it
works you can say over an average we be
fine but we don't base our Electric
System on the average we base it on the
acute day when I need power now can you
deliver sorry call me tomorrow that's
not good
enough so did I understand you to say
that not only is offshore wind expensive
at $150 a megawatt hour but it also
increases other expenses on the grid for
these backup plants if we would go with
the capacity Market you're talking about
probably tripling quadrupling the price
of the capacity Market Market this is
billions of dollars and it's the fact
comes down to it that again we don't
want our electricity we don't judge our
electric service on averages we judge it
on instantaneous reliability and if you
can't give me the power I need now then
I get a problem that means I have to
have a backup and someone's going to pay
for that backup it's not
free further questions for
representative uh
Harrington representative McGee
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Harrington for presenting
this bill so my question is you were
serving on um on the offshore wind
commission and I know the other states
were more anxious around this than we
were we were there observing and uh
we're always a little bit recalcitrant
in terms of whether or not it was
something we were interested in but my
understanding was that the plans were
always for the turbines to be in the
Gulf of Maine because the wind is
preferable there and the part that New
Hampshire was was supposed to play was
it coming on Shore uh to get to an
eversource interconnection in Portsmouth
at least that's what I had heard is that
we were looking to um beef up Workforce
in order to support the onshoring of
that power from the Gulf of Maine so um
I guess my question is are the other
states decide have the other states oped
not to go
forward uh and if they are still going
forward and we are simply pulling back
on investigating or
participating will that still result in
higher rates for us since we're on a
regional
grid well well there's a lot to that
question I could I could answer that for
probably 45 minutes and bore the hell
out of everybody with it but I I'll try
to a little bit uh more concise than
that yeah the other states are different
but remember the other states have an
edict the government is making the
decision not private Enterprises the
utilities aren't saying this is the best
way to serve my customers by building
offshore wind they're being told by the
government you will develop offshore
wind we don't care what it costs go
figure it out do it and Conneticut for
example has backed out it was supposed
to be a three-state uh I guess m Mutual
contract between massachusett Rhode
Island and Connecticut Connecticut
pulled out of it because they looked at
it and says it just it costs too much
Rhode Island in Massachusetts was
supposed to come out with a figure last
summer which they put off to the fall
which they put off till after the
election which I Now understand has been
put off until March so they still
haven't come out with a with a price on
it I'm not sure where they're locating I
would assume they're going to be off the
coast of Rhode Island and Massachusetts
which means they can use fixed platform
wi because the depth is lower the Gulf
of Maine does not allow that it's just
too deep if somebody wanted to go into
the Gulf of main um I mean it's
federally licensed uh they could I I
assume they could bring this uh on Shore
they would have to go through the site
evaluation Committee in New Hampshire to
bring the uh transmiss a new
transmission line from the shore to
wherever it went even if went just to
Massachusetts so that would have to be
uh litigated that way but I I just uh I
don't really see uh the other state
saying your utility rate payers are
going to pay to build offshore wind off
the coast of Maine or New Hampshire and
we're going to uh uh uh we're going to
have them build jobs and infrastructure
and all this other stuff all those jobs
and whatever are going to come from
Massachusetts or Island because of the
ones paying for it and I should mention
to be complete that there is one
offshore wind project that's being done
by the state of Maine again it's a
government edict no one is voluntarily
spending a dime of their own money on it
but they are building a small project as
a prototype floating one off the coast
of Maine and I think at least until that
comes out and we see that run for a few
years and what the results are uh we
should not spend a single more dime on
it we can just watch and see what
happens and then make a decision based
on actual knowledge rather than
Theory representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um and thank
you for being here representative I'm
going to piggyback on the chair's
question of the impact of wind power
investment because a CEO was fired um in
Maine Irving Oil has already announced a
10% increase of oil because of the
arbitrary tariffs that have been placed
on
Canada um can you please tell me what
the impact of these tariffs are on
offshore wind power and wouldn't because
New Hampshire doesn't have oil and gas
but we do have wood solar and wind
wouldn't we want to invest in creating
energy
Independence I think you're confusing me
I'm not Donald Trump I mean just to make
that clear because uh you seem to be
confusing about that fact as far as the
I am not but thank you for the
clarification as far as the tariffs go
on that hang on a minute
okay representative Thomas you need to
secure the permission of the chair to
speak so please don't interrupt people
in the future uh if I'm being insulted
I'm going to call it call it out no
you're being instructed by the
chair that you're not allowed to speak
it's in house rules I can show you the
citation if you need to see it
that says you have to be recognized but
by the chair before you speak you
interrupted representative Harrington
and therefore I'm asking you not to do
that again do you need a further
clarification I have a question yes go
ahead if someone who is testifying
insults somebody who is a member of the
committee shouldn't it be the chair's
responsibility to call that out yes it
would be the chair's responsibility I
heard no such insult
representative Harrington you can answer
I'll answer the question in by as short
as I possibly can this this bill has
nothing to do with uh tariffs on Canada
or tariffs on anybody else it has to do
with putting the offshore wind at best
on hold because nothing's going to go
forward and we shouldn't be spending any
money on it till we have more facts
followup followup does this bill have
anything to do with a CEO being
fired I think the fact that the largest
in producer uh I think it's the largest
one had fired their CEO because they
pursued offshore wind says a lot about
the uh what people are willing to do
with offshore wind I.E when it comes to
their own money they're a little bit
conservative about spending it on
offshore wind and they think I would
assume they would think that their CEO
made the wrong decisions otherwise they
wouldn't have fired
them further questions for
representative Harrington representative
nter thank you uh could you please tell
me when you filed this
bill you repeat the question please when
did you file this bill when did I file
it timeline I I'm not sure whatever it
was in the whatever was allowed to do so
on uh the new system on OS so followup
so November follow months
ago yeah I guess it was probably yeah
November December yeah thank
you representative Swanson has a a
question hi uh thank you Mr chair thank
you Mr Harrington uh did I understand
you correctly you asserted
that offshore wind only generates 1% of
the time did I did I hear that correctly
what's what percentage can you can you
repeat okay yeah no no that's not what
you heard what I was referring to is in
if you look at the iso New England
report it's dated October 24th it's like
transitioning to the new green energy or
something it's called you can find it on
their website what they said was and I
might have the number wrong I can't
remember if it was 20 gwatt or 25 GW of
offshore wind but assuming one of those
that there would then require
dispatchable which is not wind or solar
but dispatchable meaning turn on now and
give me 10 megawatts turn off turn back
on 2 hours from now give me 50 megaw
they would need 12 gaw of dispatchable
power that would operate less than 1% of
the time and my conjecture on that is
when you only operate less than 1% of
the time you're going to build the
cheapest plant you can because you're
not going to spend let's say money huge
amounts of money in building a nuclear
plant if it only operates 1% of the time
so you would build gas turbines which
but basically Jets which are the most
expensive least efficient way to burn
gas but did the cheapest to build those
are the ones that we would have have 12
gaw of now as far as the offshore wind
the capacity Factor on offshore wind is
fairly High compared to like on onshore
wind it's somewhere pushing around 50%
but again the problem is 50% is when the
wind decides it wants to blow not when
we decide we need the power so that
could run at 80% one day and 5% another
day and that's the problem why you have
to have this backup power followup
question M so
I uh installed my own solar system in my
house and it obviously is only going to
be working when the sun shines but it
does provide electricity to my neighbors
and supplements the grid as far as I
know there was no additional
construction of
more uh turbin or anything to offset
when I would be offline but uh I'm I'm
confused is the why would we take any
action here if it's not Mark if it isn't
profitable why would we prohibit anybody
from investing it if there's investment
why would we prohibit
that I don't think this it necessarily
prohibits it what it does is basically
say the state's not going to be involved
if if somebody if our friends from
eversource here decide we think it's a
great idea to build offshore wind in the
Gulf of Maine and they can convince that
the Pu that their costs are just in
reasonable uh and they can change state
law so that allows them to build
generation then go ahead but this just
says the state of New Hampshire is not
going to have an offshore wind industry
development office which where there's
no offshore wind to develop we're not
going to waste our money on it and just
if if indeed five years 10 years from
now the world changes we can bring this
back we just there's no there's no need
for it now so one further question
related to the uh's no point in having
in the office make it quick please um
would so somebody could still develop
wouldn't we want to be involved as far
as a state in whatever development takes
place even if it's completely invested
by the free
market there's no prohibition by getting
rid of this this doesn't stop anybody
from investing in anything they want
just as like if someone decides they
want to build an SMR for example small
modular reactor in uh in New Hampshire
um they could do that if they want to
put on a uh a landbased wind farm they
can do do that if they want to put in a
utility size meaning you know 50
megawatt solar array they can do that
it's just simply says the state's not
going to have a specific office just to
uh to try to make that go it's that's
like we do every other generation
project in New Hampshire it just takes
it's done by the free market thank you
Mr Harington thank you Mr chair okay
thank you representative Rand has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative Harrington for being
up there and taking questions on your
bill
um your points about uh the capacity
factor for offshore wind are are well
taken it's intermittent resource
although offshore wind as you noted has
a relatively high capacity Factor among
Renewables
but in all among all the presentations
that the committee had to start the
session I never heard that um their New
Hampshire or or the grid for that the
New England grid for that
matter was short on fixed generation
assets dispatchable power plants uh and
for that matter if if the market needed
another natural gas plant as you noted
they're fairly cheap to build I assume
somebody could build one but what we did
here was that the
constraint on PO power in the New
England grid is the supply of natural
gas we have limited pipeline capacity
into the
region so if that's our greatest danger
isn't it in New Hampshire's interests to
facilitate
the entry into the market of as many
generation assets as possible even if
they're intermittent so that whenever
they are generating whenever those
Renewables the offshore wind
or the solar are
generating the natural gas can be saved
for another hour when when it's needed I
mean why wouldn't we want to facilitate
the entry of more generation onto the
grid so that we could preserve our
natural gas and use it when we need it
well again you you you're confusing
average with instantaneous and I think
that's the issue you're talking about
something that does a capacity factor of
somewhere around 50% that means 50% of
the time it's producing nothing um and
as far as the saving the natural gas um
the the theory if you read the iso New
England paper is that when you put all
this offshore wind in that is mandated
by states which is the only way anybody
does it that will turn around and
they'll sign a fixed price contract what
with the utility in New England in
Massachusetts or Rhode Island and then
then in turn they'll bid in zero into
the daily energy markets which will tend
to drop the uh lmps which means the
wholesale price of electricity would
actually go down for the people who
aren't buying the offshore wind of
course that means a lot of these places
that we have for natural gas now that
are marginal certainly if you looked at
this winter we had a number of times
when we were producing there was one day
when the biggest generator of
electricity in New England was from oil
those will go out of business because
they won't be able to withstand that
lower price unless we turn around and
drastically increase the capacity the
Ford capacity market clearing price but
in in short of that you'll see that
there be less natural gas generators
that's what the iso New England is
contemplating basically they want to
wipe out their theory is you know if you
look at Massachusetts and Connecticut
Rhode Island get rid of fossil fuels
period so it's not going to happen
because you just you'd have to shut down
the grid but the goal there is to make
it so you use fossil fuels I.E Natural
Gas to the minimum extent possible this
whole turnover remember it involves uh
heat pumps and turning to
electrification of of cars
electrification of heating so the
natural gas supply is not going to be uh
challenged as much as it is now because
you just won't be using as much of it
but when those times when the offshore
wind is not doing and it's snowing out
uh that the nor Easter I was talking
about comes up the coast you're going to
need those 12 gaw of most likely natural
gas to produce when you say I need you
now so okay this is starting to sound
like a debate to me rather than a
discussion of the bill so I'm going to
thank representative Harrington for
introducing the bill and next call on
representative Abul Khan of sebr to give
us his perspective on this
legislation good morning representative
nice to see you
again good morning Mr chairman good
morning my colleagues the committee
members I represent SE Brook uh dist uh
Rockingham 30 uh for this is my sixth
term and I am uh for this bill I'm I'm
I'm speaking for for this bill in
support of this bill uh Mr
chairman um I
also uh um the CBR also has one of the
biggest uh Fisherman's Cooperative
called U Yanke Fisherman's Co Co-op
and few years ago I was also a member of
the uh windmill project Governor sunun
appointed me at the C Brooks
representative and I attended three uh
meetings at the past um uh facility of
the
DS and all three uh meeting I requested
that a fisherman's representative should
be in the
committee and and the
organizers uh they did refused they said
that um I am their representative I
never went for fishing I cannot be the
fisherman's representative when the
fisherman has to have a seat in the
table so on advice from the C Board of
slackman I resigned from that Comm a
commission about four five six years ago
and since then it you know I watched
from outside that how it happened and
where it is
going um Mr chairman uh New Hamshire has
only 16 17 Mile
Coastline and we love our Coastline the
way it is and all the negative all the
you know negative things I heard from
all the residents and citizens of New
Hampshire that is going to bring bad
effect to our uh natural beauty our
fishing industry even many many other
things that I you know that is going to
have a NE negative effect it's not going
to bring any Financial benefit to our
residents or citizens in New Hampshire
uh even though you know they're going to
produce electricity or whatever power
they will produce is not going to have
any benefit to it's going to go to the
greed uh through us and all the
disruption we're going to have in our
Coastline and everything else plus Mr uh
chairman as you know that this kind of
project they you know we have to think
about how they going to dismantle in
case they have to dismantle in future
and I do not hear you know too many
times that where is the money like um uh
me and uh representative Harrington we
both see and the uh nuclear dismantling
Comm commission and we have more than $1
billion in case we had to have that and
this this industry doesn't have nothing
like that and we're going to be sit on
it in in case they leave us you know as
it is so Mr Mr chairman I'm totally
against it I uh we me and my family
moved to sebr in New Hampshire uh 25
years ago this month and the time we
moved here
uh we promis that the way uh you know uh
I raise my family the way I see it the
way I found it I will leave the New
Hampshire you know if I die here we will
leave the New Hampshire better than we
found it so this will be a bad thing for
New Hamshire we should not vote for it I
ask all the Committee Member to vote for
it so we don't need any windmill thank
you Mr chairman I'm ready to take any
question thank you questions for
representative of Khan representative
McGee thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
Khan for being with us this morning so
you testified that you don't think there
would be any benefit for New Hampshire
and I guess I want to drill down on that
a little bit um like many power plants
or power infrastructure there's a high
upfront cost but then beyond that
upfront cost the the energy itself
generating the energy has no cost um and
it also has no impact on uh you know the
pollutants going in into the uh
atmosphere that are really causing all
of this effort to try and transition our
Energy System so H how do you conclude
or where did you come up with the
conclusion that there would be no
benefit if clean energy or clean power
is being generated and put onto the grid
because I think everybody that takes
stuff off the grid would end up
benefiting um in multiple ways
representative it's a excellent question
I really really like this question so I
said on the SE Board of selectman for 15
years you know until 20123 and every
year we negotiated with the power plant
uh for their tax dollar for many many
years so the power plant in our our you
know we are the host community and uh
the power plant does not except for the
taxes for the you know um uh for the
town of sebr
they give uh some money to State
education beside that this committee
trying for many many years to bring the
our energy cost lower we don't see those
power in New Hampshire they go somewhere
else we don't get a dime out of that
thing in New
Hampshire many of you are here is
Engineers you know that I am not an
engineer you know we have lot of
different things but from from sebr
power plant they're good people they are
good company they are involved in our
community development and many many good
things they do but we're not getting any
benefit out of that except for the tax
dollar so the same thing is going to
happen to the windmill they will build
it they will disrupt our Coastline and
then they they will take the you know
the line to somewhere else and they will
sell it somewhere else we're not going
to get a dime out of that that that's my
answer okay additional questions for
representative Khan seeing I want to
thank you for your testimony we'll call
next on Megan Stone from the Department
of
energy Miss Stone needs just one to two
minutes
thankfully I have several other pink
cards I think seven so after this we're
going to start limiting testimony to 2
minutes 30 seconds per
person good morning Mr chair and me
members of the committee for the record
my name is Megan Stone legislatively is
on with the Department of energy um so
the department is new neutral on House
Bill 682 however we have no concerns
with the way that uh it is written uh
the bill implements several changes uh
it modifies the office of offshore wind
industry development and energy
Innovation to the office of innovation
and removes the offshore wind related
duties from the position of the director
it repeals the offshore wind industry
Workforce Training Center committee and
the offshore import development
commission and moves the grid
modernization modern modernization
advisory Council and the hydrogen
advisory Council to the office of energy
Innovation although modifying the office
the bill retains the duty to support the
work of the New Hampshire members of the
intergovernmental renewable energy task
force administrate administrated by the
Bureau of ocean Energy Management it
also retains the duty to advise the
Governor State agencies pu and the
legislature on the development of clean
energy resources in the Gulf of Maine
and the purchase of Power by New
Hampshire Public Utilities from these
resources it allows the department to
take part in Regional discussions and
ensure New Hampshire's interests are
represented section two retains the
duties assigned to the nuclear
coordinator in RSA 162 B4 which were
assigned in House Bill 1465 in the 2024
term and pass both bodies unanimously
section three and section n of the bill
removes the grid sorry moves the grid
modernization group and the hydrogen
advisory committee under the office of
energy Innovation and this change will
enhance the role of the office by
allowing it to more fully focus on
energy Innovation the department
believes uh making this change makes
sense and will give the office a clear
Direction and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you so does the
department have any problems with the
bill no not as not as introduced
representative Vice chair Thomas thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question I'm just curious with all uh if
this bill were to pass would the
department recognize any changes in
costs would would would would any cost
be effective whatsoever no no there's no
fiscal impact to this
bill further questions representative
McGee thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I was I was
waiting for the right speaker to ask the
question about point three which is
moving the grid modernization advisory
Council and the hydrogen advisory
Council into the office of energy
Innovation I know I served uh for four
years on the Energy Efficiency and
sustainable energy board and that was
also moved into the doe and what that
served to do was remove the transparency
remove the public uh input um the the
you know the meetings were no longer
public they were they were inter
Department agency meetings so could you
respond to how the grid modernization
Council what changes will occur if it's
no longer a a separate standing body in
terms of public meetings and all that
um I I don't know at this time if there
would be any specific changes uh I it
would just move it under this office in
particular so followup followup so would
the meetings be public and would the
public be able to observe the meetings
which is part of what we were doing when
we created The Advisory Council um I'm
not entirely familiar with how that
group has been working so I would just
have to look into that and I can get
back to
you representative Wendy Thomas thank
you chair um thank you for being here
and um I heard your response that
there's no fiscal impact um to this bill
and I don't see any fiscal note um but
could you tell me how many employees
would be impacted and or lose their jobs
if we did away with this office um
because you're still retaining the
office of energy Innovation uh right now
it has there's two employees with that a
director and an analyst and those would
both remain with this office
okay seeing no further questions I want
to thank you for being here to give us
the Department's perspective next I'll
call on Rob wner of
conquered
representing
lcv ne4
osw so Mr Warner
welcome thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee um my name is
Rob Werner I'm the state director here
at New Hampshire of the league of
conservation
voters I also serve on the steering
committee of New England for offshore
wind and I run our New Hampshire New
England for offure wind committee New
England for offure wind the mission of
of our organization of our Coalition is
to advocate for and promote the
responsible development of offshore wind
in New England and we have had a
particular
focus on the Gulf of Maine in in recent
years
just some comments on House Bill
682 um and necessarily it eliminates
important a variety of important venues
established by the New Hampshire
legislature that provide an opportunity
for policy makers and New Hampshire
citizens to participate in policy
discussions and Analysis regarding the
development and deployment of offshore
wind the elimination of the offshore
wind industry Workforce training
committee is particularly Troublesome as
it short circuits important efforts in
helping to provide a path to growing
clean energy sector job creation and
economic
growth um I hope that committee would uh
vote in expedient to legislate on this
legislation I do want to make a couple
of points it's not quite accurate to say
that nothing is happening in offshore
wind uh Vineyard wind recently completed
the installation of its 602nd monopile
so those monopiles are the structure in
which the wind turbines rest so as a
reminder Vineyard wind which is up and
running and providing power to the the
grid uh when completed uh this year will
provide 800 megawatt of power to of of
generation of power of 400,000 homes
also in the Gulf of Maine I think the
committee is aware that there were
successful auctions of four of eight uh
lease areas wind energy areas in the
Gulf of Maine at the end of
October and two uh uh developers uh were
successful in those auctions and those
contracts have been fully executed so
not withstanding the recent executive
order from the Trump Administration
which as a
reminder does put a halt to Future
projects but does not affect projects
that have been permitted or under
construction um those wind energy areas
and those contracts as I mentioned fully
executed um by early
January um those projects can move
forward um there's a lot of work to do
then we're talking about you know a
fairly long
uh time Horizon of development um but
that particular situation in the Gulf of
Maine which we can take advantage of in
a variety of ways certainly supply chain
job creation um uh is an opportunity one
final point I just don't see the
necessity to completely remove ourselves
as a state from the discussion around
offshore wind which is what this bill
does and I think it's very unfortunate
and unnecessary in uh in our
view okay thank you for your testimony
and um so we have is it true that we
have two handouts from your organization
okay there was a lot going around I want
to make sure we got the right
representative McGee representative
McGee has a question thank you it's I'm
I'm rearing a go this morning how are
you nice to see you um so my question is
around uh we talk a lot in this
committee uh we have shorthand for uh
policies we like and we talk a lot about
an all of the above strategy um we heard
from the prime sponsor that there was a
concern around being able to back up
this kind of generation and in the
interim I went on to the iso New England
website because I couldn't remember when
they presented to us how much is in the
queue right now for battery storage and
backup and it's uh I have an article
right here that says it's uh there's 18
,000 megawatt of battery resources in
the queue and I think he was talking in
gigawatts in terms of the need so since
you've been on this advisory do you have
any information around the planning
that's going on regionally in terms of
uh satisfying the intermittence because
50% is a pretty high capacity Factor as
these things go but um is there a need
to to fill the other 50% like I I'm not
sure um that's clear or if that's even a
point well to be clear representative I
don't serve on these uh commissions I
certainly attend the meetings and we're
supportive um I think I would defer your
specific question but I think the point
remains that um we will need more power
certainly uh as we Electrify our economy
and we'll see what happens with data
centers in the
region uh we need more energy and my
question is where is that coming from
and again I don't see any reason to
completely separate ourselves from these
discussions with which is what this bill
does additional questions representative
PL uh thank you chair and thank you Mr
Warner for coming um it was mentioned in
testimony there's one prototype in Maine
is that one of the two you were
referring to here the cont no the um
Bureau of ocean Energy Management which
is uh under the department of interior
US Department of interior uh conducted a
long process of public uh input and wind
energy areas and you know the way you
start is with a very large area in the
Gulf of Maine and then you constrict con
constrict down so at the end of the day
there were eight uh wind energy areas
four of those were up for auction at the
end of October uh which were successful
so that's what I was referring to and
the fact that two
developers uh were successful in those
auctions and now have the right to
develop those wind energy areas with
offshore wind
resources so I have a quick question for
you the bill on
lines 11 through
14 states that the office of energy
Innovation shall support the work of the
New Hampshire member of the
intergovernmental renewable energy task
force administered by the federal bureau
of ocean Energy Management bom and it
further States on page two
lines four and five that uh the office
will advise the Governor State agencies
Public Utilities Commission and the
legislature on the development of clean
energy resources in the Gulf of M and
purchase
power and the purchase of Power by New
Hampshire Public Utilities for these
resources MH so doesn't that indicate
that uh the office of energy Innovation
will still be interested in offshore
wind I think at to some level but I
really do think that our future requires
a more focused approach and I have a
particular interest in Workforce
Development I think that's very
important I think that's uh something
that uh states around us certainly are
investing in I take your point uh Mr
chairman but I do think that we benefit
from a more
focused um aspect of concentration on
offshore wind thank you representative
rolds has a
question thank you Mr chairman um thank
you rob for being here can you um just
Enlighten the
committee regarding the leases the
successful leases that you just Al about
that have happened in Maine are those uh
have those taken place pursuant to a
power purchase agreement with any New
England utility or is that activity
that's happening in Maine still purely
um you know I
guess Market private Market based
because the it's developers that see you
know potential in in in successful you
don't have to answer that question it's
out the outside the purview of what this
bill is uh addressing I take your point
but you know just so you know the two of
the four lease areas are closer to the
cape rather than to
Maine
anyway okay uh representative Wendy
Thomas has a question thank you chair
um again piggybacking on what the chair
asked about the renewable energy task
force although they still may be
interested in the discussions don't
lines 15 through
29 on page one and including line one on
page two essentially nter that task
force by removing all of their analysis
tools I think that's a concern and
that's uh again to my point that I
believe that this legislature previous
legislature had made the decision and
made investment to some level of these
discussions and I think these venues are
important and ought to continue in my
view
thank okay seeing no further questions I
want to thank you Mr wner for being here
and next call on Sarah
Thorne from holderness who is
representing herself Miss Thorne you
have two minutes 30
seconds good morning thank you for the
opportunity to speak with you this
morning um I am a retired school teacher
and although I am representing myself
today um I I call upon you to imagine
these seats and classrooms across the
state full of young people who are
counting on
you for their future you have a big
responsibility you have a responsibility
to plan for Energy Futures for our state
that will bring clean air that that will
bring energy sources that will halt the
pollution of our atmosphere by methane
and carbon
dioxide which are as you all know
causing grave grave threats already in
our
world um these young people are counting
on you to investigate every possible
Avenue and I would remind you that the
subsidies already invested in fossil
fuels every year amount to billions of
dollars hundreds of billions of dollars
in the United States alone and the
international monetary fund estimate 7
billion globally in
2022 this is wind is a new technology
there are bound to be glitches and we've
seen some of them in the past few years
but if you think about any bold new
energy technology they have all gone
through periods of
glitches and I would ask you to stay
with
wind give it your best shot it's a
tremendously powerful potential energy
source for our
region um I sympathize with the
representative from Seabrook and his
concerns about Coastal impacts but I
would remind you to weigh that against
the impact of
[Music]
submerging the coastal infrastructure
and communities as our sea levels rise
and killing many many marine organisms
as our ocean continues to acidify
because of the CO2 we're putting into
the atmosphere
thank you for your
time thank you I appreciate
it seeing no questions we'll move next
to Mr Eric Anderson from
Portsmouth Mr Anderson you have two and
a half minutes thank you Mr
chairman
um thank you Mr chairman in the
committee uh my name is Eric Anderson
I've been an active commerci fisherman
in state of New Hampshire for over 50
years um there's there's components to
this particular bill um and one of them
that I have some knowledge about is the
offshore and Port development commission
um I've
attended and another colleague here Jim
tatone have attended every meeting over
the last two years and um that committee
or commission more or less um the
agendas were
all tended to follow you know pro pro a
pro-wind approach um in the course of
two years and I sat there as an
interested party for the fishing
industry we had maybe 40 minutes of
dialogue in that commission over two
years and I thought that was
insufficient um but I did and and it
explored many aspect of of offshore wi
one of the things that I found most
interesting was um somebody that they
they solicited at one of the agendas and
this fow represented a company that
repairs the cables for offshore wind if
they fail he's built a business I mean
there's a there's a solid business he
says without a doubt these cables are
going to fail and I'm the guy that comes
in and fixes
him he explained that it's a
multi-million dollar venture to fix
these things and it takes over 20 days
20 to 30 days to fix these so when they
fail that power that's you know the
transmission lines that are coming to
shore I'm not sure what exactly where
that power goes but that's that was one
thing I found it in interesting you know
to to hear him speak about what his
business does
um that's that's the the extent of you
know my
um of of attending the meetings at the
at the port at the um offshore ort
development commission and um I I
support that it really has explored
everything it doesn't really have much
of a function anymore thank you thank
you Mr
Anderson perfect timing by the way
seeing no questions I'll thank you and
I'll call next on
Ward and I'm not sure what Ward's last
name is um it's kind of hard to read
here is it
Bak that would be
burn oh burn okay um I'm a I'm a lefty
so I I can't write very good I guess
that's what they tell me no problem but
thanks for being here I'm uh thank you
for uh having me this morning for this
uh testimony uh my name is Ward burn I'm
a commercial Fisher out of Portsmouth
New Hampshire I own the vessel fishing
vessel sugar
daddy um I've heard a lot of interesting
feedback this morning and I'd like to uh
not many people know I well I was on the
on the Wind commission and uh I became a
student of of wind energy I dug into
every little dirty secret there is about
wind energy and um not many people truly
know the definition of green energy like
what is green energy does you know
anybody really know you know we talk
about green energy and how great it is
but do we know what it
means and I so I Googled the definition
of green energy is an energy that can be
produced using a method or form or
source that can cause no harm to its
natural environment and I read that to
you because there's a lot of bad things
that take place with windmills and I I'm
sure a lot of you haven't heard of the
cooling stations that are required for
these experimental wind farms these
cooling stations are going to take
seawater off the ocean floor they're
going to suck suck the water into the
units they're going to cool and the
reason they cool is because they need to
transfer from AC to DC power and it
creates
heat they chlorinate it to prevent
fowling in their equipment when they
discharge it they're going to discharge
that water at the tune of 8.2 million
gallons a day at 40% load into the ocean
chlorinated heated sea water if they get
this wind array that they would like
that would be 280 million gallons of
chlorinated sea water into our ocean
your ocean my ocean our kids
oceans it it would it's an O it's an
ocean killer absolutely 100% this is
their data this is from from the wind
companies their material I didn't make
this up at a 100% load that's 333
million gallons of chlorinated heated
heated sea waterer into the ocean it's
it will destroy and kill our ocean there
are no greater stewards of the Ocean
than fishermen
ourselves I'm deeply concerned about the
death of whales hundreds of whales are
washed ashore because of these windmills
no one will put a finger on it because
they've been bought out if you look into
research New England Aquarium a big
whale saer they received 1.5 million
from the wind companies everybody's been
hush on this issue and it's absolutely
ridiculous we're held to a standard to
protect whales and we and we do the very
best we can yet these these foreign
companies have no standards they've
actually been alloted a number from
Noah on how many whales they can kill if
we did that we're out of
business um there's another thing that
is on these windmills we always see
these dumps that they put the windmill
blades in there's a reason for that wrap
it up quickly please I'm working on it I
I could talk for an hour on this but uh
the compound that's on the windmill
blades is a compound called banol a it's
a a resin that's in it and the reason
they have these windmill dumps is the
blades become brittle and the outer
coating breaks off and becomes into
particles and falls into the ocean or it
will fall into the ocean after 2 years
the forage fish will eat those particles
and then the forage fish will be eaten
by the Predator fish and they will
toxify our food and I and in my closing
I'd like you to think that the banol a
is highly toxic we think of all the
windmills that are in our country right
now and the crazy Rising rate of of
Cancer all these windmills are
experiencing the same thing this stuff
is breaking off going into our ground
and toxifying our drinking water it's
something think about this windmills are
anything but green thank
you okay thank you representative Vice
chair Thomas has a question for you
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so my my question is
um as opposed to Federal bureaucrats and
windmill companies how well do you think
fishermen that fish in the Gulf of Maine
know their Waters and know what affects
their Waters and the fishing population
it's our backyard it's our front yard
Nobody Knows the ocean better than us we
know where the species are what time the
year they're there what tide they're
there it's it's it's our where we make
our living and we care deeply nobody
cares about these oceans more than us
and I I particularly care is I have a
son that's also a commercial fisherman I
have a lot invested into this to protect
our futures and for our kids we kill the
ocean it's over and these windmills I am
100% convinced are ocean killers and
it's been
overlooked uh representative schneller
has a
question I one thing you didn't mention
because your time was limited I assume
are you familiar with the super high uh
quality I guess the word is axle grease
that's used to continue to run these
wind turbines offshore that
uh is designed to not leech into the
ocean in your research and experience
does that actually leech into the ocean
and affect potentially what you
do well certainly any any oil leak into
the ocean is not good I know they they
house a tremendous amount of hydraulic
fluid I don't know specifically on the
grease on them but they they do have
large quantities of oil that that are in
it and and keep in mind the carbon
footprint it takes to build these things
is is extraordinary for for them to
install them the diesel fuel that's
burnt the discharge from Builders it's
it's
significant okay seeing no further
questions I want to thank you for being
here we have four more people who want
to testify on this bill so that is an
alert to the people who are here for
House Bill
575 that we should be able to start on
that bill in about 10 to 12 minutes so
next up is J Julie Porter of
Dover Miss Porter you have two and a
half
minutes good
morning please press the button to turn
on the
mic hello
okay there's not enough time we've been
going over this for years so I'm going
to try to make it as quick as I can and
cover as much as I can um P ISO up this
morning or yesterday sorry um gas is at
55% these this is what's powering New
England right now nuclear is at 24
Renewables at 12 so you break down the
Renewables solar is at 4% wind is at
three I I I'm going to jump around a
little bit because this is important
this
3% because that's all New Jersey is
generating and they have the most
offshore wind off the coast of New
Jersey and they're just a little like
3.9 so I'm I'm really really
wondering the point of all this exercise
wind and solar are
not steady sources of heat I live in a
solar house I know a passive solar
house okay let's talk about the cabling
I got to cover a lot of things I get
back to my farm so I'm going to cover
try to cover everything of all the bills
that I can sorry the cabling the pascao
toilla station um the pipe 50 years ago
we fought off a pipeline going to go up
the
bay well this is even worse because
after they get the pipeline to Schiller
we're going to be dealing with cabling
that carries emps which is very
dangerous for any anybody people and
animals in the
bay battery storage right now there's a
battery storage facility burning this is
the third one this is the second um one
in this particular one in Monterey Bay
Monterey Bay is now a Hazmat site
because of the battery
storage wind turbines and land we really
need to address these because they're
just as bad um another Hazmat problem if
they burn they make the area around them
unfarmable there's two farms in New York
that right now are dealing with this
they won't be able to farm their land
probably
ever win turbines and Wildlife our own
New Hampshire fishing game website
quotes wind energy the is for bats by
the way which are sort of in a
precarious place right now wi en jne any
facilities whose turbines can either
indirectly or directly kill large
numbers of migrating bats this is on our
own New Hampshire fishing game site
these things are death there there's no
green about them and there's there's
nothing that we're gaining from them so
I I I failed to see the
point reindeer and lap land oh I'm sorry
gosh reindeer and lap land won't go near
these things one final thought please
one final thought oh my gosh okay dead
citations three of us have been
following the dead citations P floating
up on the shore where wind wind is
being surveyed and running and as of the
end of December the count for cations is
293 and those are the ones we know about
these aren't the ones that are floating
out there that we never see or at the
bottom of the ocean they're not ship
strikes they're not fishing lines
they're bleeding from their ears and if
you want to look up a study the new H um
you our own US Navy was sued three times
for inflicting brain Heming on citations
we know this is causing it it it's not
just an accident that these animals are
washing up on shore and this is very
important because do we really want this
in New Hampshire do we really want
animals do we really want to kill our
fishing industry half 90% of our fish is
coming from other countries do you think
Indonesia cares about the shrimp they're
getting for us
these guys care because this is where
they live these
fishermen
so questions okay thank you questions
for Miss border I'm happy to send this
citation list because it has links
pictures the whole thing yes if you have
written testimony please submit it I
will submit that thank you thank you
okay next up is representative Matt
saborin and uh representative I want to
apologize to you for not calling you
sooner
but I did not realize from your pink
card that you were a representative
because you did not uh write
representative in front of your name so
I know you're a new State Rep in the
future on your pink card make sure you
write representative before your name
yes sir thank you sir good morning
chairman of F and members of the
committee I'm representative Matt Sabor
D Schwaner from SE Brook I want to Echo
a similar sentiments that we've
expressed so far this morning I uh
support this bill and the other offshore
wind bills that are here today I I don't
believe offshore wind should be
considered for a few reasons uh we have
a 400-year fishing industry on the New
Hampshire sea coasts including seab
Brook as well uh these offshore wind
leases are occurring right in the middle
of all of our fishermen's uh trade
routes uh we need them to be able to
fish and bring bring food home to their
families and to us as well it's a it's a
food security additionally I'd like to
point out that uh the commercial leases
that are happening in the the Gulf of
Maine right now um those are being
opened up at the exact same time as the
research lease so the research lease
that's off the coast of Maine isn't you
know they're not they should finish the
research first before going into you
know commercial leasing when the Air
Force wants to get a new aircraft that
goes through research and development
and operational test and evaluation
before you know being actually deployed
to the fleet and same thing here with uh
with our commercial fishing um want to
point out too this past summer there was
uh a blade that broke off the coast of
ncka Massachusetts the shrapnel from the
blade uh was everywhere over the beaches
and it shut the beaches down for the
summertime now I'm from seab Brook but I
know that Hampton Northampton Rye
Portsmith these are all commercial
vacation towns that if something like
that were to happen right now in the in
the middle of summertime that would
decimate our EC
um it's not something we could afford on
the Sea Coast um I just wanted to be S I
don't know if anyone has any
questions okay
questions seeing none we want to thank
you and we'll move on to the next fol
next person who would like to testify
this morning that's CIA Kelly from
hookit New Hampshire
welcome Miss Kelly
yeah thank you Mr chairman my name is CH
Kelly from Hook New Hampshire and I'm
originally from uh Vietnam the communist
country and I'm here to testify that I'm
a republican but I went to all these uh
windmills meeting for the last two years
that I don't see much of our um Democrat
friends that always Champion for you
know animal rights and all that good
stuff and I'm a vegetarian myself for 13
14 years so I deeply care for all the
creatures and from all these meetings I
gather all the baby fish and all other
the ocean creatures going to be sucked
into these machine when they run and
there won't be any baby to grow up for
us to harvest for other people that have
the need for
seafood and so that's affect our food
security and also the parameter
parameter that all these structure going
to be built in the ocean got on so limit
where the people going to be able to
fish or recreational purposes and one
last important thing that I would like
to mention that most of us in the US
won't know is that China is in control
of South China Sea and they had the
capability of build the whole Tel into
Vietnam and all these other regions so
that they can move military underground
and from all these meetings these
company that capable of building these
things in the out ocean floor if this
pass is they all foreign company it's
not us company so we have no control
who's in our ocean floor and God forbid
if there's a World War 3 breaking out
they blocking our entrance into our
region we going to be doomed doesn't
matter what party of we are from so I'm
here to support this bill to please get
rid rid of this wind thing because it's
not green it kill a lot of sea creatures
and ocean creatures and that's cruel and
that is something we want to teach our
children in school that we care not just
for the human being we care for all
creature that we coexisting together
thank you so much okay thank
you see no questions I'll turn the floor
over to the last presenter on this bill
and that's John Gage of Windam Mr Gage
you have 2 minutes 30
seconds thank you chairman Vose and
committee for taking my testimony today
um so I want to start off with a thank
you chairman Vose for agreeing to invite
the state climatologist to an
informational hearing to your committee
um I'm here today because I'm worried
about global warming and I hope
everybody will go to nasa. climate.gov
um to learn about the scientific
consensus about a pollution problem we
have um we do need a diverse energy
Supply um and wind offshore wind has a
lot of local benefits as the New
Hampshire State coordinator of citizens
climate Lobby I lobed Congress for the
ryy ACT uh last fall um this is to to
use Revenue sh sharing for offshore wind
generators uh to help the local
communities um with the rising Seas as
well as the industrial impact of uh any
energy development no
energy Supply and no energy source is
without problems um wind certainly has
some e environmental problems um but
comparing that to the environmental
problems we suffer from fossil fuels um
um if you're worried about warming water
uh We've added so much greenhouse gas um
in the air that there's two watts per
meter of warming across the whole
surface of the Earth this is warming the
oceans way more than some cooling of
wind turbines could ever manage um
remember you're here to talk about House
Bill 682 so 682 I think is part of a
three bill um war on wind power that is
um that we're talking about today uh
wind power is one we we use what 2% of
our energy comes from wind the
Netherland gets 24% of its power from
wind how do they do that well they only
use 38% uh gas power are they more
Innovative than us no they do things
like generate hydrogen with the extra
power that comes from wind that they can
then use to generate electricity during
that down times um there's local jobs at
stake it takes a long time to deploy
offshore wind and our our other states
are investing in that now and I think we
need to continue um what was decided
last year uh to make an investment uh
for Workforce training and to prepare
for offshore wind
um okay thank you for your
testimony see no questions I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
682 and we will immediately open a
public hearing on House Bill
dfn and if she is here I will call
Representative Kelly Penza to introduce
this
legislation and M Penza I need a pink
card oh you have one great thank you
you have five minutes to introduce this
legislation to us thank
you thank you Mr chair and for the
record my name is representative uh
Kelly Penza straford District 19
uh Rochester Wards 1 2 3 4 and
six um I filed this bill because I've
been following this subject for the last
couple years and have um been literally
out of my mind um with the level of no
information disinformation covered up
the truth in regards with all of this um
no one seems to be listening there's you
know our mainstream media hasn't um
hasn't really covered all of the harms
um you know the horrible disaster of
course that took place in
Nantucket uh did definitely um pull back
the curtain on this industry but now um
now it's even more um now it's even more
at the Forefront I just wanted to first
start off my testimony with um the
basically we have an executive order
right now so it's temporary withdrawal
of all areas on the outer continental
shelf from offshore wind leasing in
review of the federal government's
Leasing and permitted practicing for
wind projects the Gulf of main project
that is owned by federal waters this um
executive action uh emergency order uh
takes place so you know thank God for
the administration doing
that so one the reason why we ban this
in New Hampshire is environment m al in
Wildlife protection offshore wind
projects threaten and kill and are
killing marine life Wheels Dolphins fish
populations bottom dwellers and so on
through noise pollution habitat
destruction and increased vessel traffic
studies suggest offer winds wind farms
are dis um are actually disrupting
migratory bird patterms they lead to
higher bird fatalities uh the underwater
noise and electromatic fields from
cables interfere with marine species
navigation and breed and breeding
um literally they are just disoriented
and look and can drive uh um swim
themselves right into boats and all of
that but the most important thing which
um a previous testimony was talked about
was literally dumping millions of
gallons of toxic chlorine bleach into
the ocean that is absolutely pure
Insanity economic and job impacts
offshore wind is heavily riing on
government subsidies uh it's placing
financial burden on taxpayers without
guaranteed long-term economic benefits
that's clear it doesn't produce anything
what we need it to produce for it to be
of value it's pretty much all harm
Coastal communities depend on tourism um
and unsightly offshore wind farms of
course can negatively impact property
values and visitor rates but it's really
not about the look and feel it's about
if we're going to destroy our entire Sea
Coast in New
Hampshire uh fishing industries suffer
from restricted access Trad traditional
fishing areas reducing local jobs in
food supply chains I will provide this
committee with my testimony and then the
testimony of the fishermen in
Massachusetts because they have dredged
those cables all along the bottom of the
ocean and they are destroying muscles
and oysters and all of that
harvesting National Security risks
offshore wind farms interfere with the
military radar surveillan systems and
Naval operations potentially
compromising National Security if
something happens if that Gulf if that
Gulf of um Gulf of main projects goes on
which by the way they are not dredging
they are floating cables never been done
before um and someone let's say for
example a fisherman is out there uh and
they're caught anywhere near that we
can't even have our Naval come in there
and and help them huge security
issue um there's cyber security concerns
regarding foreign made wind bines
particularly those manufactured by of
course adversarial
Nations and energy and reliability cost
concerns when when energy is
intermittent unreliable requiring backup
energy sources often fossil fuels
undermining its environmental benefits
offshore wind is significantly more
expensive than other energy options with
maintenance cost Skyrock due to harsh
Marine
conditions and of course Energy prices
may rise due to the high cost of
building and M maintaining offshore wind
farms there are a lot of alternate
Energy Solutions as you this committee
well knows instead of offshore wind
Investments should be directed toward
more stable and less harmful Energy
Solutions such as nuclear power
geothermal energy and advancements in
energy storage as well as
Hydro onshore wind and solar is non in
non-sensitive areas um can provide
renewable energy without disrupting
marine life in coastal economies but
that still is even up for debate at this
point that's
it excellent questions for the
representative representative Swanson
has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Penza uh I I've never
heard of the thing about uh the
windmills offshore wind dumping chlorine
bleach into oceans is that what you said
can you provide a source or reference
for that the previous the previous um
speaker the fisherman told you that it's
all in their documents through Bal and
um no OAA I'll provide you that that's
how they he's explained how they clean
out the cooling systems I I'm looking
for a reference like a technical
document okay I'll provide that thank
you thank
you representative Wendy Thomas has a
question oh sor thank you Mr chair um
thank you representative for being here
um on page two of this bill you talk
about fines $50,000 fines for each day
actually um
misdemeanor misdemeanors and felonies um
my question is how did you come up with
these penalties and what's what are the
specific charges that you're you're uh
implying
here okay um I can point you to uh line
page two line uh
two uh line 11 and line
13 so once the if this bill passes
anyone that is proceeding to um move
forward with this this is a um a
multi-trillion dollar industry so um
nationally and and actually really
globally so I think that they could
afford that amount I worked with OS on
it and that's what we came up with for
people that are going to violate um
moving forward on something that is
against state law follow up follow up
thank you um and I um am very interested
in lines 14 and 15 on page two that says
if illegal offshore wind activities have
caused environmental harm or disruption
The Violator shall be held financially
responsible and required to restore the
affected area or take corrective action
did you confer with Dees and if so what
is the specific methodology because
we're trying to get a company in marac
to clean up after their mess and we're
not having great
success well because there is no
offshore wind activity currently um that
is that's just there basically if
somebody moves forward or if it moved
forward um so I want that in there just
because it's we're not going to be able
to get into specifics at this point um
I've done a lot with this bill at this
point which was I think um what we could
do at this time um it's just basically
saying that they would be held
financially responsible so for example
let's say the we'll use Nantucket as an
example that if that's causing uh the
city or the town of Nantucket you know
millions of dollars for the cleanup and
all of that that the offshore wind
company would be held responsible for
all of those damages for all to clean
up further questions representative
Bernardi has
one thank you chairman
uh you uh indicated uh their are
National Security risks and that
potentially the Navy cannot assist a uh
someone who is uh in trouble near the
near a windmill yeah the Coast Guard so
okay the Coast Guard not the Navy
yes um and is is this also uh is it your
understanding that that the cable areas
and the windmills areas would be uh
foreclosed for Naval uh uh Transit and
potentially you know submarines would
also be foreclosed from uh certain areas
there yes they would because it's
floating and those are still moving and
we don't have we have nothing to base it
on at this point cuz the ones that there
um have not been used and just if you
think about weather alone uh hurricane
bad weather we it's just it's crazy to
think that we'd be putting floating
cables in a place that could be so
volatile for different weather patterns
thank you representative R answer a
question thank you Mr chairman um
representative Penza you your testimony
consist consisted of a lot of
citation of the many dangers and horrors
of potential um offshore wind I just
wondering have you ever visited Block
Island and seen the 11 existing wind
turbines that are within sight off the
coast of that summer vacation Hot Spot
no I have not but I've visited Virginia
where they are um installing offshore
wind I lived in Chesapeake for a couple
years my girlfriend lives on Virginia
Beach um and they are the people are
trying to fight it there but it is
unbelievable what they are doing there's
our dredging because of course there's
our um you know pylon into the ocean
floor which that parsus alone um
destroys Wildlife it the sound all of
that so so but no I haven't been to what
you're talking about I've been to
Virginia though thank
you representative McGee has a question
thank you and thank you representative
Penza for taking my question um you
testified that that the flo the proposal
for floating in uh the Gulf of main
floating floating uh wind turbines is
untested and hasn't been done before are
you familiar with high wind in Scotland
because there is a there is a project
where they're using
floating um wind turbines no I'm not
familiar but I'm I'm talking about the
United States not not Scotland and if
you look kind of what's going on with
internationally they're shutting down
all of their wi projects too as well
pretty much I don't think Scotland is so
I don't I don't want I don't know about
Scotland but I know most of them are
getting shut down yeah and we have an
executive order that says no more wind
so I think we should follow it in New
Hampshire okay seeing no more questions
we'll move on whoops there is another
question representative
Swanson so uh thank you Mr Mr chair uh
thank you representative uh just uh
little further clarification uh I think
you mentioned some uh national security
issue or whatever but my understanding
is that any offshore wind would have to
be be permitted by the federal
government and there would be a thorough
uh vetting process and cost benefit
analysis and uh are you saying that the
federal government would permit
something that would be deleterious to
our defense
yes I am um the previous administration
I believe yeah and this been going on
for a long time so this isn't a a
partisan thing um there was a lot of
people that really weren't paying
attention and under big huge thousand
page bills under the the guise of green
energy which I'm all for protecting the
environment I'm on environment and
agriculture I do it all the time so that
I don't have any problem with that the
reason why an executive order has just
been put in place
whatever the date of that was um a week
and a half ago or so is because of the
damage that they're causing and there
hasn't been enough due diligence we are
talking about the other rep uh the other
person that spoke the amount of money
that are pouring into these um
organizations and all of that that would
have be hard against this are turning a
blind eye because they're taking in
millions of dollars and um and yeah and
we don't have
everything that we're doing here in New
Hampshire Banning past poos all of that
kind of stuff none of these are none of
these are good for the environment and
then just where we would even put these
blades just like the same thing that we
have problems with solar panels in you
know you can't recycle all of them in
the toxic you know chemicals that come
from it so there hasn't been a lot of
things that are thought out um there's
been a lot of money that's gone around
and that's why we're in this this mess
that we're in thank you represent and
thank you Mr God uh representative Wendy
Thomas before you ask your question I
just remind you that we have 15 pink
cards of people who want to testify on
this bill um thank you Mr chair just a
clarification on this bill um and
representative I really respect your
your Devotion to the environment and
your your will to protect um our our
oceans and our land um but I'm a little
confused about what appears to be the
second part of this bill which is to um
establish a renewable energy fund can
you can you just walk me through that
that
part where is that it starts uh page two
it starts down at line um uh
189 or actually
19 none of that is 24th starts on 24th
sorry okay that's not part of my bill
that is already
statute oh so you're just removing okay
all right thank you very
much okay seeing no further questions
we'll next call
Representative
um
Matthew
saor from seab
Brook and representative will give you
two minutes 30 seconds is that
fair thank you chairman FKS and members
of the committee again representative
born D Schwaner from sebr um you so I
spoke before I'll I'll go into another
aspect of uh these this wind technology
so so one thing that you can't change
about the wind technology even if we
were to actually um improve the product
in the future is the effect of wind on
the ocean the wind plumes themselves so
I know that they do have I know um I
think one of the representatives here
mentioned um a wind farm out by Scotland
I know that there there's already a wind
farm in the North Sea in in in England
right now and what they're experiencing
is sediment plumes being kicked up and
what does this mean for our food
Securities so in in our ocean food chain
it starts off with the phytoplankton and
then the zoo Plankton which feeds off
the phytoplankton and Then followed by
the fish and shellfish larve that will
you know eat the zoo Plankton um
phytoplankton feeds off of sunlight and
the sediment plumes that are kicked up
by the wind uh by wind tabes will
actually uh douse the upper it will
bring shade too H throw it will throw
shade to the upper layers of the ocean
that the very bottom of the food chain
relies on uh the phytoplankton um were
basically pulling the rug out from
underneath the ocean food chain just
wanted to throw that out there for you
guys about some of this technology
so okay an important Point any questions
for the
representative seeing none next we'll
call on representative Abul Khan to get
his perspective on this rep on this leg
legislation two and a half minutes okay
yeah thank
you thank you Mr chairman again a member
of the board uh thank you for hearing my
testimony I am in support of this bill
uh Mr chairman uh coming out of the
campaign and our campaign is a long
campaign you know it starts very early
on we do our primary we do our regular
campaign and every time I went to you
know knocking many many people asked me
about these questions and um I I didn't
have a you know clear answer that what
what is going to be until um the we
heard that executive order last week
thanks to the current Administration
that they uh doing this for our state
you know is going to get a big benefit
out of this Mr chairman New Hampshire
has only I mentioned New Hampshire has
only 177 miles we don't don't have 117
miles just 17 miles and if you drop
those 17 miles you will see how pristine
it is you know you know it cannot be
changed with anything else it's so
beautiful and these companies out of
state it's not even out of state out of
countries companies they are here to
destroy our way of life the way we live
here this is no good for our New
Hampshire for the future generation and
everything the way we killed the other
project you know from the hydro project
from Canada we need to kill it the same
way you know for for our future
generation so I'm urging uh all the you
know the Committee Member for us please
vote with our bill and you know show our
next Generation that we are with them
and we're going to live the way we found
New Hampshire and we're going to leave
it better than that thank you Mr
chairman I'm ready to take any other
question
question okay thank you questions for
representative
KH seeing none we'll call up next Megan
Stone from the Department of energy to
get the Department's take on this
legislation and I believe the department
just supplied us today an updated fiscal
note for this bill is that
correct um I have not seen one today but
I also haven't opened my computer in a
while so not entirely sure yes we did
receive one we have we have a copy up
here okay um so good morning again Mr
chair and members of the committee uh my
name is Megan Stone legislatively is on
with the Department of energy um the
department is neutral on House Bill 575
but we do have some concerns with the
language um the bill implements SE
several changes that fall under the
Department's purview it abolishes the
office of offshore wind industry
development and energy Innovation
including its funding source however the
bill retains the statutory duties of the
Court ordinator of nuclear development
but provides no funding or Staffing to
support those duties it repeals the
offshore wind industry Workforce
Training Center committee and the
offshore port and development commission
um the department has no concerns
regarding this section and similar
language is also found in um House Bill
682 which we heard this morning um as
written the prohibitions in this bill
would make it all but impossible for the
Department to defend the state's
interests in Regional energy matters as
it relates to Offshore wind development
in the Gulf of mime if the committee
wishes to deemphasize the state's
involvement in offshore wind in the Gulf
of Maine while still safeguarding the
state's interest the department believes
the language contained in House Bill 682
from this morning um is preferable and
I'm happy to take any questions
questions for the Department
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um if I'm reading this right
you're saying uh for the fiscal note
that the department would save
$220 because an ad administrator and a
utility analyst would be as eliminated
that is correct however when I asked you
earlier the impact of removing the the
wind uh Department you said there would
be and I'll have to find My Notes but
there's a director and an analyst they
would not there would be no impact so
which which is it correct um the bill
this morning did not remove the entire
office just the offshore wind duties of
that office so those two positions
remain this Bill removes the entire
office so it would remove those two
positions with
it thank you for that clarification
further questions Vice chair Thomas uh
thank you Mr chair um just a comment and
uh from the previous uh representative's
comments for the record uh I believe I
heard
$220 it's actually
$220,000 yes my error thank you okay
seeing no further questions for the
Department we'll next call on Michael
Lata of eversource to give us the
utilities perspective on this
legislation good morning Mr
Lata next up will be Lisa lenos good
morning uh Michael Lata representing
eversource energy I'll be brief uh
appreciate the opportunity to come and
testify before you today uh eversource
is opposed to this
legislation uh we know in the past the
committee has discussed and received
numerous Pres presentations on the
projected increases in electri
electricity usage uh regionally New
Hampshire has pursu pursued a technology
neutral market-based approach to its
energy strategy and we believe a blanket
prohibition as called for under this
bill on one technology is inconsistent
with that approach we believe that
each sorry about that uh we believe that
each proposed project regardless of
Technology should be evaluated based on
their individual merits through a
thorough permitting review if projects
are determined to be uneconomic or have
unacceptable environmental impacts those
projects should not proceed but again we
do not support a blanket prohibition on
even considering projects such as
offshore wind and with that I'd be happy
to answer any questions that I
can questions for Mr LC representative
McGee has one thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr Lata for coming here today
um we heard earlier that there's no
energy type that is perfect um in terms
of uh damage or uh Downstream
impacts uh I'm looking at the only
existing floating uh wind turbines in
the world I'm looking at their project
literature and I don't see anything here
about um bleaches being used there's a
section on lubricants and liquids so I I
guess where I wanted to um what I
noticed about this is they have a
decommissioning plan they have um an
assessment for harm to Wildlife it seems
like this these things can be done
poorly or they can be done well but um
my question is are we better off being
involved in the process so that we're
aware of what's going on offshore rather
than closing the doors and closing our
eyes um to not understanding what's
going on without our
participation thank you representative
um you know I I can't speak to any
specific project uh what I would say is
that if projects are developed within or
proposed within the uh Gulf of Maine uh
we believe that they should be subject
to rigorous
environmental uh permitting and if the
environmental impacts or economic
impacts of those proposals are
unacceptable whatever technology or
whatever specific um uh details of those
projects are then they should not
proceed thank you thank you
representative Bernardi has a quick
question thank you Mr chair so uh if you
accept the fact as uh representative
Harrington uh testified earlier this
morning that in order to have wind Mills
in the uh ocean we need 12 GW of backup
power isn't that already enough to say
no it's unacceptable we can't afford
this our view is that uh offshore wind
could be one component of an overall
resource mix and I again each individual
project should be uh evaluated on its
own merits and obviously there are
challenges as this committee is well
aware uh from numerous presentations by
groups like ISO New England on future
growth and the resources required to um
to meet that so each technology has its
own benefits and its own
drawbacks okay seeing no further
questions I want to thank Mr Lata and
call next Miss Leisa Lisa
lenos uh who is an expert on wind and we
haven't seen you in a while here but
welcome back thank you Mr chairman I
appreciate that um uh for the record my
name is Lisa lenos I've been resident in
the state of New Hampshire and have
spent the last 20 years evaluating
investigating the impacts and costs of
industrial scale wind energy uh for the
last 5 years I've been focused almost
entirely on offshore wind working with
Michael shenberger whom you might know
um I'm fully in favor of this
um bill as as in favor of the bill prior
as well um I had three suggestions I
wanted to make with regard to the bill
the first is if HB 219f does not secure
sufficient support to phase out our RPS
I suggest you add language stating that
the offshore win is not eligible for
class one treatment and that way there
would be no mechanism in St statute
where offshore wind can be recognized by
the state and subject to our subsidies
second I'd encourage adding language to
the bill that would explicitly prohibit
the state of New Hampshire from
mandating or approving utility
negotiated long-term power purchase
agreements for offshore win in this way
New Hampshire rate payers will not incur
the cost of projects
um and in any way um
that feed into even those that feed into
the regional grid so if a project is
built offshore
Massachusetts a utility here chooses to
buy some of that energy albe all of it
has been all of it that's under
construction is already on contract with
out with other utilities we do not want
the cost to be borne by New Hampshire
rate payers and finally while I'm not
sure if this is possible but if a
project is proposed that falls within
the state's ocean view shed but is on
shored onto into Maine or new or
Massachusetts I encourage adding
language that the state would discourage
any positive consistency review under
RSA
specific it is entirely consistent for
the state to establish limits on
Technologies it does not choose to
impose on the state of New Hampshire um
with that I'm happy to take any
questions could you elaborate for me
please on your last point about a
discouraging
viewshed I didn't quite understand what
you meant by that let me make that more
clear so right now there are no leases
at the Bureau of ocean Energy Management
has not identified any leases within the
Gulf of ma of Maine that are will cause
a wind project to be built within our
viewshed as far as I'm
aware if a project if a lease area is
proposed in federal waters adjacent to
New Hampshire Waters what happens is it
goes through a federally um required
consistency review the state will go
through that process where we identify
as a state whether or not that project
if it falls in this case I'm saying if
it's within the viewshed meaning it's
anywhere from 20 to 25 miles offshore or
closer we will go through a process of
identifying whether or not there are any
issues with that project in terms of
impacts on our tourism impacts on our
fishing industry impacts on other
industries that are ocean that rely on
the ocean as well as the environment and
if there's any way to put language into
the bill that discourages any positive
consistency review if the state of New
Hampshire says we don't want this
project because it's going to cause
problems with the environment Pro
problems with our fishing industry
problems with tourism and dramatically
reduce our economic opportunities that
are not that exist today and maybe
impact it we could tell the federal
government we don't support that project
and that's what I'm talking about but I
don't know if such language can be put
into the bill and leave that to the
attorneys okay thank you for helping me
understand that I appre appreciate that
questions for M
lenos representative McGee has one thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question so you mentioned that you
wanted to be sure that the one of the
points that you made that the state of
New Hampshire wasn't responsible for the
the
cost um if other states in the region
decide to go forward with the project
and I'm reminded that and I wonder if
you could speak to this that uh uh when
we when we opted
to uh invest Less in Renewables as a
sector of our energy
portfolio we have received increased
Transmissions cost attributed to New
Hampshire because we're not investing at
the same rate as as our neighbor States
so I I I wonder if you could speak to
how you think we could be um protected
from the cost
if the region goes forward and we decide
to opt out I think there might be some
penalties and I'm afraid we would end up
paying either way we just wouldn't
necessarily have any benefits yeah thank
you for that question because that's a
very important point the projects that
are under construction today Vineyard
win and Revolution win off the coast of
Massachusetts in Rhode Island are under
contract with utilities in Massachusetts
Rhode Island and Connecticut those are
the only two contracts only two projects
right now that feed will feed energy
into the New England region those are
above Market long-term contracts
anywhere from 15 years to to 20 years I
believe I don't remember the exact but
anyway it's 15 and above years the cost
of the that above market cost that the
will only be borne by the rate payers in
Massachusetts Rhode Island and
Connecticut to the extent that they are
buying the energy so we're talking about
15 roughly 1500 megaw that whatever that
generates the only people paying for
that electricity are the rate payers of
Massachusetts Rhode Island and
Connecticut we will not bear any of that
cost as because our utilities are not
buying that
energy now there is a separate cost that
I believe you're talking about and and
representative Harrington discussed it
as well and that is as more and more
intermittent regen generation is built
in the region there's going to be have
we're going to have to build grid
additional grid infrastructure
to support reliability and resilience of
our grid system okay and those costs
will likely be socialized by the iso New
England and we will all bear those costs
so as more and more intermittent
generation is built within the New
England region
we will all bear a heavy cost because of
that in order to make sure our lights
turn on when we turn the switch on
because we cannot always rely on weather
Reliant weather dependent resources but
one last point in terms of the
transmission generally the transmission
cost that is intended to
support renewable energy built in the
outer reaches of Maine and New Hampshire
to go down into Massachusetts we should
not be bearing that cost that is
generally considered an economic cost
not a reliability cost those
transmission projects should actually be
borne by the developer and the state
that's supporting them not by the New
England region generally unfortunately
there's been a tendency to say well
we're all going to benefit by renewable
energy so let's just socialize it but so
far I don't I don't Herington may know
better I don't believe any of those
projects have been socialized this's the
one coming on down through Maine that I
believe Massachusetts was going to cover
the cost I'm not sure where that stands
right now did that answer your question
okay representative Swanson has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
ma'am um the uh ISO New England provided
us a slide a little while ago and uh
I'll just say what the caption said and
if you want you can get some more
information from them it's a they said
Market select the most cost effect cost
efficient resources to meet current and
future electricity needs I keep hearing
statements that uh investment in Wind
sources is going to make things cost
more whereas we have a system in place
that will select and encourage the
lowest cost and I canot cannot imagine
anybody investing in a generation
capability that's not going to be
profitable and cost effective and
competitive with the other sources that
are in the market but is are you saying
otherwise no what I'm saying is if we
really were operating a true
market-based generation system here
meaning you build a gas you're you're a
merchant plant you build your gas plant
in New Hampshire because you will make
money selling the energy into the grid
that is a market decision that a private
developer will make and recoup the cost
of his Capital cost and make money by
selling the energy that's not what's
happening with wind energy and
particularly not happening with offshore
wind offshore wind is getting built in
New England New York New Jersey all up
and down the East Coast because the
states have said that they two fold but
the states primarily have said we're
willing to impose high costs of this
generation on our rate payers because we
believe it will solve the climate change
problem I have more to say about climate
change in my next testimony later but um
so the federal government want
particular the Biden Administration
wanted to see offsh wind built the
states Massachusetts Rhode Island and
Connecticut in particular wanted to see
wanted to meet their mandates their Net
Zero mandates for energy and as far as
they were concerned the cost was worth
it New Hampshire is not has not adopted
a net zero mandate New Hampshire has not
said we will build renewable energy at
any cost so so there's a difference
between what the market is doing and
what state in opposed mandates do and
that's what I think you those should not
be confused this we're living with State
mandated requirements for this
generation thank you Miss lenos thank
you
chair okay thank you seeing no further
questions I want to thank you for that
testimony and bring up next Sam Evans
Brown of clean energy New Hampshire whom
we have not heard from yet
today welcome Sam
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee Sam Evans Brown from clean
energy New Hampshire clean energy New
Hampshire does oppose this bill um i'
just note on a high level uh New
Hampshire specifically but also New
England more generally I think is and
has distinguished itself as being the
land of no um in my short career
watching the energy industry I've
watched us run a natural gas pipe
pipeline out of the region I've watched
us run a transmission line out of the
region and now uh I've also watched us
run terrestrial wind out of the state of
New Hampshire and now it seems like
we're poised to do the same for offshore
wind um I I'm hearing a great deal of uh
techno certainty from the testimony the
idea that wind is expensive offshore
always will be expensive and the prices
will never come down um I've watched a
couple investment Cycles in offshore
wind I was very bullish uh in the sort
of n 2019 2020 time frame when we were
seeing offshore wind Tenders in Europe
in the $80 a megawatt hour range which
would be very competitive in New England
um these are very Capital intensive
projects and so with interest rates
Rising uh we've seen the prices go up
which is unfortunate I do I do uh share
concerns about the direction of the
industry r large but I don't see that as
a reason to prohibit the the technology
as a whole so uh certainly there are
concerns about cost shifting I would
just note uh when it comes to ISO New
England Market design we' heard a great
deal about what the impact of more and
more intermittent Renewables on on those
markets will be um I I could pull uh the
numbers for folks but it's important to
point out that the energy markets which
is you know the the uh the five minute
auctions that happen every day to that
set the price of of the electricity are
the Lion's Share of the cost of what
goes into the Energy Service rates that
that we all pay uh and so saving you
know just to put it quite simply if you
save a couple billion dollars on the
energy markets but see uh the capacity
markets go up by by a small amount as
long as the savings on the energy side
are pay are paying for the increase in
the capacity side um then your your
bills go down so uh it's not a given
that that having the more intermittent
Renewables on on the grid will result in
in our bills going up um and as several
speakers have pointed out these projects
are being supported by other states uh
economically so uh New Hampshire rate
payers are not seeing those costs on our
bills so uh it it's um it's I think
unfortunate to hear that sort of uh
fearmongering um but I think it's not a
given that that rates are going to go up
as a result of these projects coming
online um I don't really have much more
to say I I'm sure there's plenty of
other folks uh who will come after me
who who can speak more to things but
that's what I got okay that was perfect
timing uh representative Harrington has
a question for you yeah uh you talk no
I'm not on this bill no uh you talk
about uh spending on these you know in
the other states it's state mandated
they the utility has no choice in the
matter would you like to see that same
mandate be put in New Hampshire and if
it came to your money do you or your
organization are willing to give
voluntarily invest in offshore wind with
your own money and not somebody else's
so so I don't think that's what uh the
bill in question is is about um uh clean
en New Hampshire has in the past been on
the record uh in support of of doing
offshore wind procurements I think that
if we were to if the state of New
Hampshire were to purs pursue a
procurement of offshore wind that rate
pair protections it would be important
to build those in um but that's not the
bill in front of us
today any additional questions
representative McGee yes thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
today Mr Evans Brown um so
as I hear all the people who've
testified on this bill so far the
question that comes to my mind is um
whether or not the state of New
Hampshire is looking to save money now
versus later um I think a lot of times
when we hear testimony it's very easy
for us to say we don't want to spend the
money because we're basically Frugal and
uh most people agree with that I think
the difference between us and the folks
uh in the states around us is that they
their mandate are coming from a
recognition that they will probably have
to pay a lot more money later for the
damage that will be coming as a result
of continued overdependence on fossil
fuels so it's there's a diversity
question that they're trying to meet
with their policies that we are not to
be making a speech representative trying
to clarify the question so so the
question is really on the on the balance
between pay now pay later um you have a
lot of expert you've been uh covering
energy for a long time and I guess the
question is are we do we do ourselves
any favor as a state to ignore the
long-term costs that uh appear to be
looming if we don't diversify or get
serious about having a plan of how we're
going to meet energy needs in the future
because we don't have one uh so so I
think I maybe I'll I'll uh try to answer
that question with uh and see if see if
I can I can land the plan here
um generally speaking we have pursued a
path of of restructuring of our electric
electric Industries whereby the the bulk
power sector has been deregulated and
operates according to markets um and and
everything else is still is still
operating under sort of a regulated cost
of service model um what we have seen is
that that deregulation has resulted in
costs going down in all the sectors in
which in which markets uh are are
allowed to function
um and so broadly I think that policy
has has worked uh it's important I think
for policymakers as they look at how
those markets are working to realize
that those markets were designed with a
certain set of techn Technologies as as
the assumed generation portfolio and and
the latest you know ISO New England is
currently talking about redesigning its
capacity market and when you look at the
papers the the white papers where they
talk about that redesign one of the
things that they point out is that the
threeyear Ford capacity Market auction
design structure was created because it
took about three years to build a
natural gas combined cycle turbine uh
and that we live in a different world
now in which there's a great more
diversity in in fuel sources that are
being brought into into the markets and
so there needs to be a recognition of do
we need to change the market design um
all that is to say that I think there
are are huge questions here regarding do
do the current market paradigms that
we're operating under actually serve us
given the technological world that we
live in um and are they providing for
the fuel diversity that is going to
result in the lowest long-term costs to
rate payers all around New England
that's a huge question um and I don't
think that we that we do ourselves any
service by by saying one technology is
just going to be simply cut out as one
of the options which I think is what
we're talking about
today okay seeing no more questions I
want to thank Mr Brown for being here
and call next on Rob Werner who
testified earlier for
the league of conservation voters I
believe it
was I will be very brief um thank you
again Mr chairman members of the
committee Rob wner State chair League of
conservation voters in New England rer
wi
Coalition um sitting here thinking to
paraphrase Thomas Hardy uh New Hampshire
is not an island we're part of a grid we
are part of a uh economic uh region a
vibrant economic region in New England
there's a lot of supply chain aspects of
offshore wind that's been built that are
in operation and I just think that it's
very shortsighted to pursue legislation
such as this to uh pick winners and
losers essentially in terms of an
industry I thought that the sense of a
lot of policy makers in our in our
current government is not to pick winner
and lers but that's EXA ly what we're
doing here so I I am very opposed to
this bill and we as an organization are
very opposed to this bill partly for
that reason but also the larger sense of
I think we need as I had said before we
need to stay engaged in this project and
in these discussions yes there are
challenges yes there are questions that
need to be answered yes there's a lot
more research to be conducted to get to
those answers but to Simply turn our
back and walk away I don't think is the
answer
okay thank you very
much seeing no further questions for Mr
wner we'll Now bring
up Jerry Leman from the New England
Fisherman's stewardship Association of
South Portland
Maine good morning and welcome good
morning thank you Mr chair and fellow
committee
members uh I am Jerry Leman the CEO of
the New England fisherman stewardship
Association we represent roughly around
th000 members of our Coastal communities
these are wild Harvesters everywhere
from your high water mark to the e um to
touch on a few points um representative
Swanson asked about the discharge of the
chlorinated heated water you can find
that on Sunrise wind appendix
N2 um that also talks about a 40%
capacity that's at 81. 8.1 million
gallons per day discharged at 86 to 90
in their own appendix it also states
that it's 100% mortality to Plankton now
if you go talk to the Northeast Science
Center we've also in witness it over the
last two and a half decades that
Plankton levels in the New England
region are in Decline which is directly
why we oppose offshore wind at this
moment it's not the fact that any
Fisherman's against going green it's the
fact it's basics in navigation if you
don't know where you are you don't know
where you're going we have not done
enough proper research the EMF effect
there's been acoustic studies from the
Norway from alisandra Cressy showing
that EMF can directly affect larvel
statuses of our juvenile fish stocks
causing them to lose vertical swimming
EMF effects also on Lobster carasses
which is the majority of your Lobster
fishery here in the state of New
Hampshire that also shows that not only
the eye sockets the carrasses and the
vertical swimming are directly inclined
now to get the procurement of the power
back towards Shore you know what was
talked about today by the site analysis
of the distance it's well over 50
nautical miles to get back here to shore
which is going to make you have to use
DC cables at a 400 megawatt capacity so
for every gwatt you're talking at least
three cables space 200 to 500 yards
apart with a 6x6 dredging that 1,200
gallons per minute with 100% mortality
to all juvenile life that comes in
contact with and as we get closer to
shore to the geology is the granite
we'll be putting concrete structures
over the cables which was going to be
creating habitat for lobsters to crawl
up under to get direct
EMF which will directly affect your
Lobster fishery now the Rosa the
responsible offshore science Alliance
also just did at the Cooperative
research Summit in Portland Main last
week showing research that the pile
driving noises coming from the sunr
vineyard wind and down that way had a
third scale operation done inside of a
harbor was showing the Clappers on the
scallops which that means it's stressing
the scallops that was at the 1/3
scale we do not have enough information
to outline what directly is going to
happen to the impact Isis committee met
at Rhode Island earlier last summer what
was mentioned was the United Kingdom and
everybody was there is we directly know
we're changing the ocean but to what
extent we have no idea we are literally
leaping before we look which is a direct
reason why we take a pause every
fisherman in the world will tell you the
same thing if you don't know where you
are you don't know where you're going
and as well I got to talk about the
Leading Edge erosion so particulates in
our air freeze during the weather
variabilities while the speed of these
wind blades cause Leading Edge erosion
those Nano particulates end up in the
water column while Nano our phytoplank
it mistakes that is forage which ends up
working our way into the food chain
which is endo disruptors causing
reproductive harms not only to satti
animals but humans as
well I can go on and on but uh the noise
pollutants again and not to mention when
we have the nor Easter nobody has yet to
talk about the parasitic drain these
things will still require power that's
why there's 5,500 gallons of diesel
capacity on here because they will have
to go into shutdown mode or otherwise
they could be destroyed and yet we have
not done any real hurricane force winds
the center The Vineyard wind blade was a
356 ft blade that was tested in an
environmental chamber at 300 ft it was
not a complete survey but as we saw in
July when we lost the wind as everybody
must have seen on the news all these
particulates floating up on all these
wind beaches from New York to Road
Island across Massachusetts that was
only 6% of the
blade in two months that was recovered
so just IM imagine what happens when
multiple blades fail now we just saw
what the devastation and the cost
analysis for that cleanup was just for
6% 94% of it was still intact on the
ocean floor which sat there for months
before it was retrieved and yet we have
no
data data or analysis on any of the
fiberglass or those micronutrients
getting into the wild forage and how
that affects the health of the community
of the wild bystanders you the American
public it's a natural resource that
belongs to every one of us and the fact
that we could be contaminating our last
wild protein it's just
unconscionable well thank you I noticed
that you had some notes you were reading
from do you have written testimony that
you could Supply To Us by any chance yes
I can draft you up the the written
testimony and give you all of the data
from all the research um like I said
this is all stemming from the Bureau of
ocean energy management and the last
thing I will state is during the federal
process for the lease agreements for the
Gulf of main the science center openly
filed at the federal registry openly
admitting we have no Baseline data in
the Gulf of Bain which is a direct
meaning we do not know where we
are so you can provide us links to
information about the decline of
Plankton the EMF
effects the stresses on
scallops the quote about we know we're
changing the ocean but we don't know how
yep I will get that from Dr Andy lipsky
he's the head of the greater Atlantic
wind team and for the question about
high wind Tempest they were put in in
2017 and they've all had to go back to
port for major reconstruction so those
are still not tested vetted and not to
mention those are four-part anchoring
systems in the United Kingdom while
we're only being proposed three
anchoring systems per turbine here but
we do not know which model we're using
it's unvetted technology they're all
prototypes okay further
questions Vice chair Thomas has one
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question although you you may
have provided an answer but I will ask
the question anyway um I know that from
my personal experience I have seen
several of your videos that you've put
out on just what you uh uh said here
here and I believe they provided um um
background information and links and so
forth to substantiate what you were
saying have any of the uh has any of the
information that you presented in these
videos have they ever been disputed by
any uh agencies as to be
incorrect uh or and also do you believe
that any of what you've put out there
any questions have they been answered to
your satisfaction before you can proceed
forward
uh as for one a lot of folks have taken
stuff that I've said out of context and
tried to mix it but everything is
verified through peer rever
peer-reviewed research not only from the
science and statistical committees but
from the science center alone who is
retrieving all of our data for the New
England region they also set the
allocations for the fishing fleet as
well and the fact that during covid we
did no data research at all no surveys
were done we have no Baseline so the
fact that the cited areas that we're
looking into the Gulf of main are in
high production use from the fishing
fleet this will push effort right out of
those regions which will end up
concentrating effort on another fishery
which will impose problems from state to
state New Hampshire is not out of the
fold on this one even though these are
outside your state waters the impacts
will directly come back to
you additional questions representative
uh spear
thank you uh you went over very quickly
so I just wanted to make sure I
understood uh got the name the name of
the company that says that they're still
using chlorine chlorinated water it's in
the it's in the appendix N2 on Sunrise
wind project this was flagged to me by
Doug Crystal lead policy analyst from
Noah Sunrise wind wind okay thank
you okay further
questions seeing none I want to thank
you for testifying thank you and ask
Ward burn to come back and give us uh
his take on this
bill 2.5 minutes please two minutes 30
seconds five minutes two
minutes two minutes 30
seconds dear members of New Hampshire
House of Representatives we the New
Hampshire commercial fisherman
Association respect respectfully urge
you to support Bill 575 which seeks to
pres prevent construction to Offshore
wind energy and projects in the Gulf of
main as an or organization dedicated to
preserving the livelihoods of commercial
fishermen and a agricultural oper
agricultural operators in New Hampshire
we believe that the development of
offshore wind energy and our Waters is
not only harmful but
irresponsible with far-reaching negative
consequences for marine life agriculture
agriculture and commercial fishing
industry the Gul of main is a vital
ecosystem home to an array of species
that support economic and cultural
foundations for our Coastal communities
for from the abundance of cod and hack
and lobsters to the delicate habitats of
marine species and sell shellfish Farms
that contribute to our economy the
Region's Waters play a critical role in
maintaining the health of our oceans and
the economic stability of our state
offshore wind energy development as
proposed poses an undeniable risk to
these delicate balance first the
construction of the operation of
offshore wind turbines would drastically
disrupt the Marine e ecosystems and
construction process alone involves
significant seabed disturbance including
dredging and piling which could leave
devastating impacts on marine species
that depend on these habitats the noise
pollution generated by the construction
of these of of turbines and their
ongoing operation can interfere with
marine mammals and the ability to
communicate navigate and Hunt
potentially displacing them from the
critical feeding grounds the these
disturbances can lead to a decrease in
population of key species further
harming our Fisheries in a broader in
the broader Marine ecosystem
agricultural operations are at risk from
offshore wind development in New
Hampshire our shellfish Farms many of
which produce oysters and muscles rely
on clean stable water conditions to
thrive the construction of offshore wind
turbines could significantly alter the
water quality circulation patterns and
potentially leading to sedimentation
changes in the water temperature and
nutrients and nutrients imbalances such
such impacts
could undermine the health of selfish
populations reduce the productivity of
Agriculture operations and create
Financial strain and already vulnerable
industry the potential displacement of a
agricultural sites due to turbine
insulation and restricted access to
Marine areas would further limit the
viability of local farms moreover the
risk for commercial fishermen is
substantial the insulation of wind
turbines in the Gulf of Maine will
result in the loss of critical fishing
grounds restricted access to productive
areas and impose additional hazards on
vessels and Crews present in the large
scale wind will not only limit our
ability to harvest our resources the
that have sustained our families and
businesses for Generations but also pose
significant navigational and safety
risks to fishermen operating in these
Waters the livelihoods of New Hampshire
commercial fishermen agriculture op
operators and the health of the marine
ecosystems cannot be sacrificed for the
sake of un unproven and distributive
disruptive energy source while renewable
energy is important it should not not
come at the cost of marine life in
industries that rely on the Gulf of main
we believe that the state should
prioritize subst substantial practices
to protect the environment and economic
stability in the communities in closing
I will spe respectively ask that you
consider the long-term consequences of
austal wind energy development in the
Gulf of Maine and support House Bill
575 the future of Fisheries agriculture
health and oceans depend on making
responsible informed decisions that P
prioritize the well-being of our
environment who depend
on on it thank you okay thank you since
you have written testimony I assume
you'll be sending that to us I can do
that okay thank you all right let's keep
moving can I I I have one thing to say
if you could give me two seconds okay I
heard the term feir wongin you should be
scared 100% should be scared of this
thank you okay thank you so next we'll
hear from
um Eric Anderson who I think we heard
from before of Portsmouth Mr
Anderson uh good morning Mr chairman um
I I I I stand as I previously had
identified myself um I've been a
commercial fisherman for over 50
50 years
um this issue of offshore wind is is a
subject of concern today and it's been
the concern of the fishing industry
for more than five years from where I
originally you know became involved in
it and as you've heard with a variety of
testimony offshore wind has been
sold as a safe and environmental
friendly new energy source but nothing
could be found father from the truth
you've heard a variety of environmental
issues that have been presented to you
today and I hope you take take heed in
in recognizing them um many New
Hampshire fishermen have identified and
questioned a long list of environmental
issues and consequences that would
result in the Gul of main as the
development continues most of our
questions mostly all of our questions
have gone unanswered and issues are
shunned by the federal government
agencies in control of the development I
and other fishing colleagues have
responded and submitted many written
comments to the Bureau of ocean um
Bureau of energy management bom and on
every occasion when requested but the
process has continued with B recently
conducting a lease offering of over
850,000
acres to developers in the Gulf of Maine
two companies have acquired a
substantial portion of that acreage and
continue with plans to build enormous
offshore wind farms at their sites with
a power coming ashore in either New
Hampshire Maine or Massachusetts this
power would provide no economic relief
to New Hampshire rate payers as I think
some testimony has
recognized um and it would be destined
to go south into the uh into the grid um
this legisl of pth which substantially
reduce or eliminate the possibility of
that power coming ashore in New
Hampshire and either CBR or Portsmouth
those have been the two areas that have
been identified for the transmission
lines if they were to come to New
Hampshire if completed it would most
likely come assure in our neighboring
states and the same negative
environmental consequences will affect
the entire ecosystem of the gulf Comm
this legislation have passed will
represent new h e efforts and concern to
question offshore wind for any energy
benefit and show its concern for the
real negative environmental causes
consequences that will unfold in the
future thank
you okay thank
you seeing no questions we'll move along
and bring Nate Graves who's wearing a
new hat now representing the business
and industry Association to give us
their perspective on this
legislation thank you Mr chair and
members of the committee n Grace the
business and industry Association
Statewide Chamber of Commerce we oppose
this legislation I did pass out a uh
letter earlier I don't want to be
needlessly repetitive um but we have a
all of all of the above approach to
energy so we would uh prefer that the
committee not foreclose any uh potential
opportunity and I would just remind the
committee that we cannot predict what uh
future technological advances May uh
enable this particular or any particular
type of energy to uh to be more
competitive uh be more friendly towards
uh some of the concerns you heard today
I'm happy to take any questions that you
may have questions representative Wendy
Thomas thank you chair um specifically
because you are representing the
business and industry Association I'm
wondering if you could give me an idea
of the economic impact specifically to
Industry and jobs if if we forego all
wind power in in New
Hampshire I don't have industry specific
data I can certainly see if I can get
that I think generally speaking by
foreclosing a specific energy type uh
future job growth that may exist so a
future investment that may come from
other businesses would not occur because
it would not exist and it's kind kind of
hard for me to provide data about what
future jobs may exist depending on what
future Technologies May evolve
understood thank
you seeing no additional questions I
want to thank you for your testimony
written and um delivered
personally oh sorry representative McGee
thought of one thank you Mr chair for
indulging me nice to see you n um so the
question is again around um the economic
impact for businesses is I guess that
would be your bellwick right um if we
are uh Banning with a bill like this our
ability to participate in
planning um and the other states move
forward then would that be considered um
a negative impact to local businesses
and jobs because there would be a lot I
know I've seen um discussion around all
the activity that would be resulting uh
in terms of supply chain as others have
mentioned so um would would it be a
missed opportunity from the perspective
of the business and industry uh
Association if a large scale project
like that was occurring and we had no
part in it so we certainly promote um
competitive advantag just broadly is is
something that organization promotes um
one thing I would keep in mind um as you
consider this legislation and other
legislation is that you know although um
we are part of the the regional grid and
and everything um one of the major
concerns that uh industry has
particularly manufacturers is the cost
of energy here so it's not only
potential jobs uh that exist but it's
also you know within this particular
industry but it's also uh especially as
we look at uh the federal
administration's efforts to bring uh
additional manufacturing to the United
States one of the key things for our
organization is making sure that New
Hampshire is highly competitive and the
number one issue we hear from
manufacturers is the cost of energy so
when they're thinking about are we are
we going to expand the plant here in New
Hampshire we going to expand the plant
in you know Texas um one of the things
they're looking at is that energy cost
overall and so we that's why we promote
the all of the above uh solution in
order to try to lower those costs make
New Hampshire more competitive bring
more jobs
here representative Harrington has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank
take my question I'm not sure if you be
able to answer this but my concern with
the bill is that it talks about banning
infrastructure coming into New Hampshire
so that would be let's assume that we're
we're talking no one's going to build
wind within the territorial Waters so
we're talking about a federally license
facility that's more than three miles
offshore so they bring that transmission
cable in through New Hampshire does New
Hampshire have the authority to ban that
transmission cable if it's going to
provide Power let's say to Massachusetts
or is is that uh a FK
issue I think there are plenty of people
in the audience behind me who could
answer that
okay okay fire
enough okay any others no questions
seeing none I'll call next
on
Teresa fof of Canterbury New
Hampshire good morning and welcome good
morning thank you for having me um my
name is Tara federov um I um am from
kbur New Hampshire I have a farm um up
there Family Farm um and I oppose this
bill it is a continuation of the attacks
on clean energy that we are seeing from
the current federal
Administration uh I love this great
state for a lot of reasons the beautiful
Outdoors the interconnected supportive
community and the self-reliant Spirit
Granite Staters are wonderful and embody
the best of the past and all of the
promise of a more beautiful and
sustainable future through our love for
all things hyperlocal growing our own
food the farmers markets and supporting
each other but most of my friends and
neighbors and most of the residents in
this state power their homes with
damaging imported fossil fuels that make
us relyant on outside actors for
something as basic as heating our own
homes wind power allows us to embrace
our hyper local self-reliant spirit and
by not being reliant on anyone but
ourselves for our energy uh and bringing
job growth and economic prosperity to
the people of this great state imagine
how great it would be to have a
completely local reliable and affordable
power source that also ensures a livable
future for all of our kids and grandkids
and is indefinitely available the nhcap
or the New Hampshire climate action plan
states that the effects of climate
change could increase the number of days
that are over 100 degrees in New
Hampshire from one per year to 23 or
more I remember marveling if it even hit
80 here when I was a kid uh in this
future things that we love here in New
Hampshire like pond hockey ice fishing
and white Christmases could be gone
forever and I really want my kids to
have those things in their lives wind
power helps us fight against this
dystopian future decrease air pollution
and increase our power economically
making both ourselves and this be and
the Beautiful Outdoors that we are
surrounded by healthier and happier
fossil fuels did great things for our
state but they are not our future
ideally it is the job of the government
to take a Long View the CL climate
crisis will cost uh billions if not
trillions in future damages fossil fuels
damage our uh atmosphere biodiversity
and oceans through uh oil spills and
pollution and we subsidize them with
billions of taxpayer dollars every
single year certain communities in the
US can literally light their water on
fire because of fossil fuel
pollution uh there is no zero impact
energy source as many have said today
but investments in renewable energy that
is less carbon intensive now will divert
much of the economic environmental and
human costs in the future and um yeah I
really support wind and uh and renewable
energy thank you okay thank you seeing
no questions we'll move along to Julie
Potter or Porter
we have four more people who want to
testify after Miss
border
sorry
um I'm used to talking to animals not
people so bear with
me I have a farm as well and I've seen
what these things can do I'm just going
to cover a couple things right now in
Newbury port
in the industrial park there's been a
windmill there for 10 years and a couple
weeks ago it it blew blew up or bleue
gasket or whatever it did and spread
hydraulic flu because these things use
an excessive amount of fuel matter of
fact it takes energy to get them up and
running so newburry Port right now is a
Hazmat situation hydraulic fuel is all
over in radius of at least I don't know
in the industrial park and the condos
and the people are very
upset I going to Farm in Portsmith a
million years ago the head farm and John
had a windmill he shut the windmill down
so it wasn't wasn't giving him any money
at all thing was a waste so they
dismantled the
windmill just a note on the dead
citation list those are on the East
Coast primarily in New York and New
Jersey I really will send you that
list hang
on so in July this summer a 350t blade
fell off a turb and Vineyard one during
testing wasn't even up and running this
sent 60 tons of fiberglass with banol
and other psaf and a mystery foam that
is not washed up has been washing up all
over the East Coast just yesterday
another large piece of foam was found on
the beach in Nantucket the company
abandoned them the Islanders cleaned up
the foam not the company the company is
still responsible for this and they
aren't answering they're I think Dutch
company which gets me to another point
you talk about economy they're bringing
in their own people they're not hiring
our people if you really want to get
down to the Brass tax they're bringing
in ask New Bedford ask how many Union
people got hired to work on those wind
farms yes we should turn our back on
this wind
problem there are other Al Alternatives
nuclear is huge and it's up and coming
and it's clean and there there there
don't even melt melting down anymore
they're using spent rods which is huge
for me cuz I actually walked on the seab
brook occupation so now I'm actually for
nuclear my dad worked on a um there's a
generator sitting on the JIS suin bridge
and it's been ticking under there for
like 20 years and it's making energy
problem is there's no money for hydro
that thing's been sitting there and
generating energy no one will look at it
UNH is doing this it so I want you to
just in closing pay attention to the
fishermen next time you go to the
grocery store I want you to look where
your fish is coming from never mind meat
which is coming from Australia and
Brazil look at where the fish is coming
from do we really want we've done a job
on the farmers my whole life here do we
really want to do that to these
fishermen do we really want to not have
local fish do we really want to rely on
Indonesia Japan thank
you thank you seeing no questions we'll
move along and hear from quick off of
the conservation law
Foundation good morning I'm Nick cof
with the conservation law Foundation
again appreciate being here to testify
an opposition to HB
575 um this committee often says that we
shouldn't pick winners or losers for the
state's Energy Mix um but because this
build do exactly that and what cause our
state to miss out on the benefits of
offshore wind this committee should
reject the
bill offshore wind projects in the Gulf
of Maine would generate major economic
benefits for the State of New Hampshire
um there was a report recently issued by
the department of new Department of
energy New Hampshire that estimates that
a single offshore wind project in the
Gulf of Maine would generate over 3600
jobs and $800 million in benefits for
the state and that's a single 1,200
megawatt project um the other thing is
New Hampshire doesn't have much
regulatory authority over offshore wind
it's mostly Federal so the bill will not
stop offshore wind from being developed
in the Gulf of Maine meaning that Maine
and Massachusetts and not New Hampshire
receive the economic benefits of
offshore offshore wind um offshore wind
will also reduce our dependence on
imported fossil fuels with extremely
volatile prices um recent studies show
that offshore wind can also improve the
electric grids reliability that's
especially true in Winter we all know
that in winter you know offshore the
wind blows pretty consistently and
strongly and so that offshore wind can
provide um reliability benefits in
Winter um you know over the past few
years we've seen High Energy prices um
that New Hampshire families have
experienced and um this bill would make
us even more exposed to high prices from
um fossil fuel energy now one one final
point is that the bill claims that it is
necessary necessary to protect New
Hampshire's natural resources and his
Coastal and Maritime Industries um but
the process of identifying the wind
lease areas in the Gulf of Maine it was
a very thorough process and considered
all of those issues um I participated
directly in that process um I witnessed
how Federal Regulators they frequently
met with stakeholders you know
environmental organizations fishermen
other stakeholders tribes um you know
they ended up leasing areas in the Gulf
of Maine that avoid the most heavily
fished areas and the areas that are most
important for wildlife habitat um and
I've also seen in Southern New England
how Federal Regulators they require
projects to adopt strict mitigation
measures to reduce impacts even further
um for ocean users and for for wildlife
um and so for those reasons I would urge
you to reject this Bill thank
you okay thank
you representative Harrington has a
question for you thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question I'll
ask you the same question do you think
that this bill uh oversteps State
Authority in that uh the regulation of
transmission is a f jurisdictional and
would end up in court if nothing else
yeah I mean I think it could um you know
I questioned that myself and I you know
read the bill a couple times you know I
think the state probably has
jurisdiction for you know the
transmission when it comes to shore but
I think once you start trying to
regulate you know the transmission of
electric within state borders then
that's a federal issue under the federal
power act and so you know depending on
how you read the bill I'm not sure if
it's trying to prohibit the transmission
of electricity from offer within the
state but that I think would definitely
violate the
FBA okay thank you for that seeing no
further questions we'll move along to
CIA
Kelly welcome back thank you Mr chairman
um I would like to um ask everyone in
this room and all that watching to
please um Google up the word the modern
day Sil
road that is used to be in China and
that's all the traffic with the silk now
this modern day Silk
Road has been developed by the Chinese
communist government to control all the
ports and all the trans important
transportation
to control the world and has been going
on a normal citizen like me know about
it I'm sure our government should know
and I don't know why this project was
rushed by the Biden Administration to
have it auction off at the end of
October before the election to make it
legal biding and most of the people that
been up here opposing this uh bill I did
not see them attend these meetings and I
spoke to those people at the meetings
and they don't create jobs for Americans
we don't have the expertise nor
technology or capability all the
materials and M Power imported into
these projects and the second thing that
you need to know is the silk war
strategy War we have been at war with
China all these years if you need to I
can come back and give you a whole
presentation about that it's at we at
war that we don't even know that we are
at War we're losing our job our natural
resources China don't care a damn thing
about green de de whatever they destroy
the Earth they get the advantage of
economic environment everything to sell
everything cheap to us and took away all
of our job and supplies So Co remember
the vaccine they prevent those thing to
uh I mean the mask to bring back to our
country here they are planning to kill
just not just American it's the whole
world because the flag of China the big
yellow star up there with all the four
stars around that mean China rule the
whole world with
Communism they are projecting themselves
at the world leader we have to be all
under the Communist rule so if you
imagine that you have your power feeding
the and new Hampshire in the winter time
and the wires are in the ocean have you
watched what happened in Europe with all
these cable got cut off so we going to
be freezing to death relying on those
things so these people that's supporting
something that they don't even know once
you are dead or your family is dead you
have no money to
count life is important food is
important water is important National
Security is very important we are at War
we have been at War
thank you and I support this bill for
the record thank you thank
you all right let's next hear from
Meredith Hatfield of The Nature
Conservancy
thank you chairman V members of the
committee Meredith Hatfield for the
nature conservancy and I um am sending
around a testimony letter that actually
covers all three offshore wind bills
that you'll be hearing this morning um
and I do have to let you know chairman
Vose I do have to leave shortly so I
need to withdraw my pink card for the
next Bill thank you um The Nature
Conservancy in addition to our 60 years
of work on environmental issues in New
Hampshire we also have been working
globally um for more than four decades
on a range of ocean issues focused on
protecting
habitats sharing science for informed
decision-making mitigate mitigating
climate impacts and biodiversity loss
and supporting sustainable Fisheries uh
we deeply respect the fishermen um who
work so hard off of our Waters and who
also uh go out of their way to protect
and avoid um damage to many of our
important marine
species we do believe that thoughtfully
planned and cited offshore wind
development can be compatible with other
ocean issues uh we also agree that there
are many questions that remain and we I
have uh staff colleagues who are working
very hard um at every level to make sure
that the sighting is done in a sensitive
way um and that mitigation uh does take
place we agree with many of the other
speak ERS uh who have said that even if
New Hampshire doesn't want to purchase
wind energy others in the region will be
doing that and will that will result um
in uh offshore wind being built and we
think it's a mistake for us not to be at
the table to ensure that our state is
protected and that um folks like
fishermen and local communities can
benefit from mitigation funds uh the
attachment to my testimony letter which
I will send to you electronic Ally so
you have it um is a series of webinar
that we did recently on offshore wind
issues and they're all recorded on
YouTube um a couple I wanted to draw to
your attention um there was a session
these are all with um experts in various
Fields including scientists there's one
on whales in offshore wind addressing
myths and facts one about offshore wind
and birds with um two experts from aabon
looking at the both the risks and the
benefits of offshore wind to uh birds
and also um there's one on the
interactions between fish and offshore
wind thank
you thank
you representative Thomas Wendy Thomas
has a question for you uh thank you
chair um and thank you for being here um
with regard to the um the leases that
have been permitted um in the Gulf of
Maine is can you tell me is there a
standardized policy or process to robust
to robustly study the environmental
issues uh when considering offshore wind
and who is responsible for conducting
those
studies I believe yes there are rigorous
processes and I also believe that
various parties are responsible for
different aspects of it um I do know
that my colleagues who specialize in
offshore wind issues have Prov provided
comments in the various processes um
advocating for very rigorous
analysis um as Mr kof mentioned um I
believe it was him um some of the lease
areas have been tailored to try to um
avoid impacting the most critically
sensitive areas and the most um at risk
species um like endangered whales um and
we also have provided comments on um
once the turbin are deployed you know
what kind of monitoring should be taking
place um and different ways that
environmental impacts uh could be
mitigated so you know if if this is of
interest to the committee um to do a
deeper dive I'd be happy to arrange a
time for one of my colleagues to come
talk in more detail thank
you thank you see no further questions
we'll give the last word on this bill to
Mr John Gage Mr Gage you have three
minutes please uh confine your comments
to the bill
itself thank you chairman Bo and
committee um John Gage I'm speaking for
myself I oppose this bill um last
January last month was the warmest
January on
record last year was the warmest year on
record the year before that was the
second warmest year on record the last
decade has been the warmest DEC decade
on record the records go back to
1880 um so I've heard comments about
lobsters and whales about this bill uh I
grew up in Connecticut we used to go
sailing in the fish's Island Sound Off
the shore of Connecticut and there were
Lobster buoys all over the place there
are none anymore off the Connecticut
Shore because the water has warmed uh
leading to disease and death of the
lobster population there um you can sail
and fish is Island Sound without
worrying about Lobster Pot buoys anymore
um so the lobsters have moved North
where the water is cooler and out deeper
where the water is cooler uh they're not
stopping their migration because the
water is still
warming someone mentioned socialized
costs I passed out an economist
statement on carbon dividends the last
bill um statement is signed by 3,600
some us economists noting that this is
uh carbon price and is necessary to
address a failure of the market uh to
account for the social costs of the
pollution from fossil fuels and the
price of fossil
fuels um these external costs are what's
driving lobsters north um somebody
mentioned Wales whales are changing
their migration pattern because the
oceans are warming and phytoplankton
their feeding on is moving um this is
moving them into shipping lanes whales
are not getting hurt by offshore wind
whales are getting hurt by changing the
migration patterns into shipping lanes
and getting hit and also um Lobster
lines so this bill is not market-based
or technology neutral this is kind of a
hypocritical um piece of legislation to
a a group of people who who says that
that's what they're in favor of and I
account for this part two on the war on
wind power is coming from Alec uh a
fossil fuel funded organization that is
against anything that will reduce the
sale of fossil fuels um Alec is a thumb
of the fossil fuel industry pushing down
on New
Hampshire please confine your remarks to
the bill itself please sure to go to
bitly faced game to read more on that um
we should not be listening to the fossil
fuel out of state pollut industry to
determine New Hampshire's energy um
positions and the options that we choose
to take we should be going um on what
our core principles are we we need a
diverse energy Supply we should be
market-based and we should also account
for a future price on carbon and you can
learn more about that at bitly Carbon
price Gap PDF
thank you okay thank
you seeing no questions for Mr Gage I'm
going to and having no more pink cards
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill
575 F in and I will open the public
hearing on House
Bill or actually house continuing
resolution
4 and I'm going to uh given the late
hour I'm going
to take a break and we will resume this
public hearing which is now
open at
1:00 that of course will delay the
public hearings on the two following
bills House Bill 219 FN and House Bill
567 FN those public hearings will
commence immediately following the
resumed public hearing on house
continuing resolution
4 so we are now officially on break
until 1:00 see you
then
e
e e
okay everyone welcome
back I opened a public hearing on HCR 4
just before we took a lunch
break so now we're going to resume that
public hearing and I'm going to ask the
prime sponsor of
hc4 Representative and vice chair Doug
Thomas to introduce this
legislation thank you Mr chairman and
thank you and good afternoon to the
distinguished members of the Science
Tech and energy
committee my name is Doug Thomas I
represent Rockingham County 16 which is
the town of Londoner I might add it is
not a coastal town it's pretty much
Inland and I don't believe I have any
commercial fishermen departing out of
there at the time I will preface my
comment by saying that um I do not and
have not ever attended a conference from
Alec nor have I read any of their
material my comments today are from
local sources and from what I have
learned sitting on the uh offshore wind
and Port development
commission I will preface again my next
comments by making a
comment for those of you that have
watched TV a long time ago you may have
seen a commercial and the commercial
went something like this when EF Hutton
speaks people
listen I believe that the New Hampshire
fishermen are the EF Hutton of the
fishing industry and I listened and I
listened October the 28th at one of our
commission meetings when the general
public came and offered their opposition
to Offshore wind and had very little to
do with renewable energy uh Pros or cons
it had a lot to do with the ecosystem
and the dangers it presented to the
lifestyle of our
fishermen now so as I listened I
listened to people from the U New
England fisherman stward Association
which I mentioned earlier uh today which
put out some very good videos on their
concerns I know that fishmen know their
Waters best better than any government
bureaucrat that I'm aware of and I
listened and I
researched and I and I and I did I did
see pros and cons and the details from
this resolution were taken from these
pros and cons
which really says there are unanswered
questions to Offshore wind in the Gulf
of Maine and because it's in the Gulf of
Maine it affects more than just Maine
fishermen it affects New Hampshire
fishermen because they all fish in that
area and affects a lot of other
fishermen there as as as well uh
concerns are potential seabed Disturbed
from moving cables back and forth it
could affect the the ecosystem and the U
the the your food chain uh the area that
was is being cordoned off can reduce the
fishing area and also uh as you heard
earlier there is pollution from chlorine
infested warm water that is discharged
from cooling stations which is necessary
to keep those cooling stations operating
in a prime in in Prime condition now the
reason why I'm doing a resolution is
because offshore wind is in federal
territory and we cannot pass a bill that
prevents the federal government from
providing leases to in in a you know
federal waters but the
resolution has a very prant purpose one
of the Prime purposes of a of resolution
is to call attention to a pending
situation and to uh Provide support for
our
position uh it sends a powerful message
to to our Senate to our Senate okay to
our Congressional Delegation to our
governor and to uh the federal
government that New Hampshire
categorically rejects offshore wind
until and this is the key until such
questions that have been unanswered have
been completely vetted and
verified and only upon approval of the
New Hampshire
legislation so this resolution basically
says hey stop we don't want this
offshore wind to go in those Waters up
in Maine because it affects our
fishermen as well as others but there
are unanswered questions if you can
answer them satisfactory particularly to
our
fishermen then we will consider that but
until then we don't want it because
you're moving too
fast so that's my opening comments
because I had a lot more to say but a
lot more you heard previously for other
bills I would invite everyone here to
defay their questions to the people that
come here to speak afterwards because
they can speak more to the technical
aspects uh that have been spoken before
and I don't want to take up their time
doing that so with that being said um I
would prefer you delay your questions to
the people behind
me okay thank you for introducing that
legislation representative Doug
Thomas representative Wendy Thomas
insists on asking a question in spite of
your request for her not to do that
well there you go um it this is a
question specifically about the bill um
lines 22 and 23 that the general court
urges neighboring ocean states to take
similar action is that truly your intent
to tell other states what to
do it is truly my intent to call
attention to the other states that they
need to listen to their fishermen and to
think twice about putting in offshore
wind until those questions have been
completely vetted because I believe it
isn't just the New Hampshire fishermen
that have concerns it's main fishermen
and and other fishermen thank
you okay thank you for introducing this
legislation representative Thomas now we
have 10 pink cards
of people who want to testify on this
bill and many of these folks have
testified already on the previous two
bills that we heard on this
subject so I'm going to have to restrict
testimony to two minutes per person so
that we can get through this these 10
pink cards next up is representative
Abul Khan from seab Brook
thank you Mr chairman member of the
committee my name is Abul Khan as I you
know spoke before uh Mr chairman uh sebr
is proud for our fishing Heritage for
many many years long before I arrived
there SE Coast is very proud of our
fisherman and the fishing community and
Whole New Hampshire is proud for our
fishing industry
and this windmill that we all talking
about in the of the coast of New
Hampshire is going to kill our fishing
industry all together they have many
regulation last few years this is if
this happens it'll be the you know the
end of the fishing industry and we all
know that uh Mr Mr
chairman as you all know that uh
seabook uh Beach and Seabrook Coastline
owned by town of sebr taxpayers it's not
the state of New Hampshire property we
can do whatever the the taxpayer of CBR
wants so next year um uh you know next
uh election cycle the next town meeting
in 2026 we will introduce a citizen
petition that anyone cannot you know go
through a transmission line through seab
Brook you know that we will make sure me
and other St representative Matt subaran
we will bring that citizen petition you
know so we will have it on the record M
Mr
chairman New Hampshire is not New Jersey
New Hampshire is not Maine New Hampshire
is not Rhode Island New Hampshire is
unique and these uh out of out of
country uh companies they want to
destroy New Hampshire with this windmill
thing we will not going to let it happen
so thank you very much Mr
chairman and I will if I have if anybody
has any question I will answer okay any
questions for representative Khan seeing
none we'll call next representative
saborin representative Matt saborin also
from
Seabrook thank you chairman Vose and
members of committee I'm representative
of Sabor Schwaner from Rockham District
30 C Brook so testifying in support of
this resolution um spoken twice already
today we're not interested in
the offshore wind transmission lines
coming ashore to cab Brook if you look
at the boam website on the companies
that
were allowed to bid for the leases in
the Gulf of main most of them were um
foreign owns I think federally
subsidized offshore wind companies
displace ing the organic American
private sector fishing industry doesn't
sound very America first to
me
um what
else we're at risk of losing our Cod
stocks I'll say
that so the frequencies that are emitted
by the towers when they're vibrating
will attract one of the oldest fishing
stocks in
America and
codfish instead of being out in the
waters where they can be fished they
will instead be congregating around the
windmills themselves unable to be fished
by our fishermen so there are secondary
and tertiary consequences to be
considered with offshore wind and I
support the resolution thank
you thank you questions for the
representative seeing none thank you
representative for testifying on this
bill next let's go
to
JY to town or to Troon
troton tone okay from the Yankee
Fisherman's Cooperative
welcome please turn on the mic and you
have two minutes please two and a
half uh I want to thank the committee
for allowing me to speak here I am the
uh my name is Jim tatone I'm from seab
Brook I am the U SE Coast commissioner
for the New Hampshire fishing Game
Commission I'm also a member of the
commission for offshore wind and Port
development but I want to make it clear
I'm here today strictly as Jim tatone
owner and operator of the fishing vessel
Fly Girls you know we're talking about
preserving our environment and what this
wind and this green is going to do but
we're not taking into too much of
account protecting the pristine
environment of the Gulf of Maine the
Gulf of
Maine is the most productive ecosystem
one of the most productive ecosystems in
the world it supports over 4,000 species
of different marine life and out 80
miles off our Coast we have cashous
ledge habitat Management Area this area
is closed to commercial fishing because
it's so important
for the life of the Gulf of
Maine this cases ledge is an underground
is underwater mountain range 35 miles
long 6 miles wide it ranges in depth
from a th000 feet at its base up to 25
ft up the top what's unique about the
Cash's ledge is aan rock at its peak
creates such a disturbance to the
currents within the Gulf of Maine it
creates this cold water upwelling which
is vital with for nutrients for the life
of all the marine species that cashes
ledge supports now just east of cashes
ledge a budding cashis ledge is a 98,000
Acre Site which is designated for an
offshore Wind Farm now Cash's ledge
contains the largest kelp forest on the
entire Eastern Seaboard kelp is far more
efficient at reducing or in carbon
sequestration than any Forest on land
but yet we're going to put an ocean
offshore wind site in the proximity of
Cash's ledge to jeopardize this this
forest and all the marine life on there
now the O the uh the turbines that'll be
out on the uh on the offshore sites
they're a th000 feet tall their Blades
of 500 feet in diamer now these these
blades and these propellers when they're
working they create a wake of effect and
this wake effect it disturbs the ocean
currents and it also provides sediment
that blocks sunlight which prevents
nutrition for getting into the bottom
sea life so that's that's one of the
other issues um then we come to the
economic parts of this offshore wind is
50% more expensive than offshore wind
than onshore wind excuse me and the
floating platforms are 22 more ex 22% %
higher in cost than the cost for a fixed
monopile um
Foundation the estimates to run the
power cables ass sure are between five
to7 million per mile and that's when you
have a relative uh flat bottom the Gulf
of Maine is geologically comp complex
the most geologically complex bottom on
the entire Eastern seab board now to run
cables are short to landfall from the
Gulf of Maine is going to require a lot
of ups and downs through valleys through
basins through Peaks to ridges these are
all going to have to be covered with
special concrete
blankets and these these blankets are
notice for shifting with ocean currents
and they chafe and the cables will
chafe and so the cost for running cables
from offshore wind will be far more
expensive than conventional offshore
other offshore wind platforms the
vineyard wind power purchase agreement
that came in at $74 per hour but they
are guaranteed annual rate increases for
20 years after the operation begins on
that wind farm so this thing about going
to scale when you go to scale the cost
should go down not when you have
Guaranteed Rate increases for more than
20 years that's just totally ridiculous
I'm I'm one final thought please I'm as
a member of the Yankee fisherman Co-op
and of 60 members we're urg this
committee to support this house
resolution to prevent uh offshore wind
from ever coming to the Gulf of main
thank
you excellent testimony thank you
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question of course I do um thank you
chair and and thank you very much for
being here I was actually waiting for
for um the testifier from this um from
this uh uh document so um the Gulf of
Maine goes from Nova Scotia to Cape Cod
correct well that's not my question so
the Gulf of Maine goes from Nova Scotia
to Cape Cod that's considered the Gulf
of Maine the Gulf of Maine right it's
like rectangular area Okay so right now
the Gulf of Maine is warming at three
times faster than the global average and
and it is rising at 2.5 times faster in
recent years than in the last century so
my question is is there already an
impact to
fishing and are you concerned about
these threats that are currently
happening in the Gulf well well just
last year the um the deep water um
weathering bullies that are out there
have been
noticing extreme cold water upwelling
developing in the Gulf of Maine
scientists cannot explain what is going
on and why these cold water upwellings
are coming so my my position is that
maybe eventually that if these cold
water upwellings continue it may Pro it
may slow down the heating of the uh the
Gulf of Maine as for species uh impact
um what I've seen the only thing I've
seen is catching in my traps lobster
traps are species that probably
not customarily caught around here like
black sea bass and trigger
fish thank you very
much uh representative n has a
question thank you and thank you for
being here today um I didn't know
anything about cash a ledge before so
this is all new to me and since your
time was cut off I wondered if there was
anything else that you wanted to tell us
that you weren't able to until somebody
asked you a question did I go into the
fact that
the Gulf of Maine covers only 10% of the
total Atlantic Seaboard but yet it's
responsible for 50% of all the fish that
Pro all the seafood that is landed on
the entire Atlantic Seaboard that's
pretty amazing fact that 10% of your
water is uh responsible for 50% of the
seafood that gets
landed that's a fascinating statistic
thank
you uh one other question from
representative Swanson
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr toon
um the uh representative Thomas
mentioned that uh this should be in
effect until uh there's an agreement or
understanding by the legislature that
all the concerns of the fishing industry
have been addressed uh we've heard a
number of different concerns and uh
probably maybe risk from a variety of s
sources besides uh offshore wind but as
far as the offshore wind question
there was an implication that you might
reconsider opposition to Offshore wind
if somebody provides uh assurance that
the risks that have been discussed are
addressed and who would you uh accept as
a an authority on providing that
Assurance well you know these are
offshore winds sites because of the
propon of cables that are could be uh
suspended in the water column and
because of the moing lines moing lines
are generally 7 to1 ratio if you have
1,000 ft of water you have to have 7,000
ft of moing scope the size of the chains
that are going to be holding these um
turbines uh the one link is probably the
size of one of these tables and they're
going to be scouring the bottom and the
other thing is these because of the
floating nature of these and the
suspended cables these these uh wind
farms are going to likely to be full
exclusion zones meaning that you won't
be able to navigate through these uh
wind Farms so if you're out 25 30 miles
Beyond then you got to get in because
the weather's getting bad you're going
to have to circumnavigate around the
wind farm and put yourself in more
Jeopardy just to get get to shore
because you cannot navigate through a
floating offshore wind farm so follow-up
question followup is there
uh any situation or condition then
you're I I think I hear are you saying
then that there's no condition or
description that you would accept well
I'm my my major concern is the pristine
environment of the of the Gulf of Maine
in Jeopardy of producing necessary food
because I believe the Gulf of Maine is
Cap capable of producing food that's
more valuable than any electricity that
will be
produced
okay so you know further questions I
want to thank you for your testimony and
call Lisa lenos
welcome back again thank you Mr shairon
I appreciate the chance to speak with
you um for the record my name is Lisa
lenos and my I'm going to speak in
support of HR HCR for and before I get
started I wanted to comment to
representative Harrington the state of
New Hampshire does have full authority
to stop an onshoring transmission line
that and that in New Hampshire will be
done through the side evaluation
committee but in other states like New
Jersey at one time it was the before
they took their right away it would have
been local rule to stop
it um the point I want to make most
important is that the we've heard from
the fishermen and I want you to hear
this issue around uh what bom has said
in terms of the impact to the fishing
industry and these are this is the same
comment that they made with regard to
the vineyard wind project the revolution
wi project and also the CV Coastal
Virginia wind offshore wind project
that's happening off the coast of
Virginia they stated in their uh
environmental impact statements that the
impact on fishing would be negligible
commercial fishing would be negligible
to Major meaning that the actual impact
is uncertain and depends on evolving
factors like how fish populations
respond how the industry adapts and
whether ation efforts succeed it also
means that while some areas and
stakeholders might experience minimal
disruption others might face severe
consequences that's how bom has left it
so there is this point to the question
of whether or not what if you can be
assured there is no way they're going to
be assuring that the fishing industry
would survive offshore wind development
as it's happening to reduce the major
adverse finding to minor are negligible
which is the process that they have to
go through in order to approve these
construction and operation plans bom has
bom is now requiring developers to
provide compensatory mitigation meaning
fishermen will be rece receiving funding
to cover their revenue losses so in
effect they are they are proposing and
have established that this will be the
case you will be if you're not able to
secure the same level of yield that you
were before or perhaps not be a to fish
at all we will pay you to compensate you
that means that they won't be fishing
that means the fishing industry will die
the extent to which it will happen we
don't know but the listening to the
fishermen it might be quite
severe um there was one other point the
um the I have I'm going to be emailing
my comments to you but in the comments I
also list the staff comments from the
staff report for the coastal Resource
Management Council which in Rhode Island
which is the entity responsible for the
consistency review that I spoke about in
my prior testimony they say a number of
things about the impacts of the
fishermen but I will just read one of
them and that is overall this is a
direct quote there will likely be a net
loss to existing Rhode Island based
Marine businesses who either directly or
indirectly profit from the fish fishery
resources located with within the
proposed Revolution when project which
is one of the projects off the coast so
that that is one area I think it's very
serious problem that is not well exposed
other other point I want to make is orad
AOS which is one of the largest
developers from Denmark they're
developing projects off the coast of New
England has stated in public
presentations that offshore wind will
likely reduce tourism re revenues for an
area by 15% annually in 2023 tourism
related spending in Hampshire which
includes ocean tourism reached $2.4
billion I don't know what percentage of
that represents ocean tourism but if
just onethird of that Revenue came from
Ocean tourists this could impact as much
as $120 million in revenues annually for
the life of the project and we know that
our coastal towns if they're like most
coastal towns they make most of their
revenue during the summer period when
when re when um visitors come okay make
your final Point okay final point with
regard to Offshore wind and climate
change and climate risk according to bom
us offshore wind projects would be by
themselves will have a limited impact on
global emissions and climate change
bom Point Blank says the impact of these
projects not just one but all of them
will not reduce climate change and the
reason they're mainly being built is to
meet the the mandates that have been
established in the states thank you
okay thank you any questions for miss
lenos seeing none want to thank you for
that excellent testimony next up is Ward
burn welcome back Mr
burn uh thank you again I'm Ward burn
Captain owner of the fishing vessel
sugar daddy based out of pors New
Hampshire I would like to put out uh
point out today that the
uh the senator that was in charge of the
wind commission is absent today and that
would be Senate Senator Waters he's not
here um I would like to point out that
the nature conservancy
foundation and
um conservative Conservancy law
Foundation both receive funds from from
the wind companies and they made
testimony earlier so it it doesn't
appear that it's we're on a fair playing
field here when we have people that are
getting paid to testify and I'm here
I've lost a day's
pay there was never a vote in the
several well several years of the win
Commission in favor of this never one
vote taken in all of our time we've
never took a vote to vote on it anything
it was always a discussion and the
fisherman were as Eric said earlier we
had about 40 minutes of time in the and
years um I would like to comment on
something the the intent of this bill
and um the intent is to help Maine and
Massachusetts well Massachusetts New
Hampshire and Maine fisherman are united
and we stand together and we do not want
wind we know it's an ocean killer I've
explained to you the cooland stations
and I'm going to I'll I'll leave it with
this with
you um it's it's unfathomable for me to
be a steward of the ocean and sit here
and we talk about money and cost and
rates and we're not even really
discussing the health of our ocean and
what this is going to do to it if we
kill that ocean we won't have to worry
about electricity we're going to have
much bigger problems it's a fragile
ecosystem that needs to be treated as
such we are highly regulated by the
government to take care of our ocean and
we're proud to be stewards of the ocean
I don't know one fisherman that doesn't
go to work put his boots on jump on his
boat and love what he does and what we
do is feed people we're Farmers we like
feeding people thank
you thank
you oh and representative Wendy Thomas
has a question for you thank you uh
chair and and thank you for being here
I'm just trying to understand the
fishing industry so in your your boat is
sugar daddy that's not my question um
but with your boat do you go out further
than three miles do you go into
international waters I do if I'm
commercial tuna fishing yes okay thank
you representative McGee has a question
hi thank you for taking my question
thank you for being here too and for the
work that you do um I think you know we
uh we all have similar uh goals in that
we want to protect and preserve our
Waters and our natural resources for
sure um and I think
uh some of the testimony that you've
given us today I went to look up I
wasn't doing other things on my computer
I was kind of looking up things that
have been said and what I wanted to look
up particularly was the idea that
chlorine was being released into the
water and that it might be bleaching or
changing the chemistry and hurting um
sea uh animals and
the all the answers that I've gotten are
that that that no floating wind turbines
do not release chlorine into the ocean
that they don't use um the ocean water
in order to circulate to cool the
turbines or anything like that so I
haven't been able to find anything that
actually corroborates that you're
correct the turbines themselves don't
use the ocean water the cooling stations
halfway between the windmill and
the uh and land and they need cooling
stations to switch it from AC to DC
power and they're going to take in
seawater off off the ocean floor they're
going to chlorinate it to prevent fing
in the equipment and when it's
discharged it'll be between 86 and 90
degrees I call it 90 because I'm I'm
sore about the whole subject but um and
they disat it back into the ocean at the
tune of 8.1 gallon million gallons a day
at 40% load now also I left out on my
last testimony that if they get the
whole wind array they don't need just
one cooling station they need
32 that's where the 280 million gallons
of chlorinated heated seawater comes
from at 100% load it's 333 million
gallons a day and uh I don't have the
actual wording I wrote it down but I
can't find it but my good friend over
here Jerry has the appendix on where to
Sunrise
appendix and two wrot that down earlier
you you will find the uh use of chlorine
uh dumped into the ocean and I mean it
doesn't you know I'm a fisherman I I'm
not a rocket scientist or anything like
that but I know well enough to know
that's going to be really
bad so thank you for clarifying that Mr
chair um can I speak just one yes so
it's the cooling stations we should be
looking at to try try and figure out it
basically sounds like as the energy
comes from the wind turbine it needs to
be it needs to be what would the word be
um conditioned uh in order to take the
current to the what you need when it
gets on Shore so there's a like a way
station in between that they look like a
put your an oil rig that's what they
look like on a Model that I've seen and
it it looks like an oil rig only it's a
cooling station to cool down the sea
water cuz when they switch from AC to DC
power it Ates heat so as they pitch of
water flowing through a pipe it's like
electricity is flowing through the wire
and when it get so far and they have to
switch over it creates heat so that and
part of this is a result of these are
they're not they're experimental
floating wind wind farms this isn't this
is the first in our country this is the
first time we're experimenting with this
type of technology in our ocean and um
and I like I've said for that we use
their data this we didn't dream this up
this is their
material okay additional
questions seeing none we'll move next to
Jeremy or Jerry lieman of n
FSA thank you Mr chair fellow committee
members um little background before I
created
nepsa I right out of high school I
started offshore trolling out of
Portland Maine then from there 7 years
later I ended up in Boston Massachusetts
5 years after that in Gloucester
Massachusetts and near the end of my
career before creating nea I ended up in
New Bedford Mass I have covered
everything from the Bay of Fundy across
the EZ line across the northern edge of
Georgia's Banks down to the Canyons
Georgia's Canyons specifically all the
way back to the west of the Hudson
Canyon down below the south end of
Massachusetts I've towed over well over
a half million miles of bottom I spent
16 and 1 12 years at sea fishing around
the clock in the last
23 we have logical Baseline studies
showing catch averages using the same
codend size over two decades the numbers
have gone up what was told to you today
about the Cash's ledge well there's also
the Jeff's ledge closure which restricts
access to a lot of commercial trollers
so when we start taking up large SLO of
our water we are fundamentally moving
fishing pattern efforts while the
management of our Fisheries are in
regions the fish do not know there are
borders we could be misad redirecting
keynote Forge stocks those Forge stocks
are what helps the vitility of the
resource for the
rebundle have not little to know
research on we're still looking at noise
I mean we're building out right now on
fixed platforms down off South of uh
Massachusetts these are floating
turbines projected for the Gulf of main
as was said the anchoring chains are
projected between 7 to1 and 9 to1
scoping well 700 ft of water average
well that's 4,900 ft time 3 so now
you're talking what 13,700 ft of chain
per turbine the ocdc converters are what
the cooling stations are called from the
sunrise wind PR appendex N2 and on our
website NE fisherman with an e.org we
also have documents showing you know
these peer-reviewed Sciences talking
about these things we have a cooling
station report same thing with a lobster
report same thing with alisandra Cressy
is a scientist out of Norway the Norway
acoustic study they did lab testing
showing that 100 htz noise produced by
floating turbines in the labs actually
called in juvenile cfish larvey well we
also know through the science center
that Alo branches like sharks and skates
are attracted in some nuances to EMF
fields which would put that larv into
predation because the same studies also
show when hattic larv were introduced to
EMF it slowed the swimming rate well
when fish and lobsters don't swim that
puts them into higher predation
everything in the ocean was designed to
eat something else 98% of everything
born was designed to Die the 2% is what
causes the re occurrence of the stocks
we have not done enough field study yet
or over enough time to figure out what
the next steps are again that's why we
say if you don't know where you are you
don't know where you're going but we're
projecting millions of dollars of money
and billions actually you know on on
unvetted technology high wind Tempest
again is the only floating turbines out
of the United Kingdom they use a
four-part anchoring system we about
producing three-part anchoring systems
well we don't know which design we're
going to use because again it's not
vetted technology one last point please
I am very strongly uh for this
amendment uh again no fisherman in Maine
New Hampshire or Massachusetts out of
the thousands that I've interacted with
over three years agree with this and we
our voices have not been heard and this
is a good time for New Hampshire to take
the lead and show a good strong
standpoint not just for your state but
for the nation thank you
okay well said all right no
questions uh for that gentleman so now
we'll call on cowo Kelly and Miss Kelly
please talk about the resolution not the
threat that China poses to the
world thank you Mr chairman um yes I am
for the resolution and like I said
earlier I'm from Vietnam and I know that
the quality of the seafood here away
when I still eating the food and my I
still go shopping for my family so the
quality is different from the imported
product Seafoods and the food from other
country especially from Vietnam that I
know so if the fishing industry is gone
we are stuck with imported products and
in Vietnam most of their Farm including
sea farms and fish farms and all that
are affected by Chinese chemicals and
they they have a farm that they just
sell and they have a farm for their
family to eat and we are stuck with the
imported products that to sell not for
the family consumes that's affecting all
of our health and I hear a lot from the
fishing industry but not enough voice to
protect the consumer protection like us
because most of us are busy working to
pay bills especially grocery bills my
grocery bills go 100% up since 2021 so
I'm to you all suffering the same pain
but hopefully some voice to protect a
consumer like us and our health and our
future thank you and and please support
this bill uh this resolution thank you
thank you Miss Kelly appreciate you
being here next up is Meredith Hatfield
from The Nature
Conservancy thank you good afternoon
Meredith Hatfield from nature
conservancy um I filed a letter on the
prior bill that also covers this bill I
wasn't intending to to
testify um but
unfortunately uh one of the prior
speakers stated that we receive funding
from the offshore wind industry and I
felt the need to just say that that is
not true thank
you thanks for clarifying
that okay last word on this um
resolution goes to John Gage of wind
Windam and Mr Gage earlier in your test
testimony on a different bill you held
up a placard that's a violation of house
rules so please don't do that again oh
sorry it was just a web address I didn't
know if
I could speak it clearly enough um so
thank you for hearing my testimony
chairman I oppose this bill
um I'd like you to if you would call the
um public online testimony the last two
previous bills were strongly favored or
strongly opposed by the public 30 to 163
and 40 to 175 um I don't know what this
one is but it would be nice to know how
the public weighs in um fishermen know
their business best um well I think
that's true they know where to get the
fish um but we do see that over fishing
sometimes happens and I don't know if
global warming is on the minds of
anybody when they're headed out to see
uh it's uh they've got a lot more
important
shortterm things to worry about uh but
this is from the National Climate
assessment that came out a couple years
ago across the globe climate change is
altering marine ecosystems and connected
social systems at a scale and Pace that
is unprecedented in recent Millennia the
combination of long-term changes in
physical ocean conditions such as
warming sea ice loss acidification and
deoxygenation and short-term extreme
events such as Marine heat waves
threaten marine ecosystems and human
communities numerous marine species from
phytoplankton to whales are altering
their distribution seasonal activities
and behaviors to align with suitable
ocean conditions these changes Ripple
through the food web affecting species
interactions ecosystem functions and
biodiversity as well as conservation
management and uses of valuable ocean
resources um a lot of fishing happens up
here now because fishermen in the South
uh in the Carolinas they used to find
species offshore are coming up here now
to fish because as the water's warm
species are migrating
um final
word uh so representative Khan said he
wants to leave New Hampshire better for
our children I think all of us do and I
think it's important for us to
understand that every energy source has
um problems um but an energy diverse New
Hampshire is a more resilient Reliant um
independent New Hampshire so I really
think you should oppose this number
three bill today on the war on wind
power thank
you thank you and with that being the
last pink card for HCR 4 we will close
that public hearing and we will open a
public hearing on HB 219 F relative to
the phasing out of the minimum electric
renewable portfolio standard and I'll
call Representative Michael Harrington
the prime sponsor of the bill to
introduce this
legislation while representative
Harington is making his way forward I
will point out that I already have 19
pink cards for this bill
and I see that more are coming
so we will probably have to uh
suspend the public hearing on these two
bills and resume them at a at a later
date which is unfortunate representative
Harrington go ahead and introduce this
legislation thank you Mr chairman my
name is Michael Harrington I'm represent
present straford district 18 I refer to
this bill as the New Hampshire rate
payers are not stupid act because that's
basically what it's what it's saying uh
we started out some years ago with the
idea that we had to subsidize renewable
energy to get it up on its feet and
running we were made promises that after
a while they wouldn't need the subsidies
it'll be so much cheaper when we build a
lot of it that people will voluntarily
buy it well we can go back and look a
like a little bit what people would
voluntarily do when I was on the uh
Public Utilities Commission there was
actually a law in place that was now
it's been suspended that said the
utilities would have to provide up to
including 100% Renewable Power to
anybody who wanted it but they would
have to collect the cost from the people
who wanted it so if you wanted renewable
energy and you willing to pay for it you
could get renewable energy this bill
reinstates that provision of course when
people were given the option as to
whether or not to purchase renewable
energy less than 1% of the rate payers
opted to do that so because the
administrative costs were so high again
0.1% administrative cost was so high
associated with it the utilities said
can we suspend this nobody's using it
and the Pu granted that wish so now the
years have gone by we've had all the
startups come and gone they've got huge
amounts of this being built and the rate
payer the subsidies are still there and
this would simply phase out the the
subsidies over a 5year period now people
are going to say well that's going to be
bad for my business well there was never
a promise made in that original Bill no
one ever sat here and said you're going
to be subsidized forever as with any
government program you take your risk
that it could be discontinued in the
future this is simply a handout program
and there's nothing that would stop
anybody who wants to buy Renewable Power
for the devolved service from from doing
it um it simply says if you choose not
to then you don't have to subsidize
Renewable Power so and people are going
to talk about oh it's creating jobs here
and jobs there well how much are they
willing to pay out of their pocket to
create some job that somebody else does
that no one's willing to pay for because
if people want to have this product they
will buy it and I think that the the
concept that was uh at least somewhat
presented in the past was well people
don't aren aware of global warming and
climate change and all this um you'd
have to be literally living in a hole in
the ground not to hear about global
warming and climate change we are
inundated with it constantly every place
you go I mean the Patriots lose it's due
to global warming uh it speaks about
everything you can think of that happens
is blamed on global warming no one is
ignorant of the fact of that opinion
anyways on global warming and now people
can make a choice that's all this does
it says should the state be ones to say
you're not smart enough to decide what
type of electricity to make even though
you've been inundated for years over the
threats of global warming and how bad
and horrible it's going to be you if
give them the freedom to make a choice
will make the wrong choice so we're
going to force you to buy electricity at
a higher cost that you don't want to buy
and that's simply what the bill says no
we're not going to do that anymore we
don't stop instantaneously because give
people a chance to plan it's a five-year
phase out so that 5 years after
implementation of the bill the renewable
portfolio standard will no longer exist
and everyone will produce uh electricity
on a Level Playing Field and people can
choose they want renewable they don't
want renewable if they want wind if you
go to the Pu website now there's some
people that sell all wind I'm sure
there's others could come up that do
similar ones like that so that's what it
does I take any
questions okay questions for
representative Harrington representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative Harrington for taking
my question we've seen this bill before
um and I understand uh the aims of the
bill I guess the question I have is if
there is any economic impact information
that we've collected to understand what
it will do um to existing businesses and
existing markets and the competitive
energy Market if a bill like this uh
goes through do do we have any
understanding of what kind of economic
impacts this bill would result in well I
don't have a specific number but I can
say that there's generally a
misunderstanding of economic impacts
because it seems to be an opinion that
if the government collects $100 from a
th000 people and then spends 80,000 of
that on some project and 20,000 on
overhead cost that is more effective at
creating jobs than the Private Industry
would I my contention is you left
$100,000 in the hand of individuals to
make their own choice they're going to
make a better choice than the government
so the fact yeah is there going to be
some economic impact on it probably if
they can't produce on par with other
sources some of these renewable uh
plants will go out of business
but that doesn't mean the money is being
torn up and thrown down the toilet it
means people get to retain their money
and spend it a different way that will
create businesses probably more jobs
than would be created by government
picking the job that we're going to
subsidize followup so um since it's an
existing program
uh it you mentioned in your intro that
um you know government impos this you
didn't couple it with the reason we were
doing it which was to try and incent you
know fuel diversity and clean energy
sources and so all the value uh that we
were trying to attain by having this
program are also still there and those
were not part of your testimony so can
you say something about uh how this my
impression is that this would just um
sort of pull up the rein on the
economics of these Investments and would
really change the energy landscape such
that we would have less fuel diversity
in the state which I think since the
renewable energy stuff is local and
sustainable it contributes to our energy
Independence so I think that's probably
why there's a lot of people here to
speak on the
RPS well I first of all I have to say
again your premise is that the people of
New Hampshire aren't smart enough to
make those decisions for themselves
after years and years of being told
about climate change and global warming
over and over and over again they can
they your what your position is they
kind of assess that and say this is a
good idea I want to buy renewable energy
and I'm going to request that the
utility sell it to me because they will
have the authority to do that and maybe
it'll create more renewable energy jobs
maybe more people will say you know to
hell this 10% or whatever it is I want
100% renewable energy and they'll go out
and it may create more jobs but you you
can't it's the premise that somehow only
government can make a decision like that
when the facts are well known to
everybody and the me the method is there
all someone has to do is request
eversource what Unitil I want 50%
renewable energy and they will have to
go get it and if there's a cost
associated with it then you'll pay the
cost when you request that but if
there's enough people requesting it then
maybe there'll be more renewable energy
and the cost will go down but either way
I think the individual consumer is smart
enough to make that decision for
themselves and we don't have to have the
government say basically you know you're
too dumb to figure out what type of
electricity to buy we're going to tell
you what to
buy so I have a question for you the
underlying Assumption of the RPS is that
renewable energy is somehow a good thing
a desirable thing
and if that is underlying assumption is
valid would it not be true that people
would be rushing out to buy as much re
renewable energy as they could
I think they would I think that right
now under the present system we have
certain limits on there and if we we to
renewable energy providers spent less
time lobbying at the state house and
more time advertising and selling their
product like other people have to do
maybe they'd have a lot more people
signing up hey get our energy it's clean
there's no pollution come to us we we're
going to save the world whatever but
they could to their effort on that and
I'm sure if they can do a good job
convincing people that there really is a
good reason to buy Renewables energy the
people will buy
it so currently the community power
Coalition of New Hampshire does offer a
plan where people can buy 100% renewable
energy and according to the coalition's
own statistics only 4% of the customers
of the Coalition take advantage of that
option do you think that means that
people are not as excited about
renewable energy as we've been led to
believe well it's other one or two
conclusions I guess you can meet either
most people aren't aware of that option
because the community power is not doing
a very good job getting the word out or
the people that are aware of it say I
don't want to pay extra money if there's
extra money involved uh in order to get
my electric bill my electric bill is
high enough as it is and if I can make
it lower even by a small amount that's
the choice I'll take but it's my choice
not
theirs representative Swanson has a
question
Mr chair thank you uh representative
Harrington
um it it seems
uh that by your logic that uh all only
people who uh have children in school
should be paying for schools and uh that
we don't have a collective interest and
that as a collective state that we can
encourage things or Investments at a
level that would benefit others
and uh it is worth making that
investment because instead of being able
to buy an extra dozen eggs per year or
something like that some of that money
is going to go back to be invested into
perhaps a renewable energy source and so
are you saying that uh they that would
absolutely be a valid alternative that
we should just leave it up to individual
citizens to decide how we're going to
get our energy and whether it's going to
be renewable
definitely I mean again you taking the
position it sounds like that people
aren't smart enough to make that
decision for themselves so the
government must step in and say no no no
no you're not intelligent enough to make
a decision on what type of energy to buy
so we're going to force you to buy this
because we know what's right for you and
you don't know what's right for yourself
this is an opportunity for freedom and
in a case like this where it this it
would simply work because you could
everyone would have the option of saying
to the utility I want 100% uh renewable
I want 50% renewable I want 0% renewable
it's there the vehicle would be there
it's not like something has to be done
to establish that which is saying that
individuals in a free Society should be
able to decide what type of energy they
want to buy follow-up question Mr chair
yes followup so um I
um I take exception to the uh assertion
that individuals are smart enough it
isn't about being smart it's having an
infrastructure or system that's there
that enables or facilitate what you're
saying should be done you know if I
wanted more renewable energy I couldn't
do too much except for Community power
when I was deciding whether I was going
to install solar panels and even though
I'm never going to pay it off I probably
won't get a complete return on
investment in my lifetime I know that a
it is for every time that I produce
energy that goes out to The Grid I don't
know who uses it because I do have a
surplus I don't know who uses it but uh
I think that it's an ultimately a
benefit overall for that and I might not
have done it if it weren't for the
credits that I could have earned by
getting that and not everybody can do
that that's the thing it isn't an
individual individual Choice it's a
individual situation but if we work
together then we can have better ability
to provide guidance to get that and so
I'm sorry I didn't really ask a question
but I do take exception that it isn't
about smarts remember we're not debating
we're asking questions
right okay any can I respond to that Mr
chairman absolutely yep uh I think
you're confused on the issue because
there is a methodology for an individual
to make a decision for themselves on
this if you want 100% Renewable Power
under this bill you could get it your
neighbor could get it the person down
the street could get it you wanted to
put in solar panels it has no effect on
ability to put solar panels in um if
things aren't subsidized and they and
they don't get done maybe there's a good
reason they're not done because if
people aren't willing to spend their own
money on an idea it's probably not such
a good idea and this would give you the
vehicle so make sure this is very clear
to everybody this would provide a
vehicle so anybody and everybody could
request up to 100% power from renewable
sources okay representative PL has a
question uh thank you chair uh thank you
representative Harrington did in this
bill the phase
out but the government had its thumb on
the scale by providing this with Rex the
people who and municipalities who put in
their
Capital I've heard from my district
that's not enough time for them to get
it back did you consider grandfathering
in and if so it's a two-part question if
so if not do your reason why thank you
no I didn't but it it's obviously we
could we could consider something like
that but I think we have to be clear
though on message here if you make a
commitment based on a government handout
there's no guarantee that you're going
to get that handout forever and you have
to take that into uh that should be one
of the variables in your assessment well
what if they stop this project in three
years two years 10 years and then you
make a decision on your own I still
think it's worth going forward or I
don't think it's going forward but
there's no guarantee it's like you know
last year I paid less than taxes if they
don't renew the tax cuts I'm going to
pay more this year I can't go spend the
money hoping that they'll renew the tax
cuts cuz they might not that's the risk
one takes when it's when dealing with
government programs they're all subject
to being
stopped representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair um you you have said
over and over that that what did you
call this the uh rate payers are not
stupid act and you keep saying people
are too stupid um energy as we know is a
very complicated topic which is why when
we present the St bills on the floor
everybody falls asleep I mean they just
they and I'm not saying they're stupid
but it's very very complicated isn't
their quality value in the government
giving us guidance and
incentive well the government's been
giving us guidance and incentives now
for I don't know how long this build
been around 10 15 years and like I say
there's constant amount of information
being released on the evils of fossil
fuel and the wonders of renewable energy
it's this isn't like uh rocket science
stuff anymore it's pretty
straightforward everyone's seeing the
stuff carbon dioxide gets produced by by
uh fossil fuels uh renewable energy such
as solar and wind don't produce carbon
dioxide and I just think that adequate
information is out there so people can
make a decision for themselves and this
would apply allow for a vehicle so that
anybody who said no I want to do part of
my share I I don't want to go with
whatever it is now 20% I want to go up
to 50% renewable because I think it's
that important or it can go to 100% or
it can go to zero but I think the
individual certainly has the information
and this gives them the wherewith all to
do
it okay representative McGee has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my
question so we we he we've heard in
testimony earlier uh that you can't know
where you're going until you know where
you are right the RPS program
my understanding is the RPS program was
designed to help us sort of measure whe
where we were at in terms of goals that
we were setting as a state at the time
um and that was uh looking at the
different aspects of our energy
portfolio and trying to clean them up
trying to make sure we were lowering
emissions so we actually had a plan at
the time which we don't have now that we
were rocking to and it was the original
um statute was 20 5% by 2025 right so we
were going to be looking at the RPS this
year in terms of have we met that goal
um but we're not talking about goals
anymore now we're just talking about
poking holes in what we have and what we
like and what we don't so what I'm
curious about is what you think it does
to the people you say governments can
pull away programs whenever they want
and nobody should depend on them but the
fact is this was something that was
strategically put in place in order to
give people a way to be able to look at
the measurements of how the state was
doing and also figure out if they wanted
to contribute in some way so how does
this how does taking this away at this
point help anything in the energy sector
you you you're talking about freedom but
what about the consistency for people to
understand that they can undertake an
investment that they might want to
undertake and know that their turnaround
on that investment is going to be
something that's a constant because I
think others tried to sort of allude to
that point we heard testimony in this
committee this year about there's a long
Tale on the return on investment for um
investing in solar and and other type of
things so it's important that there is
some kind of an incentive where people
simply aren't going to do it well I'm
not sure if I got a question there but I
I think I've heard a little bit of one I
I would respond I guess on that by if
you want to use that logic then uh we
built a coal plant in 1940 with certain
pollution laws in effect I complied with
those laws in 1940 now it's 1980 or
1990 putting in a Mercury scrubber
putting in something else putting in a
cooling tower all those rules weren't
there before now you're imposing these
new great costs on me why shouldn't I
have consistency and let that coal plant
just sit there for the next 100 years
producing all the stuff that it produces
without pollution controls there's a
constant changing and r in of things
we're also told during this that it was
a startup push on the renewable energy
that they needed it I specifically
remember hearing uh the person from next
era who was one of the largest producers
of renewable energy in the country then
and now and they were saying we're going
to need this to get going but the hope
is that we get to the economies of scale
and especially things like with wind
we'll start making it cheaper and we've
heard that promise over and over again
that wind and solar are going to be
cheaper than gas and if that's the case
then why do we have to force people to
buy the wind and
solar yes go ahead and wind and solar
are cheaper than gas now aren't
they on the average note maybe on a
particular day they might be but I think
if you look across the board they're uh
they're they're not the they're not the
cheaper okay seeing no more questions
thank you representative for introducing
this legislation I'd like to call next
representative Lori coren of Berlin coas
County district
7 welcome representative to
st& thank you so
much my name is Lori coren and I
represent the people of Coos County
district 7 I come before you today to
oppose this bill and ask that you vote
inexpedient to legislate on HB 219 the
RPS law has worked as intended fostering
New Hampshire's homegrown power
generation
creating high paying jobs and increased
tax revenue this bill does absolutely
nothing to improve the state's economy
and it will hurt existing jobs and lower
tax revenues with zero guarantees of
lower power rates I come from Berlin so
I represent the people of
Berlin as most of you probably know we
have Berlin biomass there in Berlin
which is just finding its way out of um
bankruptcy it's it's trying to get back
on its
feet uh agreeing to this bill now would
absolutely destroy Berlin um not only do
they do they give most of our residents
jobs um but they also contribute to the
uh tax revenue that our citizens in
Berlin really rely on
um the Coos County um has a windmill
project in dickville and in Cambridge
that windmill project alone gives us
hundreds of thousands of dollars that
help our delegation to pay for our
nursing
homes um supporting this bill now could
destroy all of that I humbly ask you to
vote itl on this
bill okay thank you thank you questions
for the
representative thanks for coming all the
way down from Kos County absolutely good
to see you okay moving along next up I'm
going to call on Jason stock of the new
hamur New Hampshire Timberland
Association Timberland Owners
Association if I could I know there's
some people that traveled here sounds
like you may postpone so if I could
yield my time now to let some people
have travel okay I'll get the your card
goes back in the deck all
right all right next up is meline
mano thank you chairman and members of
the committee uh my name is m Mino I'm
Chief Operating Officer of Essex power
services that owns and operates 14 small
hydr power projects and I'm also a board
member of Granite State hydrop power
Association which is the trade
Association for small hydros in New
Hampshire um I want to really focus on
the fact that the renewable portfolio
standard in New Hampshire was created in
an effort to create a minimum level of
fuel diversity in a uh to protect rate
payers from Price volatility it was just
two years ago that we were paying 26
Cents default Service rates and that
amount of price volatility is not good
for rate payers supporting our local
Renewables resources helps reduce some
of the risk of that price volatility
those really high default Service rates
were caused by global uh anxiety over
natural gas
prices um the renewable portfolio
standard includes class 4 existing Hydro
resources um and some of our small
hydros also uh are able to qualify for
class one new resources Rex when they
put additional uh new
generation Our RPS goals in New
Hampshire are modest our alternative
compliance payment levels which act as a
price ceiling for renewable energy
certificates are
$34.99 a megawatt hour for class 4 uh
that's conservative when you look at
wreck markets in the region the cost to
rate payers is small especially compared
to the benefits the C the average cost
rate payers in 2023 which was the last
report was a third of a cent per
kilowatt hour that's maybe about 24
bucks a year for the average residential
customer dams with Hydro are
wellmaintained they are carefully
overseen and operated the RPS and Rex
are very important especially to the
smaller Hydro projects if we get rid of
the RPS and put some of those smaller
projects out of business we lose
important generation and we lose that
responsible Dam operator which can make
that Dam become a public
liability for all those reasons I would
ask you to itl hb2 219 and to support
both our renewable portfolio standard
and our local small Hydro power
resources thank you thank you Miss Mano
thank you for coming today good to see
you again questions for Miss Mano
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um and thank you for being here
you um you briefly touched on this but
I'm wondering if you could go into a
little more detail into the financial
impact including jobs and possible
closures if the RPS was phased out for
your industri sure so Grant State hydrop
Power Association is really focused on
the small projects which is under five
megawatts um I happened to be visiting a
colleague's project recently which is uh
400 kilowatts so that's pretty small and
I flat out asked him because I knew this
bill was coming up and I said if you
didn't have New Hampshire class 4 would
would you be able to keep running this
project and he said nope I couldn't keep
it going financially so that's you know
the truth I think especially for the one
megawatt and under projects the
economics are very challenging without
Rex and a lot of times these are smaller
owner operators they're not you know
spending a lot of their time trying to
qu cross qualify in different markets or
things like that New Hampshire class 4
Rex may be the only type of Rex that
their projects qualify for so um and
then you know as far as Jobs typically
for us each project has at least one
full-time
operator and we hire lots of local
contractors and businesses you know we
certainly go shopping for lots of
supplies at the local hardware store as
well as lumber yard steel we buy lots of
supplies this is large infrastructure
that Demands a lot of Maintenance and
upkeep thank
you additional questions representative
Swanson
thank you Mr chair uh thank you for uh
being with us today uh question uh so
relative to uh representative
Harrington's earlier statements uh do
you me uh can you envision a scenario
where the rate payers individually are
smart enough to uh get the generation
locally that's renewable that you
provide uh as an alternative if they had
the money back it's not a question of
smart enough in my mind it's not having
access to the market right like they an
individual residential Electric customer
is has no idea
honestly how where their electricity
comes from or why their electricity was
so expensive two years ago the average
Electric customer spend something like
two minutes a billing cycle looking or
thinking about their electric bill
so an an individual residential customer
can't go to their local Hydro power
station and say I want to buy your power
and make that happen so it's more about
having access to the markets and with 20
$24 a year they're not going to change
market dynamics either okay thank you
thank you
Mr so I have a question for you because
I know you know this stuff well you've
been around around it for quite a while
RSA
374f which is our restructuring law
yep the purpose statement of that law
states
that the most compelling reason to
restructure the New Hampshire electric
utility industry is to reduce costs for
all customers of electricity by
harnessing the power of competitive
markets doesn't the
RSA fly in the face of the stated
purpose of RSA 374f so I would argue
that the RPS is a competitive market re
are a commodity and when we generate re
we're competing directly against the
other generators that also generate reck
and so all of the entities that have to
purchase Rex so yes that's a mandate but
they're looking for the best deal for
their customers or rate payers and so
I'm competing in pricing against other
wreck
generators um the only way that a
supplier should be paying top dollar
which is capped by the alternative
compliance payment is if there's not
enough
Supply and then there's a feedback
mechanism with a renewable energy fund
that aims to increase that Supply so
unless there's an imbalance in the
market really all of the generators
should be competing against each other
in a competitive
market to give rid payers the best deal
on those
wrecks but isn't R7 RSA 378 F about
electricity markets not about renewable
energy credit or certificate markets
they're two different markets they are
yes and aren't they
incompatible I don't think they're
incompatible as I said I think our
renewable portfolio standard is very
modest it's not telling the rate payer
what 100% of their electricity should
come from we're talking about 25% at
most and so I still think that it's a
very
conservative minimum amount of fuel
diversity and local resources that we
want to make sure to keep around the
other
75% of electricity that is supplied in
New Hampshire can come from any
resource and that still might be you
know sort of a lack of fuel diversity
but we're not going to dictate every
electron of electricity where it's
coming from I don't think that having
that
25% let's make sure we keep not all of
our eggs in one basket is completely
incompatible
with giving great payers some price
competitiveness okay thank you
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair and you you intuited
that I had it I don't even think I got
my hand up um so you've mentioned a few
things that I tried probably very poorly
to mention in my prior questions which
is that it's a market and that we should
first Do no harm certainly um but what
interests me is um hydros I think
provide a very kind of
unique um uh unique quality to our uh
local sustainable energy in that they're
dispatchable right so we're talking a
lot about both both affordability and
reliability and certainly we can rely on
our hydros and we don't want to see even
the small ones go under for the value
that they bring right that that would be
me saying that but I think in general
the committee has agreed to that so the
question is you you talked
about um the current a AC uh P Price and
it being relatively conservative is that
in contrast to other states around and
how does our wreck Market uh integrate
with theirs in other words I'm trying to
figure out what the disadvantage would
be if it if it just simply went away so
um yes I was saying it's relatively
conservative compared to other wreck
markets for similar resources um you
know when Massachusetts for example had
the SRE program those were two I think
$200 or more a megawatt hour um so that
I would consider extremely generous as a
a a a wreck value and their goal goal
was to create a boom in development so
they were generous I think on purpose
um most resources you know if they can
qualify in other wreck markets they can
um sell their decide where to sell their
wrecks because it's a competitive market
there is not um a requirement that um
but every Market has requirements to
qualify so for example for small hydros
to qualify in the Massachusetts Market
you have to be low impact Hydro
certified
that comes at a cost not every project
is certifiable as low impact Hydro um in
New Hampshire they have to be in New
Hampshire or interconnected in New
Hampshire so we actually have somewhat
of a protection from having other hydros
swamping our wreck Market um so in every
state for every class there are
requirements to qualify to be able to
produce and sell re in that market
follow up and the followup would be on
another portion of your testimony where
you initially talked about um costs and
benefits and you talked about how
currently New Hampshire dams are
well-maintained because we have a hydro
Market um
so it sounded to me like what you were
saying is that you're doing that damn
maintenance but we don't have a plan for
how that would happen if we put if we
put small Hydro out of business yeah
what I I was trying to say is if a small
Hydro project goes out of business
because it's no longer financially
viable in part because they lost direct
revenues um then that owner no longer
has a source of Revenue to maintain that
Dam and so it may become a public
liability either the costs will go to
taxpayers or it will become less safe
and become a risk to the public um some
dams where Hydro is operating are public
dams that are being leased by the Hydro
power operator to be able to operate
Hydro if they no longer are running that
Hydro power it will go back to the
public entity that owns it and therefore
become the responsibility of
taxpayers okay seeing no further
questions I want to thank you and next
bring
up Brandon Kibby representing Great
River Hydro
good afternoon Brandon good afternoon
thank you very much my name is Brandon
Kibby vice president of external affairs
with Great River Hydro thank you Mr
chairman and the committee for taking uh
my comments I'm also circulating uh two
uh handouts written testimony as well as
just a sort of general fact sheet about
Great River Hydro while that's
circulating I'll give you a couple of
the highlights on on the facts about
Great River Hydro uh and first of all
I'm here to uh uh uh to oppose uh uh HB
219 um uh as well um Great River Hydro
operates 13 different generating
stations and three storage only
reservoirs on the Connecticut River and
Deerfield rivers in New Hampshire
Vermont and uh Western Massachusetts six
of those stations and two of those
storage only reservoirs are on the
Connecticut River here in New Hampshire
um these are uh about 5503 megawatts of
installed capacity in New Hampshire
alone uh so we are the largest uh
conventional hydropower generator not
just in New England but obviously here
in New Hampshire and probably the
largest um renewable energy generator in
New
Hampshire um these are the largest dams
uh Moore and cumerford Dam are the
largest dams in all of New England on
the largest river um this is massive
infrastructure massive infrastructure on
a very large river um we're a wholesale
electric generator we're not a retail
Electric electric generator we don't
sell directly to customers we sell um uh
into the wholesale electricity Market
about 1.6 million megawatt hours a year
um it's tremendous amount of generation
about enough generation to power 213,000
homes on
average um and our our hydrop power is
pretty unique we have uh Reservoir
storage all of our hydrogenating
stations all of that uh uh allows for
base load power to be produced at all
times 24 7 but also allows us to
dispatch when the system needs us the
most meaning we can come on when prices
rise and help keep the prices lower
because of that dispatchability um our
hydros also provide a tremendous amount
of other grid resources uh or grid
reliability resources that other
renewable variable renewable generators
can't do uh so uh things like um voltage
support and frequency regulation and a
whole bunch of things that will make
your mind go numb thinking about it that
are important for the Electric System
that most average consumers don't think
about uh meline had a good example that
people think about their electric I like
to say people think about their electric
bills twice is once a month when they
open their bill and uh if their power
goes out that's the only time uh
residents ever think about
power um uh other benefits of course to
uh our facilities go Way Beyond just the
hydropower generation that we produce uh
we we have a about 30,000 Acres of
property associated with our our hydrop
power stations all of that's permanently
conserved open to the public to use we
manage public boat ramps uh picnic areas
dozens of these located throughout all
free and open to the public to use at no
cost uh River Management so during high
water uh uh events we're able to store
water in our reservoirs during droughts
we're able to let water out and so the
river has recreational opportunities in
it all year round if the Connecticut
River did not have the type of of hydro
storage and generation that we have on
it there would be periods of time during
the summer where all those people that
enjoy going out on their motorboats on
the Connecticut River would not be able
to do
that uh uh obviously there's other
direct benefits um the jobs that we
provide 30 we have 30 folks over 30
folks that work for us that are New
Hampshire residents these are highp
paying highly skilled jobs that we we
provide uh we also pay uh just under $1
million a year in local property taxes
in 19 different jurisdictions in New
Hampshire uh we also have a water use
contract with the state uh New Hampshire
Dees for Murphy Dam and Lake Francis for
the use of that facility as well and
those funds go directly to the
maintenance and management of Murphy
Dam uh Hydro is as mateline mentioned
Hydro requires constant investment these
are massive infrastructure roads and
bridges you know that well require
constant investment the average age of
our facilities there's 96 years old this
is stuff that was built at the dawn of
commercial electrification but is still
uh really well-maintained and still
operating and functioning in ways but
it's not to say that it was built uh to
to representative Harrington's uh
earlier Point uh that a coal station is
built and it's just should should
continually operate no environmental
regulations have changed we get a new
license every 40 years we have new
requirements that we have to meet
uh renewable portfolio standards are
really important drivers of investment
that we make now we get our we get our
our like I said we're a wholesale
electric generator we generate uh
revenues from a variety of different
sources in these markets that have all
evolved kind of together uh renewable
portfolio standards is one of those
markets that we've evolved and have been
participating in I can tell you that in
2017 uh we've had uh we had 122
employees that company uh here in 2025
we have just over a 100 uh the the
deregulation of the markets in the late
90s have struck a whole bunch of uh
efficiencies into the electricity Market
there's a there's a graph in the back of
my comments that shows the wholesale
electricity prices going down over those
number of years of course in New England
wholesale electricity prices are driven
by the price of gas it's gas-driven
electricity so we're price takers in
that which means our revenues go down on
an annual basis annual basis annual
basis as a wholesale electric generator
so having access to a diverse source of
revenues are really important for us to
make sure that we can stay viable and we
continue to make the significant Capital
Investments that are required uh we
recently brought online a brand new 4.7
megawatt hydrogenating uh uh uh unit at
our Mo facility the single largest Hydro
station in all of New England that 4.7
megawatt uh uh station generates a new
incremental uh uh generation of 27,000
megawatts a year of new incremental
Generation Um that investment part of
the investment thesis was based on the
ability to qualify that for renewable
portfolio standards um that project
alone generates 66,000 new New Hampshire
class one uh wrecks into the marketplace
increasing the supply and therefore
decreasing the overall cost cost of Rex
in New Hampshire supply and demand um so
we based almost $20 million investment
in that facility uh in part not solely
on Rex but certainly in part on the on
the Suite of different Revenue sources
that we can get uh for that that
facility and uh that $20 million
investment in the town of Littleton
means a lot to that Community as well um
so in submm we've got about 192,000
me megawatt hours a year that we qualify
into New Hampshire class one Rex these
are Regional markets that uh that those
those also qualify partly in other
jurisdictions as well and we're we have
to sell those in a competitive way as
meline mentioned into those Regional
markets it's a it's a it's one of the
legs of the stool that we depend on from
a revenue uh standpoint for our business
to continue to be as successful as this
has
and I'm happy to take
questions okay thank you um your written
test amounty says that
you you generate 1.6 million megawatt
hours of carbon free generation annually
but you just stated a moment ago that
you only qualify
192,000 recks per year
so for New Hampshire class one Rex if
your question is why is it there a
discrepancy there so all 1.6 million
megawatt hours of ours uh qualify for
some wreck somewhere in New England um
no two wreck program is alike um and the
the qualification um uh uh requirements
in New Hampshire require a certain
amount of investment for class ones to
be made for new incremental after a
certain date and so when only we've only
been able to qualify to date only
192,000 megawatt hours out of that 1.6
million megawatt hours to qualify for
New Hampshire class ones at this point
because of that investment requirement
but the full
1.6 million rex that you would be able
to to generate qualify somewhere
somewhere mostly in Vermont or Maine um
because those are very uh uh low
required the the qualification
requirements there are very low bar just
basically need to be a re rable
generator period um and so uh whereas
New Hampshire class 1's for us to
qualify as a pre-existing renewable
generator we have to make incremental
investment to make incremental new hydro
and so that's where you know like for
instance at our Vernon station uh in
Hinsdale and Vernon Vermont we had
replaced uh four of the generators out
of the 10 there with new generators that
allowed uh Vernon to qualify um at
Comerford we did a very similar thing at
Moore we built this brand new UN unit so
this is how you have to make these
Investments to
qualify so M lenos probably knows this
question better than I do but just for
an example let's use $25 a wreck 1.6
million Rex would be worth $40 million
is that a sum that you actually collect
wouldn't that be nice
um uh so most of those uh low values
like like I said a very high percentage
of our generation qualifies for these
what what are low value wrecks so these
are are wrecks that compete with uh
other massively supplied you like L
nuclear and other um imported
large-scale uh uh Hydro so Vermont tier
ones are a good example of that right is
that there's a very high Supply Plus
there's a very low demand Vermont's a
pretty small state and there's not a lot
of demand for these things so large
Supply because the qualifications are so
low that just about everything qualifies
and uh uh low demand so the prices
really suppressed so it's you know you
know two and a quarter maybe per wreck
not okay that that that's understandable
thank you yep additional questions for
Mr Kibby representative McGee thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Mr Kibby for
taking my question so you bring up a
good point you know we started with um
Dr Mano talking about small Hydro class
4 and then you brought up that you're uh
benefiting for a portion of your recent
investment in class one which is New
Generation would you um could you
comment on whether the class
one uh wrecks are designed to Spur
Innovation because it would seem to me
that people might be more reluctant to
invest if they didn't have that category
of Rec so I just think for the benefit
of the committee just maybe understand
you're investing are you investing in
part because you qualif for certainly in
part because we qualify for uh the these
renewable energy credits remember the H
as I said earlier Hydro is the longest
10e generator on the system these are
long investments in Hydro are long
duration Investments they're not you
know solar met last 20 years a hydro uh
type of uh uh infrastructure lasts 40 50
60 years a dam and you know the General
Life of a dam is considered 80 years
many of our dams are a lot older than
that because we've been making
consistent Investments so the time
Horizon the payback Horizon on the
Investments that you make in Hydro are
extremely long and to make that you have
to have certain assumptions that you're
building into that now uh to the
representative's earlier point that
everything has risk and that's why we're
glad that we're Diversified in multiple
different markets to help absorb some of
that risk but like I said the
deregulation of these markets has driven
so much efficiency into these that
there's very little wiggling left
um you know I I I laugh when people
think you know a lot of people treat
hydrop power as oh that's been there
forever it's been fully depreciated we
don't have to continue to pay for that
anymore you know they you know people
claim they're like water-powered ATMs uh
we wish but uh just like you know you
have to continually invest in your roads
and your Bridges and other major
infrastructure require continual
investment and investment in this type
of infrastructure these types of
equipment are massive Investments that
have a very long long payback
period follow up so we talk a lot about
how we're interested in Innovation and
new technologies and that sort of thing
um
and you're a hydro uh person but we're
new generation is actually a category in
the
RPS um I'm looking at it and thinking
I'm making that connection in my mind
that if you want Innovation then you
should be having an incentive program
that says to people invest here and it's
okay we're not going to pull the rug out
from under the making the economics work
because often times as you said those
Investments don't return they're
long-term Investments right so they have
to have something stable right that's
correct and we for you know to use I'll
use the example of the Littleton project
as the example again about $20 million
investment that we made in this 4.7
megawatt unit which we essentially
strapped on to an existing Dam an
existing station so built this
efficiency into it um
we when we were relicensed the last time
at that facility we were required at
that point to pass 300 cubic feet per
second at all times through that Dam uh
cubic foot's about the size of a
basketball so people have a visual here
um we were passing 300 cubic feet per
second through 40 megawatt units to try
to spin this giant unit with this little
volume of water that's hydraulically
efficient at multiple thousands of CFS
and so we were spinning this J unit with
300 CFS but at a very low efficiency
like 18 or 19% so we were generating
power with it but it was not had very
low efficiency so what we did was we
took that that same volume of water and
put it through an appropriately sized
unit that we can now generate 27,000
more megawatt hours a year simply
because it's doing so more
efficiently uh and you know again that
investment $20 million worth of
investment if you check power prices you
know uh most the time they're very very
low in the Wholesale Electric and
they've been getting lower and lower and
so to try to just just make that
investment based on that loan is really
difficult to to justify so it's it's
because of these markets and because of
the robust nature of these markets we're
able to take advantage of
that representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um and thank
you for being here um you mentioned it
during your testimony and on page two it
says that you pay $1 million a year in
property taxes that's that's a lot of
money um if the RPS were phased out I'm
assuming you would be in in a little bit
of financial trouble and you mentioned
that a lot of your land is open to the
public would that land be in Jeopardy of
being sold for development if the RPS
were were phased out so all of our land
almost all of our 30,000 acres of land
are subject to conservation easements
that protect it from other types of
development we have the ability to you
know use the property obviously for
Hydro power generating and and
transmission and that kind of thing um
because uh but that was a license
requirement you know every time we go
through a licensing all of our
facilities we get the the regulations
get more and more and more restrictive
we can do less and less with our hydrop
power so we have three generating
stations on the Connecticut uh Vernon
Bellows Falls and Wilder um in Hinsdale
uh uh uh Walpole and uh Lebanon New
Hampshire all going through relicensing
um and we are I laugh it's I want to cry
when I say it we're 13 years into a five
and a half year process for
relicensing and uh that process is going
to restrict our ability to have as much
operational um flexibility as we used to
have and that means we're going to have
less capability of of dispatching we're
going to have less capability of peaking
we're going to have less it's just less
of everything because that's what's
happens every time you go through
licensing so uh that's a financial
burden on us obviously um but you know
when our properties are evaluated from a
from a property tax perspective it's
typically done on an income basis right
U so these are Income generating
properties and so uh the appraiser will
look at all of our revenues that we make
and apply you know on all of our costs
and then create a value for the property
obviously if our revenues go down our
value goes down our property taxes go
down so even if you just look at it
specifically from that angle um it could
have a potential negativea impact on
property taxes
followup follow up um you say that uh
the property taxes are for 19 different
jurisdictions do you have just an
estimate of of the impact to some New
Hampshire towns of the increase in
property tax well in I can tell you in
some communities we represent upwards of
40 to 50% of the total tax revenue that
those communities take in so we are
we're not the biggest we are by far the
biggest taxpayer in those communities
and so it can have a real significant
impact thank you
y okay seeing no further questions thank
you very much we'll call next on Charlie
nebling of bosan
good afternoon Mr nebling good afternoon
welcome back to St thank you thank you
Mr
chairman members of the of the committee
uh my name is Charlie nebling I live in
bosow in New
Hampshire I am a self-employed
Forester and I've spent the
last I don't know 15 years of my career
involved in supporting and advocating in
support of uh the responsible use of
wood to make energy primarily focus on
heat but also combined heat and power
and power generation in the state of New
Hampshire um part of my my work has
involved assisting and
supporting uh institutions
municipalities counties and others in
exploring the option of of modern wood
heat and combined heat and power as an
alternative to to the use of fossil fuel
TOS for heating mostly in parts of the
state probably entirely in parts of the
state that don't have access to pipeline
natural
gas uh so they're stuck with oil or
propane essentially for for heating on
on any kind of meaningful scale I've
seen firsthand in that work through
feasibility analysis financial analysis
assisting and supporting in identifying
Grant
resources uh to to help with the
significant Capital cost of this modern
Uh Wood technology I've seen firsthand
the impact that
Rex electric thermal have on the
economics of these projects and I just
want to leave you with an economic
argument you're you're going to hear
lots of testimony today on this bill and
the one to
follow um
as I stated a week or two ago on House
Bill 224 a reminder to the committee
that we we import most of the energy
that we use in this state we are we
don't produce fossil fuel we export
billions of dollars a year and I I went
hunting in the most recent State Energy
report trying to find the figure from
the 22 Energy report I couldn't find it
but I'm going to keep hunting Mr
chairman but but years ago it was like 3
to four billion a year that hemorrhages
out of the state because of the oil coal
natural gas and propane that we depend
on for transportation Heating and
electricity so I'm I'm going to make a
purely economic argument to you and
state that Republicans Democrats
Independence uh all ought to embrace the
goal of reducing ing that Hemorrhage of
wealth from our state by producing more
of what we can within this the state to
displace what we were we are otherwise
dependent on from other states or other
countries there's so much common
opportunity to work together there and
focus on that goal and to the extent
that the RPS helps us uh by establishing
a Statewide platform policy platform to
achieve that goal in part I support it
um I would encourage you to to vote this
bill in expedient or perhaps uh
transition it into a study bill to
evaluate the broader goal of
comprehensive policy review on what we
can do to keep more of our wealth in the
state and be less dependent on other
people's energy and achieve a measure of
sovereignty that we don't otherwise
benefit from that's it thank you thank
you Charlie I know you know a lot about
the RPS I'm going to ask you this
question sure are there any
opportunities within the existing law to
save more money for rate payers for
example with eliminating classes so that
all Renewables compete against each
other save rate payers money in the long
run it it might uh potentially
benefit technologies that can compete or
for which the the value of Rex at a
lower level is sufficient to provide
them the competitive advantage that they
need but there's a very important reason
why House Bill 873 17 years ago created
separate classes so that they compete
within a technology category and not
among technology ology
categories
um I would remind the committee that 12
years ago primarily because it was a
cost-saving measure a small piece of
class one was carved out and allocated
to Thermal at a lower alternative
compliance rate or cealing
price because thermal can compete at a
lower cost than electric generation that
was a cost-saving measure it's the only
reason
that bill passed uh during the time that
that Bill O'Brien was speaker of the
house it was the only reason so yes
there are opportunities to find savings
but I'm not sure that lumping classes is
necessarily going to achieve the goal
that you you think it will it certainly
would harm uh fuel
diversity okay we'll talk more about
class one thermal in the next bill yes
thank you all right thank you next up
let's get Sam Evans Brown back up here
to U give us
his Salient
points does from very often I'd love to
put my time the end
okay um how about then
um Sheila Connelly of holderness
representing
RMI hello Miss
welcome thank
you good afternoon my name is Sheila
Connelly and the RMI ref refers to the
name of my company which is Resource
Management Inc and our company is based
up in holderness and we were born 30
years ago because of the biomass
industry our company's first job was to
recycle the 5,000 tons of wood ash that
are the by byproduct of biomass power
and what I want to just point out is
that not unlike what Charlie was just
describing about all of our wealth being
exported um when we have uh fossil fuels
rather than local renewable energy um so
the unintended benefit from investing in
biomass so many years ago uh and then
subsequent RPS investment has been to
help our New Hampshire farmers in ways
that nobody had
foreseen um part of growing crops in New
England and anywhere requires um three
nutrients n nitrogen phosphorus and
potassium in New England we don't have
pottassium mines to provide this very
important piece of the fertilizer
equation at the scale that's needed in
fact in the United States we have the
the majority of our podes comes from New
Mexico and that is not enough for our
country in fact we are the 10th larg
10th largest potash Source in on the
planet and we get our poach from uh
Russia the Soviet Union
former um China is a is the second
largest and the third that we are
dealing with our partner is Canada now
the tariffs that are being
bandied about are really going to hurt
our Farmers here in New England and in
New Hampshire remember we're here to
talk about the RPS I understand
sir and I think it's really important to
understand that it's not just the
electricity that's being created it's
all of the things that are related to
that type of electricity and uh one of
the things that's nice for New Hampshire
Farmers is that they are able to take
the chips that are harvested from the
forest processed into clean electricity
at these biomass plants and then that
wood ash comes back to their Farm fields
to grow crop for New Hampshire this is a
very important piece of the puzzle often
overlooked and un and understood and so
I just think it's really um important to
look at the whole package and say you
know Hydro is good for these reasons
wind is good for this solar's good for
that and the biomass has a place here
the only way these biomass plants can
remain viable and continue is through
this RPS program so for today I did
bring a copy of my testimony as well as
I have little baggies of wood ash for
each of you this is a wonderful
fertilizer product and you should put it
on your Tomatoes or your pumpkins or
whatever you grow um and I can hand out
both these samples as well as my
testimony okay thank thank you very
much questions for miss
commy seeing none we'll turn next to
Michael oir and Jody
grimas welcome back to the two of you
nice to see you
again going to start yeah
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Jody grimus I'm here with Michael O
who's the asset manager for Bridgewater
power company I know a few of you have
come up to visit the plant for those
that have never have we'd love to have
you come up to visit the biomass plant
in Bridgewater I'm assuming we're just
speaking to 219 right now Mr chairman
right because you want us to speak to
later okay because I've held my card for
that one um I'm going to have Mike talk
a little bit about why we're opposed to
this phase out of the RPS and how it
benefits um particularly in the area of
biomass which is class three and then if
you have questions we'll go through it
what I've passed out to you um is
actually a study that was done uh at the
at the behest of this legislature U
actually representative Thomas was the
um sponsor of house bill 10005 that
talked about a um commission to look at
the low grade Timber industry um and
what the needs were in New Hampshire and
I would just point out it's highlighted
in your in your report it just came out
in 2003 chairman harb from house
resources was the chair of that
commission but on page four it talked
about how important this industry is to
New Hampshire um and it talked about how
one of the things that we need to do is
support the renewable portfolio standard
support um biomass power and low-grade
Timber so that is for your information
but it's it's a study that was just done
in
2023 and it shows about the importance
their ultimate recommendation and
conclusion was that it's a very
important industry to New Hampshire and
should be supported at all levels of
government and state agencies and they
specifically touted supporting the
renewable portfolio standard so I'll
turn it to Mike to talk a little bit
more about
biomass well Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you very much for
allowing me to testify as Jody said my
name is Michael oier I'm the asset
manager of Bridgewater power company
we're a 15 megawatt biomass plant in
Bridgewater New
Hampshire I come before the committee
today obviously opposed to House Bill
219 and I strongly encourage the
committee to vote it an expedient to
legislate I've testified many times
before the committee and uh can
certainly tell the committee members a
lot about the history of the biomass
plants and I'm happy to do that at the
end of my testimony while I only
represent Bridgewater virtually all of
these facts pertain to all the small
power plants uh small wood buring power
plants in the state each of these plants
directly employs between 19 and 23
individuals and indirectly employs
almost 100 people in various support
roles most notably our fuel
procurement we have direct payroll and
benefits over over $2.3 million per year
just at our facility alone our facility
purchases 200 to 220,000 tons of holtry
chips annually with a value of
approximately 5 to 66.5 million these
chips come from all corners of the state
and come from a number of different
sources traditional forestry is only one
of those sources others are land
clearing for roads and housing
developments clearings to remove trees
infected by invasive insects like the
emerald ashb damag trees from storms and
more we have other operations of
Maintenance expenses of over 1 million
annually most of all these dollars
mentioned stay in the state and have the
multiplier effect in the New Hampshire
economy since 2007 programs to promote
renewable generation were initiated many
states across the country these programs
have universally been referred to as
renewable portfolio standards and
commercially salable product derived
from these programs are called renewable
energy certificates a wreck is
generated by the production of one
megawatt of Generation by a renewable
resource our facility has three salable
products our energy our capacity and our
renewable energy certificates these
recks are critical to the viability of
our facility we will be out of business
without the ability to sell Rex into a
viable New Hampshire class 3 Market this
bill eliminates that product and that
market it is very important for members
of the committee to know that from 2007
to 20
2015 and very significantly from
2015 until currently the New Hampshire
class 3 plants were in actuality
supported by the Connecticut RPS program
and the cost to New Hampshire rate
payers was
negligible rrex was sold into the
Connecticut program the new yet today
the New Hampshire program is
significantly more important to us as
Connecticut has reduced our ability to
sell into their Market
one extremely important thing to
understand about the RPS program is that
the State's Department of energy has the
legal authority to adjust the purchase
requirement for Rex already and they
have done that many times in the past
the last two years for example the
purchase requirement has has been
dropped to
.5% from the
statutory
8% therefore this bill is not required
for the purchase requirement to be
lowered the biomass industry supported
these reductions and testified in in
support of the change at the doe when we
knew we had our our recre sold into the
Connecticut Market working openly and
transparently with both New Hampshire
doe and New Hampshire Dees the biomass
industry has been a model of success for
other states in the country it is
somewhat disingenuous to frame this bill
as a vehicle to provide significant rate
relief
each year doe issues an annual report
about the RPS program the most recent
report was issued
11124 in that report on page 14 it shows
that the entire RPS program not just
class three the entire RPS program adds
0.33 cents per kilowatt
hour utilities generally use a 600 KW
hour average for a residential customer
doing simple math a customer would save
approximately $1.98 a month if you
eliminated the entire
program the state will have lost all the
benefits mentioned earlier and in
addition to those benefits the power
generated from our stability from our
facilities stabilizes the grid and
lowers both hourly Energy prices and
capacity costs as we sell as what is
defined as a price taker and I'm happy
to explain that at the end of my test
testimony reviewing the most recent
forward capacity auction if 100 fewer
megawatts were bid into that auction
which is what would happen if all of
these facilities closed New Hampshire's
share of the capacity cost would
increase by over 13.5
million in closing again i' strongly
urge the committee to vote this bill
inexpedient to legislate I would like to
just uh make one point about rate pay is
being smart or being dumb or whatever it
might be and I think that I'd rather
rather than think of them that way I'd
rather think of them as maybe kind of
using their Yankee common sense and
understanding that the electric grid is
pretty complicated and they don't
necessarily have the expertise to know
how to deal with that and if you look on
ISO New England's
website you'll you'll very easily see
this and it's pretty important ISO New
England considers fuel diversity as a
critical factor for maintaining system
reliability in the region particularly
due to New England's Reliance on natural
gas and its
vulnerability to potential Supply
disruptions during Peak demand periods
especially in the winter therefore ISO
New England actively analyzes and
promotes a mix of fuel sources to ensure
power generation stability across
various scenarios including extreme
weather events biom Mass power is a
Basel loaded resource and we have bid
into the system every day this
winter happy to answer any questions
thank you
questions representative McGee has one
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr lei
for taking my question so I was
copiously writing notes and you made I
think a really important point when you
said that if there were 100 fewer
megawatts if the biomass uh in New
Hampshire went under that we would in
turn have an increased capacity cost of
13.5 million can you just explain that a
little bit more yes when ISO New England
does a capacity auction they start with
a needed amount of power and they start
with a base price the last auction
started with a base price of
$14.25 per kilowatt month and what
happens is they do What's called the
declining clock auction and as more
megawatts go into the system then
they're what considered their demand
requirement that price of capacity goes
down and it goes down further which
actually makes the system more reliable
because it means more megawatts than
they really require are going into the
system but it brings the price of that
capacity down because otherwise rate
payers would be paying more than their
actual demand requirement as it ratchets
down until no more plants will bid
there's a floor of
$2 the last the last auction uh closed I
believe it was
$3.57 and so if 100 megawatts were out
of that it would have closed higher up
more at like
$383 and if you take New Hampshire's
share of that it would have been $13.5
million
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um thank you both for being here
um Jody just as a point of clarification
you mentioned that this report was the
result of a bill by representative
Thomas and because we have to do this
all the time on this committee can you
please identify which representative
Thomas sure I'm sorry um it was House
Bill U one5 by representative uh Doug
Thomas uh chairman V was a co-sponsor
thank you very much as was Senate
President Carson and Senate President
back then um Jeff Bradley so it was a it
was a thank you much appreciated thank
you um can I just mention one last thing
I was thinking more about the Chairman's
question about
374f and the RPS and whether they were
conflicting um I was around in um 1997
when the market was restructured um I
actually see them as complimentary
because as I look at the um the view of
the electric Market the energy market
and how the price of that wholesale
energy has gone down I think that's what
restructuring was thinking about was
making sure the energy prices were
continuing to go down that wholesale
Market because of competition where I
think RPS is complimentary is that it
pushes that diversity and the diversity
if you have all your eggs in one basket
I.E natural gas there is no competition
and we get the spikes whether it's the
Ukraine or the winter months or whatever
it might be it's it's we can't we can't
be upheld just by one kind of focus on
energy so I think the RPS is
complimentary to what we've seen which
is successful restructuring where we've
seen lower energy prices and electricity
prices on the wholesale Market but we
have the benefit of that diversity of
biomass Hydro coal this that like all
the different types of energy generation
so I think that's where I see them as
complimentary not
conflicting thank you okay
representative Swanson has a question
we're down to about 18 cards here so
okay so I should make it quick if my
neighbor get we'll be leaving at five
minutes a five if we U so if this this
bill proposes getting rid of the RPS or
or effectively scaling it down and I
think I heard you say that it would
equate to $1.98 a month per rate payer
yes for for an average 600 most of the
utilities when they when they represent
an average rate payer they use 600 kilow
so if my neighbor had this $1.98 a month
back but also it sounds like the uh the
the market for the gas fluctuates
significantly would there be any way to
distinguish whether they got their $198
back no and I think we've all seen that
when when a lot of the biomass plants
were not producing power no nobody saw
their rates go down at home and so was
there were a number of years where none
of the bio I think Bridgewater was the
only one of the small biomass plants
that actually stayed running the entire
time nobody's nobody's rates went down
and and and when we talk about subsidies
and we talk about trying to be an even
playing field every form of energy gets
subsidies there there are investment tax
credits there are production tax credits
there are depletion allowances there are
guaranteed loan funds for nuclear power
plants
if unless unless the committee thinks
that they can somehow rewrite the
federal energy code or the federal tax
code you can't we have a hybrid system
we we we really
can't have say that everybody's
competing on an even playing field there
there's too there's there's too many
complexities to the to the marketplace
for energy thank you very much thank you
Mr chair okay representative Doug chair
Vice chair Thomas has a thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question ju I
didn't have a question until until you
mentioned those last bit of facts can
you tell me
then of the subsidies you mentioned the
long string of them which ones only come
from the
state which ones for us the only one
which ones only come from the state of
of the ones that you mentioned all the
subsidies you mentioned for all the
energy all over the country which ones
come from are directed by by New
Hampshire renewable energy credits and
many most most states in the country now
have adopted renewable energy credits
okay follow up
yes therefore all the other ones you
mentioned are all federal directed
correct thank
you okay seeing no more questions I want
to thank you two and invite Eric wormy
to come talk to us he's from Bradford
New
Hampshire good afternoon Eric good to
see you
again good afternoon guess I haven't
seen you in quite a while so I haven't
been here for all of the build today um
one minor correction I live in Sutton my
post office is
Bradford okay somehow Sutton has five
different zip
codes um thank you for letting me speak
here my testimony
is kind of unique among everything else
here
it doesn't really fit to any of the
bills but I wanted but looking at some
of the other testimony for the
bills none of them made any mention of
the productivity that we need in
producing power or anything else and how
that productivity relates to our
standard of
living so the my concern is
that for some of the
generation schemes for wind power and
solar for example those are both highly
subsidized from the federal levels and
through the RPS
stuff and one of the big reasons there
is to prevent the effects of climate
change which is largely solely blamed on
co2
emissions climate change turns out to be
a lot more complicated than just that I
won't go into details because we'll be
here for the rest of the day
um suffice it to say that the United
States has done a pretty good job at
reducing CO2 emissions in the last 10
years or so largely thanks to our
Reliance on natural gas which is good or
bad um other countries especially India
and China have seen their emissions
increase by quite a bit China
equaled the United States CO2 emissions
in 2006
they now emit something like almost two
and a half times as much CO2 as we do so
I don't see our attempts at lowering CO2
emissions is being terribly
productive and given that the cost
behind wind power is so high and even
solar people are saying solar is getting
cheap now but some of that comes from
buying it from China
um but a lot of that is still dependent
on getting subsidies and my point for
all of this and it ties ties into the
Rex and the RPS systems here is i'
really would like to see getting away
from subsidies as much as we can um on
the other hand in interest of full
disclosure I I also see that a diverse
power supply is extremely important and
ISO and like the previous speakers
mentioned
understands that too and I've seen cases
where our alliance on natural gas on
some really cold days a couple years ago
triggered increases in the spot Market
to
be several hundred dollars per megawatt
hour so we need to get keep that under
control too so ultimately I really have
no good ideas on what I would recommend
that the state of New Hampshire tries to
do to maintain the sort of power
distribution system that we
need thank
you thank you uh and also thank you for
the written testimony that you
submitted we appreciate that any
questions for Mr
wormy yes Tom
PL thank you chair and thank you for
taking my question you mentioned the
productivity and standard of living well
as you heard in testimony we have this
big circle I'm going to use that analogy
of growing the trees we have people out
there that got Capital Investments that
chip them transport them bass now we
even use the ashes along with the
historical we only have so many dams
we're never going to replace them the
hydro that gets
wrecked you mentioned it would you
cons label that as high on the standard
of living productivity for New Hampshire
to keep those thank you um
yeah for the most part yes um one thing
I mentioned in my written testimony is
that in the Gren wind project several
years ago when nire wind was trying to
prevent more wind projects in the new
found Lake
Region I discovered that groten wind had
something like four full-time employees
to maintain their 24
turbines and this wound up being each of
these people was responsible for I
believe about 12
megaw of
power if the wind was blowing that high
enough to run the wind turbines at full
power on the other hand I was quite
astounded to discover that the Granite
Ridge natural gas plant in
londondary was running with I checked
today they say about 30 people then I
think it was 19
and each person there is responsible for
generating something like 23 megawatts
of
power
so this is one of the key
reasons now there are several reasons
but it's one of the reasons why I'm
really not a fan of wind power at all um
other generation schemes like
hydroelectric I believe can run
extremely efficiently um the
infrastructure costs are High um but
once set up and running that doesn't
require too many people to keep things
in operation uh one of the things you
have not heard from when the wind power
people is that the the blades wear out
faster than the wind turbines in general
themselves because they get impacted by
insects and bats and other things and
just dust so a lot of times um turbine
blat need to be replaced well before
their expected 20e
lifetime okay seeing no more questions I
want to thank you for making the trk
down here from Sutton or Bradford or
whatever thank you very much okay next
we'll call on Dennis McKinny from
barington New
Hampshire Bennington I'm
sorry should have put my glasses on
welcome Mr mckin
thank you it's Bennington New Hampshire
which is a wide spot in the road in
Hillsboro
County I am uh speaking in opposition to
House Bill
219 my written testimony was submitted
through your electronic portal late
yesterday I'll be as brief as
possible uh I am opposed because of I
think believe strongly that we need
public policy that Fosters wood as a
renewable
homegrown uh fuel source it's important
for us to be as energy independent as
possible and more specifically I am a
land owner of 100 acres of Timberland in
Bennington and I've been a Consulting
Forester I'm now in my 50th year uh I
have used biomass as a a tool for the
management of Timber projects Wildlife
projects Recreation projects and uh to
enhance water quality on Municipal
watersheds it's a critical tool and it's
deserving of stable
markets thank you also on the issue of
subsidies I would note that you can go
on the eversource page and there's an
entire section devoted to rebates for
heating and cooling uh and I have been
the beneficiary of some of those
subsidies when I have been smart enough
to install heat pumps and cooling
systems in my own home so thank you very
much okay thank you seeing no questions
we'll move next to Jennifer Smith from
Pembroke
no Jennifer Smith from
Pembrook
okay next we'll go to Jim Van valkenberg
from froling energy in
Peterboro welcome back I think we saw
you recently it's been a couple of years
I think so thanks for having me uh
froling energy is located in Peter
excuse me it started in Peterborough but
it actually uh is in Keen right now I'm
from Peterboro myself I'm vice president
of sales and marketing there and uh I've
actually been involved in Renewables
since 1978 in New Hampshire so it's been
a long time and a long uh fight to try
to get things established here and it's
been a a long road that's been very very
rewarding um I just say this I'm here to
support the biomass side of the RPS and
that's where where froling energy is
involved we happen to have a CHP system
on our site where we're generating a
heat for drying wood chips because we
created this product called uh pdcs
which is a dried wood chip fuel that is
a very cost effective uh Fuel and mainly
it's because it reduces the cost of
infrastructure in a boiler plant so we
came up with this about 10 years ago we
actually took it from Europe it's not a
a new fuel but over in Europe over in
Europe it is a common Fuel and so we
have many customers right now in New
Hampshire and some in Vermont
that are using this Fuel and it's
offsetting about a million gallons of
fuel oil every year by our plant in Keen
that utilizes wood chips that come from
about a 50 mile radius most of those
from New Hampshire and uh that is
supporting this whole Marketplace uh
these places include like wheel and
Engineering which is offsetting about
170,000 gallons of oil on that one site
alone every year that's offset and what
what access do they have to Fuels they
have oil they have propane they have
electricity they don't have anything
else so we just like Charlie noted
earlier we are in the area that is not
served by natural gas and will probably
never be served by natural gas just
because of all the impediments of of
putting new infrastructure as well as
Supply but the the keys are that they
found that this was the best alternative
to oil that they could find it's
actually very cost competitive to what
if there was natural gas in that area
these dry chips and then green chips are
even less costly than that especially
when you apply the uh the uh thermal
wrecks that are part of the RPS so we're
that little wedge of the RPS um we're
also are heating a big Nursing Home in
westerland a county supported nursing
home uh we we are the Department of
Corrections in bosan we heat that whole
plant and uh you know these kinds of
things are are just common in New
Hampshire not many other states are
doing this and this has been a big
success story and there's so much more
to do there's there's so many more
businesses out there the the I think the
rural areas the non-natural gas areas
deserve to have a lowcost fuel and
that's what the RPS does in two ways is
it gives you a a chance to get a rebate
or maybe a grant to put in this rather
expensive system it's about double the
cost of what a regular conventional oil
or gas system would cost and you end up
with a a uh a better incentive to be
able to do this by also running the
calculations of what the thermal wrecks
are going to give them over time so our
fuel costs the equivalent of oil at
about a dollar and a quarter a gallon
currently so it's very inexpensive and
it's a very high tech very low emissions
very low maintenance there's lots of
good things about it the technology has
come forward and we've been able to
advance this there's not many companies
in this business we'd like to see that
expand but at this point this is where
we are at step by step so I just say uh
let's let's uh not go forward with with
uh abandoning the RPS we think it's
doing great things and the fuel
diversity in the state I think is very
very
important all right thank you for coming
here and giving us your
testimony representative Thomas I guess
has a question yes I do um I'm intrigued
about why you would dry chips is it that
they burn better or is it they they
weigh less and it there's less to
transport them it's actually interesting
is it Greenwood chips come right out of
the the the woods generally is that you
have a a chipper in the woods he's sort
some gentleman is sorting the the the
logs and then putting them in the
chipper accordingly so he's paying
attention to that but they come out as
random size a lot of things could be as
big as your fist some things are big as
a matchbook and others could be as big
as your arm and there's also uh metals
and things that could come through that
that that end up in a chip Supply so a
wood chip plant plant like some of these
that are in like miramac Valley High
School they take in chips right out of
the woods it's about 45% moisture and it
falls off the tailgate of a truck into a
pit and then from there it has to be all
these pushers and things under the pile
have to they sort of move all these
heavy chips around and finally get them
to the boiler and the boiler has to S
dry them within the boiler itself before
they actually burn so that's a long long
process and it's going to be a big
facility it's got to be bigger than a
high school actually these days drywood
chips we take the the same chips and we
take they drop them off at our plant
over in keen and then we put them
through a screener that brings them down
to a smaller size and then we dry them
to 25% moisture and it gives us this one
advantage that we're able to use a
blower truck to put it up 30 feet in the
air up into a silo and that's a simple
agricultural silos so you end up with a
steel Silo that's very inexpensive above
ground and when it's minus1 degrees
outside Dry chips don't freeze together
into a solid Mass so it's it's that 25%
is just the perfect place for this fuel
to be I find that fascinating thank you
very much we do too representative
rolds thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Jim for being here yeah he does it
Jim does a great job of explaining all
of the technology involved but I just
want to ask you you gave a few examples
but could you give the committee a sense
sense of the the overall
number uh in its in the lifetime of of
the company rolling energy uh the number
of municipalities and school districts
and County facilities where you have
installed biomass heating plants not
just the Precision dry chips you
described but also you know the the
other kinds of boilers that you purchase
um would pellet spoilers how many
communities school districts County
facilities throughout New Hampshire have
been installed by your company and when
they did that they relied in part on the
revenue stream that would come from the
uh renewable energy certificates under
the RPS there's a good number in fact
that is our biggest Market is schools I
didn't even mention the schools but even
places like Plymouth State and and the
University of New Hampshire have our
systems on site uh we have school
districts uh like in uh uh the the uh
Belmont schools and the the Shaker
District we we go up to Campton we're in
Plymouth we're in you know there's
there's about
30 I'd say no maybe probably 2025
districts in particular and many many
schools as a result of that District um
we often go in with the energy
Performance Contractors and we act as
the lowcost fuel that helps them to pay
for these big energy renovations that
are done in the school districts across
the district so okay followup just again
I was also asking about municipalities
yep counties how many how many other
jurisdictions have made these
Investments the towns um there's a a
good few towns there's not a whole lot
of towns it's more the counties you know
like chesher County and and uh and
Marram County I'd say the towns like
Peterboro has like five installations in
town and other towns have very small
buildings we're out in the rural areas
um you know but it's generally the
schools that we're we're working with it
seems the the municipalities we're like
the henker uh um Wastewater not the
wastewater treatment but the DPW garage
we we did as well as Hopkinson things
like that are very minor but they you
know they add up they add
up
good okay seeing no further questions
we'll next call on Brook
Peterson of Keane also from froling
energy
please confine your temp testimony to
something different from what your your
um companion there from Fring energy had
to say I will um thank you for for
having me
um thank you chair and um thank you
house committee my name is Brooks
Peterson I'm with froling energy and
froling wood
boilers
and the letter that's being passed
around was written by Mark froling and
I'm I'm here on his behalf to testify
for froling
energy and we are strongly opposed to
House Bill
219 Fring energy specializes in biomass
heating systems and combined heat and
power projects and I can unequivocally
state that these bills threaten not only
the future of renewable energy in New
Hampshire but also the economic
viability of local businesses job
creation and New Hampshire State's
leadership position as sustainable
energy
solutions while HB 219 proposes a
gradual phase out of RPS over 5 years
the reality is that impact will be Swift
and
devastating the mere anticipation of
declining RPS requirements will cause
renewable energy certificate values to
crash within the first year or two
the rapid devaluation undermines the
financial stability of existing
renewable energy projects and
discourages future investments in Clean
Energy
Technologies in addition there will be
economic impacts if this bill is passed
such as job losses business uncertainty
and higher long-term
costs the renewable energy sector
supports thousands of jobs in New
Hampshire phasing out the RPS will
trigger job losses across the biomass
solar wind and other Ren rable
Industries companies like ours rely on
the RPS framework to secure financing
for projects without a stable wreck
Market investors will Retreat halting
the growth of local renewable
businesses although the bill projects
short-term reductions in electricity
costs these savings are
misleading over time Reliance on F
fossil fuels will expose rate pairs to
volatile Energy prices and undermine
efforts to achieve energy Independence
furthermore there will be environmental
impacts such as increased carbon
emissions and energy insecurity the RPS
has been instrumental in reducing
greenhouse gas emissions eliminating it
will reverse progress increasing our
carbon footprint and undermine and
undermining New Hampshire's climate
goals a diminished renewable sector
makes us more dependent on out-of-state
energy sources compromising our energy
security I urge the committee to
consider the broader implications of
these bills please vote no on HB
219 okay thank you
questions representative Thomas thank
you um the the uh document that you sent
out is also for HB 567 will you be
testifying for that one as well I will
thank
you all right seeing no more questions
we'll call next on Ben crra of New
London representing Duron and crowl
lumber thank you Mr chairman and
committee members uh my name is Ben
croll I the vice president of durgen
croll Lumber Company um we were founded
in
1976 we employ 80 people um we run a
eastern white pine
Sawmill uh we we have dry kils we have a
planer Mill we have a pellet Mill as
well
um let's see our our products are kill
dried lumber wood pellets bag shavings
bark mulch wood chips and sawdust uh
each year we buy uh about 200 uh buy
from 200 suppliers a year from the guy
that delivers 10 loads of logs a week to
the farmer that goes and cuts a load in
the wintertime and helps pays his taxes
um
uh we we sell domestically and overseas
our electric consumption is about uh
10.5 million kilowatt hours a year and
costs us about $1.2 million it's our
highest
cost um we are in the process of putting
in a new 600 horsepower wood boil um and
back pressure turbine to help offset
some of those electric costs um and uh
and to replace a a existing wood boiler
that was put in when I was in diapers um
which was about 47 years ago so it's
time to replace that system with a
cleaner more renewable or not more
renewable but a cleaner system um and
get some power out of it and be able to
update our kils right now our kils are
our bottleneck in our process we can't
saw anymore because we can't dry
anymore um
let's see the new system is going to be
uh a lot more efficient we're putting
the the proper uh back tech uh um the
technology to clean up the gas scream
and part of that is due to wanting to
qualify for the thermal Rex uh which has
been built into US building this
project
um where am I you know uh one of the
things this project will help us do is
offset about 990,000 gallons of propane
a year that we have to supplement right
now we're burning some of our own
biomass but we can't burn enough in the
wintertime uh our our current boiler
isn't big enough to supply all our needs
during the cold so we have to supplement
with natural gas and that's about 90,000
gallons a year we'd really like to get
off of that use our own byproducts and
try to really become our own Island
there
um you know we think the uh the the RPS
is is vital um to to our to this project
um and and to the wood industry as a
whole we're we are a big family uh when
it comes to the power plants in the
Sawmills we deal with the same
loggers uh and all that money stays in
New Hampshire which is one thing about
this industry that is very unique is the
guy the guy changing the tires and the
log truck is sending his kid to the same
high school that you know the Sawmill
owner of the power plant owner the guy
that's running the power plant it's all
together here in New Hampshire and that
money stays in New Hampshire okay final
thought please final thought uh I I
would urge you to vote no on House Bill
uh
219 and that my final thought
okay representative Swanson has a
question for you thank you Mr chair uh
thank you for being here and providing
the testimony uh Mr car uh how much
would you say that the you you mentioned
getting uh wood from various Timber
suppliers correct yes and uh so how much
does that fluctuate on an annual basis
or is it uh the market value or cost a
month-by-month change
mean from the the amount of suppliers we
get from right the cost I mean you pay
for like the board foot or something
like that how oh how much so the the one
thing
uh in the pine industry we we ride a
wave that's like this whereas
dimensional number 2x4s your 2x 12s your
structural Timber they they ride a wave
like this and so one thing that you can
almost set your watch by the price of
pine uh it might fluctuate by you know
some dollars but it stays right here
where you get into the hardwood markets
you get in the softwood markets and it's
a little more volatile can you following
question Mr chair follow up can you take
a stab at percentage of
change I guess I'm not understanding the
question like it goes up or down 5% 10%
oh it probably probably our our wood
cost varies
you know two to 5% okay thank you thank
you Mr
chair okay seeing no further questions
we'll move next to John Moses from Bath
New Hampshire
representing Britain
Lumber representative Swanson turn off
your mic when you're not speaking thank
you good afternoon my name is John Moses
I'm from east in New Hampshire and my
family owns and operates Britain Lumber
Company in Bath New Hampshire uh thank
you for having me and um the opportunity
to
testify uh we've been a family-owned
business since 1946 I manage our
manufacturing plant in Bath New
Hampshire uh our family just invested $7
million into a combined heat and power
plant which is also going to heat our
sawl um among other things we're not
some huge corporation it's my brother
dad and I trying to do what we think is
right and make smart Investments so
obviously comes down to economics and
having stable State policy part of the
economics for this investment was
because of our ability to generate
thermal wrecks if we had known that
these were going to be taken away from
us right after we made the investment we
still probably would have replaced our
45-year-old Woodfired boiler um
installed the back pressure steam
turbine but we may not have been able to
do the Sawmill heating or fuel layers um
and some other aspects of the project
that we relying on these um thermal
wrecks to kind of help us with our
return on
investment uh these are all good
projects for the state and especially
the North country as they create and
retain jobs all while creating much
needed diversification in our energy
Supply it's also very sustainable to use
local a local renewable resource to
manufacture Lumber and use that sawas
byproduct to generate electricity
we employ 35 to 40 people in bath our
annual payroll exceeds $2 million and we
support 250 plus loggers and Foresters
that circulate over $4 million into the
local economy um another thing I'd like
to point out is that we received a New
Hampshire Department of energy grant for
our project because of its ability to
generate reck which is part of what this
RPS bill is all about so we kind of
looked at um the return on investment
and the um money that was out there
through these programs that kind of
helped us make decisions on how big of a
scale of a project we were going to be
able to afford to do um which again is
putting money back into the local
economy supporting um the loggers and
the good people that we employ and work
with um the other thing
that I guess I mean this has been said
but if this gets taken away this will
affect
um the logging capacity if we don't have
good markets for our
byproducts um and yeah kind of hurts the
people that we employ and work
with now again I urge you all to
reconsider this bill and I would like to
invite every one of you up to the mill
to continue the conversation we had
Kelly aot and Dave Rosher up at the Mill
for a sawmill this past summer and they
both support what we are doing it would
be nice to have the support from the
rest of conquered as well thank
you okay thank
you seeing no questions we'll move next
to John O'Neal from the city of
Manchester Waterworks or water
department good afternoon Mr O'Neal good
afternoon uh Mr chairman committee
members um my name is John O'Neal and I
am the Watershed land and property
manager
for the city of Manchester Manchester
Waterworks
Department uh I want to thank you all
for the opportunity to testify today uh
I'm here today as a spokesperson for the
Manchester Waterworks to oppose House
Bill uh
219 uh Manchester Waterworks owns and
manages 8,000 Acres of forested buffer
around Lake Massabesic uh the southern
New Hampshire's uh public water
supply uh we own this property to ensure
the protection of water quality at Lake
as Bic uh the primary source for our
communities served our utility franchise
supplies water to 13 cities and towns
including Manchester and all of our
abing communities and we um do uh ship
water all the way down to plasto and
Salem uh in all approximately 150 uh to
160,000 New Hampshire residents um or
businesses use our water uh the health
of our forest around the public water
supply uh Reservoir is crucial crucial
and critical to help maintaining optimal
water quality biomass harvesting is
considered a vital tool to best manage
our forest a healthy chip Market allows
us us as resource managers to optimize
best forestry and health by removing
dead and unhealthy trees as well as Tree
Tops and slash to minimize the amount of
Slash and debris Left Behind after a
forest harvesting
operation uh the absence of a chip
Market uh this material will be left to
decompose in the woods and would
therefore increase fire danger as well
as uh nutrient loading into our our our
surface water supply uh which could
introduce uh toxic algae into the lake
um by nutrient loading um for the reason
stated above Manchester Waterworks
opposes both House Bill two uh or
opposes House Bill
219 um thank you for the opportunity to
speak today um to summarize you know you
know what I'm here to bring is that this
is a really good tool for us to we we
remove a lot of the low-grade material
and keep the healthy stock in our forest
and makes it resilient against um all
kinds of uh you know storm events and
other things that could impact our water
quality so it's really about managing
our buffer and without a b healthy
biomass Market it it would make it very
difficult to impossible to maintain the
level of of uh of Forest Health that
we've been able to maintain in
Manchester
okay thank you very much for your
testimony Vice chair Thomas has a
question for you thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question uh just
for my own uh understanding
so the Waterworks company does not
receive reck from the old wood it's the
fact that you can you can sell the wood
to companies that do have use for it and
therefore they get paid re for it is
that correct yes it's yes it's it's a
keeping ath Marketplace for the chips
that is a big part of what we what we
Harvest off our Timberlands I'm part of
a a larger group uh community group of
all the large water supplies throughout
the Northeast and when I go down to New
Jersey Massachusetts and other places
where they don't have chip markets they
often have a lot of forest health
problems that we don't have and they
have a lot of water quality problems uh
in their watersheds but uh because New
Hampshire has invested in the low
quality uh in the the lower quality
Market place it has allowed us to really
have a um top-notch um Force Management
program which really translates to
healthy Force seal clean
water representative rols has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being here um you're in your testimony
you mentioned um between Manchester
obviously and surrounding towns that you
supply water to
160,000 uh customers or households uh
um you must be part of a Association
there must be other Metropolitan um or
you know other cities in and towns in
the
state do you uh is it your understanding
that you know other municipalities other
towns in the state have
similar uh Reliance or at least that
they the chip Market the healthy chip
Market helps all these other towns in
the state manage their watersheds I know
in Portsmouth we depend on the Bellamy
Reservoir and and Durham is it is it the
same story across the state so many of
our municipalities are relying on this
vibrant ship Market um any M
municipality that has a forested
watershed uh would utilize the biomass
markets in order for to perform uh best
Forest practices so I know the city of
Keane has a large Watershed that they um
they have U managed and I would assume
that they are in the same boat we are
where um you know we're not high grading
we're not um we're not cutting for
profit we're cutting for water quality
so it does help uh it offsets our costs
and actually makes it feasible for us to
actually perform the Harvest um so there
are the White Mountain National Forest
is a huge Watershed for the upper marac
river and the and the Connecticut River
so even the operations that happen on
Forest Service lands is all about
watershed management as well so it kind
of goes across the state uh
uh thank you Mr chairman we've heard
that from the sponsor of the bill um you
know to do away with the
RPS and it's very easy to calculate when
you take compliance costs of
RPS and divided by rate payer you know
that it the benefit of doing so would
purportedly be $1.98 per household per
month do you think that the value of the
Watershed uh Management Services that
are supported by the U the RPS are worth
$1.98 per month to the households of New
Hampshire well I think how it would
translate for us to households in New
Hampshire is that um the customers that
drink our water rely on um you know
having a pristine having a pristine
source and we do treat the water we
filter um we filter the water that we do
get but we uh the the water quality as
it comes in before it's filtered is is
very high quality but yet still requires
treatment um if we were not um if we
weren't managing the buffer the way we
are now it could increase you know
treatment costs which would increase
cost to the customer on the other end so
there could be that you that
circumstance if we uh see a diminishment
of our water quality where our treatment
costs would go up thank
you representative McGee thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question the last couple of testifiers
um have all mentioned their little piece
of the pie in terms of how you know
Yankee Ingenuity Works in New Hampshire
where we we've solved multiple problems
um and are doing more than just the one
thing right that's what you're saying
you're saying a a byproduct of the way
you operate your business is providing
this other benefit so um so what would
what would you say about um
uh well I guess the word I want to use
is tenuous but I get the sense that
we're sort of uh that a lot of small
businesses are holding up basically um
the energy economy and also uh many
other aspects of the environmental
economy um can you speak to that at all
because I you did allude to it just very
specifically about how you're operating
but if you go away tomorrow right if if
we end up doing something that that puts
uh small businesses like Mr Moses's
family business that's been with us
since
1946 if we make it harder for those
businesses to function what do you think
the uh the impacts are and I think I
think representative reyolds was trying
to get at that too with his
question to the state if we lose if we
lose the small Marketplace out there for
Sawmills and and other and other
production in the state of New Hampshire
I mean I think it it would you know you
have small land owners owners that uh
manage their properties and and get
income to help pay their taxes um by
Timber harvesting so that would that
would um you know that could impact them
if there isn't uh loggers and and
Sawmills to you know to come and uh buy
their product so that's that's one
impact I would think of that if you if
you lose I mean I've seen it i' i' I've
been in contact with uh you know other
uh water companies and uh forestry
people south of us Massachusetts New
York um Connecticut Rhode Island I mean
there's some big owners down there and
and they have to ship all their Wood
Products out of state uh to get
manufactured and therefore it's a it's a
much less bottom dollar for the property
owner so whether it's a private property
owner or a water supply or someone else
um you know and then it sometimes just
doesn't make it economically feasible
for them to do the work and therefore
then the forest suffers because it's not
being actively managed for health so
it's I think if you if these markets
start to go way which we've lost markets
in New Hampshire um you know it has been
a tough go and I don't think we really
can afford to lose more of them because
you know I think you know it's a healthy
Marketplace you know to keep a healthy
Marketplace out there is important uh
one other little sidebar um you know we
are 8,000 Acres 7500 is open to the
public to come recreate and we have
people come from all around the state to
mountain bike hike hunt um we have over
400 Hunters that hunt on our property
and um you know the uh the Aesthetics of
actually biom Mass chipping when we they
chip the tops instead of leaving the
slash behind I mean it's we have a
beautiful property that you know come on
down to Manchester and go for a hike
take your dog for a walk uh it's very
accessible to the you know it's not
really just the city of Manchester it's
really all of Central and Southern New
Hampshire come visit us so and Lake
Massabesic as well you can go out
boating on the lake and it's uh and that
we we can do the best forestry with
biomass harvesting is is my
point okay thank you seeing no further
questions next call on thank you uh Bob
from run rumney Vermont Baker River
forestry I can't quite make out your
last name Bob
so uh good afternoon uh Mr chairman and
committee members I'm here today opposed
to the bill I'm my name is Robert birdie
bti I'm from
rney and I'm a licensed New Hampshire
Forester I have number three number I'm
a forest land
owner I'm a selectman in the town of
rumney and I'm currently the board
chair and I have have uh actively owned
and managed Forest land uh in New
Hampshire for over 60 years now um some
of my ownership will be passing to my
grandson and I hope he has the benefit
of having the land as I have had for
number of years um although not included
in my testimony I would like to point
out that my property has been open to
the public for since I've owned it
I allow fishing and
hunting
snowmobiling CrossCountry
skiing uh bird watching and even have
allowed people to uh pick fiddlehead
ferns on the
property uh for
this benefit to the public I have
received no subsidies and no government
handouts my land is open free to be used
by the public
the importance of the low-grade Market
in managing
Timberland is critical for long-term
Forest
management because without markets you
really can't manage your
land New Hampshire is very fortunate
that we have markets now for all the
products that are grown on our
forest since the mid 1980s the Bas
Market has provided an important
important outlet for load grade V value
fiber in New
Hampshire the quality of our forest
resource since the mid 1980s has
increased
significantly but no matter
how the the quality of the Timber that
has grown and has increased in New
Hampshire still about 60 to 70% of the
Timber harvested is of low
grade two 2/3 of which is biomass and
1/3 is which is either pulpwood or
firewood so the biomass Market is really
the most important significant element
we have for proper management of our
forest by
none uh another benefit although not
really spoken about today is the
reduction in fire hazards and I think
all of us have seen the vast con uh
destructive forest fires that have
occurred in California and in the west
however New Hampshire has experienced
some significant
fires one being in 1911 and more
recently in 1946 now the 1946 fire that
people refer to as the Rochester Fire
consumes thousands of Acres it was the
result of two items one on the hurricane
of 1938 which left a lot of residue in
the forest and also the harvesting of
Timber in in the southern Eastern
portion of the of the state and during
46 and
47 uh rather 45 and 46 we had some very
droughty years and there was a buildup
of fiber in the forest and the
conditions you really need to to have
these catastrophic fires is fuel in dry
weather in dry conditions and low
moisture content in our forest and that
is significant of what happened in
California and it could happen in the
Northeast and mo most recently uh I was
in New Jersey when they were having the
the forest fires down there and they
have a lot of drought and a lot of
residue and those fires were very close
to a lot of residential
homes uh final thought please uh yes he
said there was a
question are you done no I I'm sorry I I
just want to point out
that although not included in my
testimony that New Hampshire is very
fortunate we have very clean water you
just heard uh an individual talk from
Manchester about the quality of the
water in in New Hampshire also the
quality of our forest is is quite good
and the significance of a of a really
healthy natural resource is represented
in a lot of ways in New Hampshire gets a
lot of revenue from people who come to
look at our forest and enjoy our
resources so I just I think that this is
important that there a lot of offshoots
from the program that is now in
existence benefits Society in many ways
so thank you very
much and I have just about enough time
to get home to get to my selectman's
meeting
okay thank you that was a good testimony
I appreciated U Learning that about the
devastating fires in 1911 and
1946 because interestingly the most of
the towns in New Hampshire recorded
their highest
temperatures ever in 1911 1944 and 1953
those are the three years where most New
Hampshire towns recorded their highest
ever temperatures 1911 was a
particularly bad year where some some
towns recorded temperatures as high as
110 and uh we haven't seen anything
like that in the last 50 years so that
was kind of interesting that fires
occurred around the same time okay
fascinating stuff so thank you for being
here thank you okay seeing no questions
we'll next call up Barry Kelly from
Berlin and White Mountain
Lumber hello
thank you for the opportunity to speak
and I appreciate your patience with all
this um I'm from Berlin New Hampshire
and I'd like to go on record as opposing
House Bill 219 and also 257 which I
won't be testifying for um we run White
Mountain Lumber Company in Berlin um
it's a we and my my family and I and uh
we've got the third generation in there
now and we're going on to our 80th year
we run a sawmill primarily we've grown
into retail we couldn't run a sawmill
which employs our operation employe over
50 people we couldn't do that unless we
could have a good market for our wa our
I don't want to call it waste I've been
criticized for that it's a byproduct
bark sawdust wood chips very important
we couldn't run we couldn't be
profitable without it the biomass plant
in Berlin has been a great Boon for us
the nice thing about that is we run a su
we buy about $2.5 Million worth of logs
they come in by truck we process it we
ship it outside the area down usually
100 miles from here into Massachusetts
and rhod Island and we bring that money
back into North Country so we're
exporting a product that's grown locally
and to grow that and to manage it you
need to have good forestry good
low-grade markets are important to good
forestry just as um Bob mentioned it's
very important and it's also important
in keeping the the uh loggers healthy if
they can't cut property and move the
biomass they can't get property to cut
because people won't let you leave it on
the ground anymore in fact some places
that are in the southern part of the
state are charging land owners to chip
their wood because it's so far to haul
it so it's important to have these
markets around um we also the nice thing
about biomass when we argued or or
testified to have it in Burl and have
the the city approve it was we're we're
bringing in wood that's gr locally we're
exporting a product all over the country
but we don't have to use the roads which
are few and fire good roads are fire few
and fire between and Berlin we can
export all over without using highways
so it's a good selling point for
that we we need electricity there's no
question look at what's look at the
prediction number in addition to
electric cars just look at the amount of
electricity they're talking about using
in AI where's the electricity going to
come from I just don't see that it's
prudent to close down plants to use a
local product that are clean and
dependable and making electricity we
need self sustain we need we need uh
reliability and self-sufficiency and I
think biom biomass Plants provide that I
think it's a boon to the North Country a
boon to the whole state and I uh thank
you for listening to me any
questions okay thank you thank you
no questions and so next we'll turn
to Thomas
Christensen of 12
Western
Way CH had to leave but heed me
to ah
okay so then we'll have Nick coff come
up from conservation law
yeah good afternoon I'm Nick cof again
with the conservation Foundation um
thanks for being here today and for
being engaged this late in the day I'm
here to testify an opposition to HB
219 as we've heard today the RPS
provides many benefits to the state um
Renewables provide significant economic
and job benefits to the state U
currently there are 3500 people employed
in the renewable sector in New Hampshire
um and know today around $800 million
has been invested in the state solar
industry um without the RPS New
Hampshire stands a lose out on these
benefits while our neighbors which all
of renewable portfolio standards reap
the
benefits um one of the purposes of the
RPS statute which is right there on the
statute written there is to provide fuel
diversity um to reduce exposure to
volatile fuel prices um you know the
Region's over dependence on fossil fuels
has contributed to price spikes over the
past few years and um however increased
investments in Renewables provide energy
diversity benefits for the state
um which can insulate families and
businesses from um those price
spikes um and eliminating the RPS would
make the state even more vulnerable to
those price spikes that we see from time
to time um which could result in even
higher energy prices for New Hampshire's
families and businesses um and then
finally I want to talk about something
that I don't think anybody else has
mentioned today um but it's that the RPS
provides public health benefits to the
state um increase Renewables they reduce
pollution resulting from the combustion
of fossil fuels um which cont
contributes to our exacerbates asthma
and other respiratory problems heart
disease cancer Etc um fossil fuel
combustion is a significant source of
particular matter particularly
particular matter uh
2.5 um and Nationwide PM 2.5 causes
53,000 deaths a year in the United
States um with you know around $600
billion dollar in health costs so
getting rid of New Hampshire's RPS it
will um you know increase power
generation from fossil fuel sources and
be detrimental to the health of of our
citizens in our state um so for these
reasons I urge you to vote against or to
itl HB 219 thank you have to take any
questions
okay representative Thomas thank you um
you mentioned and and this seems obvious
but but I didn't hear it so clear C ly
spoken that if we remove the Rex if we
remove RPS and the surrounding states
don't that's going to impact us greatly
economically correct yes I mean um you
know the the the RPS does attract
investments in the renewable industry in
the state so all those other states
still have RPS so it'll just mean those
Investments happen in other states yes
thank you okay seeing no further
questions we'll um move next to Meredith
Hatfield
from The Nature
Conservancy thank you um Mr chairman
members of the committee Meredith
Hatfield for The Nature Conservancy um I
do have a brief testimony letter going
around uh we do oppose House Bill 219
and also House Bill 567 which I may not
be here for when you hear it so I
thought I would mention that now uh we
agree with a lot of the points that have
been raised um and we wanted to point
out that um the RPS helps us meet the
state's energy needs through Innovation
and competition while promoting local
energy sources and protecting our health
and environment locally produced energy
reduces our need for electricity from
the regional grid which faces
significant price volatility at
different times of the year tools such
as the RPS and the renewable energy fund
that is Created from alternative
compliance payments helps municipalities
businesses and residents reduce their
Reliance on imported fuels and increase
their
resilience I also wanted to mention that
um you probably are aware that within
the RPS law RSA 362
F5 there's a requirement um that Doe uh
conduct regular reviews of the RPS yes
and the next review that's required by
Statute is due on November 1st of this
year so we would respectfully request
that you find both bills in expedient to
legislate uh or in the alternative if
you feel as though um further review is
needed of the RPS law that you wait
until that report is issued on November
1st um by retaining the bill and then
you could consider uh changes that might
be uh prudent at that time I also wanted
to to um amplify something that someone
else raised earlier which is that there
is an escape valve currently I believe
it's just for classes three and four um
so that is something that you could
consider once you had that that full um
review in hand from the New Hampshire
Department of energy thank
you okay thank you seeing no questions
we'll move next to Matt Ley of the
forest Society
good afternoon thank you Mr chairman uh
for the record I'm Matt Ley I'm the
public policy director for the society
for the protection of New Hampshire
Forest we are a land trust so we protect
land we're also a forestry organization
so we actually
manage uh the forest lands that we do
own um so we do have an interest in in
this discussion but I would just wanted
to make one point and it's uh several
the prior speakers made this but really
the we think one of the key points about
the RPS is that it does encourage
incentivize local renewable energy
sources and that that's an important
Point um you know for society is
probably most interested in markets for
lowgrade wood U bi the biomass um energy
facilities are certainly one of those so
we would um be very concerned um if
those markets which have been under
stress are further weakened so again we
oppose this bill we also oppose the next
bill you'll be hearing but I'll be happy
to take any
questions
okay seeing no questions want to thank
you and turn next
to
Jared milliner of uh Auburn
Maine representing Maine
sis thank you chairperson it's glad to
be back here again and members of the
board my name is Jared Muller and I'm
submitting testimony on behalf of misus
to express our opposition of House Bill
219 the RPS is essential to New
Hampshire's renable energy development
supporting local sustainable energy
resources especially wood which has long
been recognized as America's first fuel
modern efficient efficient wood Energy
Systems provide affordable reliable
power while strengthening the Region's
energy security eliminating the RPS
would harm New Hampshire's Forest
economy reducing the demand for
renewable energy credits that support
responsible forestry job creation and
the productive use of low-grade wood
byproducts without these incentives wood
energy producers and related Industries
would face economic hardship leading to
job losses and increased Reliance on
fossil fuels at a time when New England
is working towards energy Independence
we can in the RPS would put New
Hampshire at a competitive disadvantage
slowing Clean Energy progress and
increasing long-term energy costs we
urge the committee to reject HB 219 and
appold a strong market-driven renewable
energy policy that benefits local
economies project protects jobs and
secures a sustainable energy energy
future thank you for your
time and okay thank
you seeing no questions we'll move next
to
a couple of different folks who declined
to speak
earlier so would either Jason stock or
Sam Evans Brown
who oops who declined to speak earlier
like to say
anything okay Sam Evans Brown you're
up oh you're declining again I'm sorry
hand out okay so will we'll scratch your
card then Scrat
card your dance card has been
scratched so Jason stock you're up from
the New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association e
Mr stock you're up okay thank you I just
wanted to make sure we're good to go um
for the record my name is Jason stock
I'm the executive director of the New
Hampshire Timberland Owners Association
you've heard from several of our members
today about the value of biomass and and
the rpss role in biomass um the RPS law
is is an area where utility policy meets
natural resource management whether it's
a watershed in Manchester a piece of
forest land in in rumney or or a piece
of or a sawmill operation up in in
Berlin um our you know the coming around
is a copy of you'll see this green page
I'm not going to go through the whole
document whoops I'll get it later um it
that is the well thank you Jody that is
USDA Forest analysis what this does is
that's a USDA does a Statewide survey of
the state's Forest once every five years
they do it to all the forested states
what this shows is that New Hampshire
has a robust forest and as a consequence
we have a robust Forest economy we
continue to grow more wood than we
Harvest um the unfortunate thing is that
in as you heard earlier about two-thirds
of that wood is considered low grade so
like your garden when you're growing a
garden you you want to grow nice quality
carrots you have to go out and do some
weeding and thinning at some point in
the season to ensure that those carrots
that remain are the high quality carrots
that you want to take into the kitchen
and eat so biomass is a tool that's used
it's a low-grade market and it's a tool
that's used for that weeding and
thinning
um it's it occurs across the state I
took a little dive deep dive into the
the uh intent to cut there's a Timber
tax in New Hampshire every town reports
Timber taxes when there's a commercial
Timber sale in the state of New
Hampshire they record the volumes and in
2023 there were
196 tons of biomass harvested across 174
towns some of these were large large
commercial Timber sales on the side of a
mountain in Orford but some of them were
small clearings for for residential
residential development or small
community forest in the southern part of
the
state
NHA hired Plymouth State it's about it's
been 10 years to do an analysis looking
at the economics that come from Timber
harvesting
and we did this in 2012 every truckload
of logs in 2012 granted things have gone
up every truckload of logs or wood chips
you see going down the road there's
$1,684 of economic activity that go into
that log that that to get that truck on
the road and get it to the
mill to put things in perspective
583 th000 tons equals almost 20 ,000
truck loads that that put this in
perspective we're talking about $32
million of economic activity that occur
across the state in 174 towns um so
there's this biomass thing is really
important for the state the state's
Forest economy and Timberland owners you
heard about the Land Management options
it's used as we it's used for Forest
Health it's used for Aesthetics it's
used for for recreation it's also an
important piece of of the logging
infrastructure in the
markets um that are associated with it
and then of course the the the for the
Sawmills the byproducts don't call it
wood waste the byproducts that come from
the Sawmills it's an important it's an
it's a critical market for them and also
as you also heard when you see a
contraction in Timber in markets there's
a contraction in logging capacity we saw
this when the biomass plants we Lo a
number of biomas plants shut down about
four or five years ago we saw an
immediate contraction in logging
capacity and what also happened was a
subsequent contraction in log in in saw
log delivery so many of these Sawmills
that you also see are suffering or
struggling to get saw logs because that
company that used to have two two or
three crews out working on the landscape
producing biomass and at the same time
producing logs may have only one crew
because they can only Market one Crews
worth of
biomass and as a result that one crew
there's two two Crews worth of Saw logs
that aren't getting cut as well um final
point please my final point is that
representative Doug
Thomas representative Doug Thomas
chairman Vose had the foresight to
commiss
that low-grade Timber and wood supply
document that Jo jod grimas had passed
out earlier and if you look at page four
and it's highlighted page four one of
the key findings is and this is when we
talk about Market
retention um one of the key points is is
that you keep you try to keep what you
can and in that report it could not be
any clear about the important role that
the RPS and policies like that play in
this intersection with the state's
natural resource management natural
resource community and just Land
Management in general so that I'll leave
that report with you the the the other
the last the very last point I'll make
is um since the biomass those closures
we've had a number of biomass plants
start to come back online trying to make
it trying to make a go of it um there
there are four there there are now three
that are kind of running the RPS as you
heard from Mr O is is one of three
revenue streams that are critical you
pull that RPS out the economics
completely the completely C in and it
they don't work and so keep we have a
level of we finally feel like we have a
level of stability in this biomass World
we're no longer freef falling passage of
two 219
will keep that will just push us over
the edge and keep that freef fall going
we've got to maintain the maintain that
level of of stability and so with that
um the other item Tom Thompson who who
had a medical uh situation today
couldn't make it but Tom Thompson a tree
farmer from Orford he did give me his
letter of testimony which I is also
circulated around um he too
opposes uh house Bill 219 and House Bill
567 happy to try and answer any
questions and thank you for your
Indulgence representative Thomas thank
you Mr chair um just trying to clarify
something you said um you said that when
you do a harvest 2third is low grade
Timber um if I heard that correctly I'm
getting a little tired um why isn't
2third high-grade Timber are we doing
something wrong or is that just the way
the cookie crumbles you know I blame a
lot of these Foresters behind me for
that what have they been doing no it's
it's it it's 2third and it's two-thirds
if you're lucky you know two-thirds is
growing out there um it's a nature of
our forest okay um it's the the types of
trees that we have you know in in the
types of trees that we're growing it's
also a function of past Land Management
practices um if you if you think of a
you know think of a let's let's pick a
one of my favorite species a sugar maple
if you harvest that sugar maple that
top eight if you're lucky 16 to 20 feet
is your saw log that's the quality but
you have branches you have Twigs you
have you know branches large branches
coming up that's all low grade oh okay
so so it's that but it's also that
Little Thicket of red Maples that are
growing next to that sugar maple that
are just waiting to try to take over
that wood lot and red maple beautiful
species I love it but it's an aggressive
species and if at the end of the day if
you're a land owner and you're looking
at growing quality and you're also
looking at return on investment you want
to be growing those sugar Maples you
want to be growing those white pines and
so when you're out there doing your
management you need to have markets for
that scraggly Thicket of red Maple
because if you don't the red maple will
be left to its own devices and over time
you'll have a a lower quality wood lot
and consequently lower quality Timber
and you'll have a sawmill saying Hey
where's that quality of logs you used to
send me all you have is this you know
scraggly red maple I used to like those
white pine
logs this is what happens granted it's
overtime but that's kind of the Dynamics
that are at place play here if you don't
have markets for this low grade again
fascinating thank
you all right seeing no more questions I
want to thank you for your thank you
very timely uh testimony and great
information next up is Lynn sweet of uh
sweet logging
and land clearing something yeah land
clearing okay thank you chairman and the
committee members for the opportunity to
testify to today I think I hopefully
will be the one that shows you about the
little muscle that is behind all the
biomass that gets to these Mills my name
is Lynn sweet I'm a co-owner of sweets
logging and land clearing a company
based out of straford New Hampshire my
husband and I have been operating over
30 years we have five employees who live
in straford Northwood Barnstead
Pittsfield and one that travels down
from
Grafton uh my husband and I personally
own 200 acres in the town of straford
and at this time our land is open to
Winter Recreation with a snowmobile
trail that connects important corridors
leading to Rockingham and bellnap
counties a little nervous
sorry I'm also the chairman of the
select board in the town of straford and
have served my town for 16 plus years
our town has at least 12 families that I
personally know that are in the logging
industry include both harvesting and
trucking just a little snapshot of our
company our payroll average is about
272 um, a year our average operating
cost is about 1.5 million a year we paid
a total of 210,000 in stumpage payments
to land owners in 23 that if not more in
2024 this also translates to an average
of 21,000 each year going back into the
municipalities for payments for Timber
tax this does not include any monies
also gained from the current use penalty
for conversion of land when developing
which could be an additional $5,000 to
$20,000 per lot this is a good amount of
money going back into our local towns
and Community communities generated from
our small Logging
Company why am I opposing these bills
which I should say I'm opposing Bill 219
and House Bill 567 but I know we're
talking about 219 by removing amending
the renewable energy classes one and
three and phasing out the electric
renewable portfolio standards this could
our industry overnight and
affect many other Industries such as
Trucking Mills equipment mechanics land
owners Foresters and Beyond this bill
would force our industry to reinvent the
wheel even though this proverbial wheel
has a few flat spots worn into it
already but it works instead you should
be sporting our industry that is one of
the founding Industries in New Hampshire
and still a very much needed industry
that provides a natural resource that is
already here and can assist our power
grid we Harvest timber for both state
lands and in the private sector which
include land owners who manage their
Timber lands and contractors developing
land we operate all over the state of
New Hampshire biomass and lowgrade wood
is a byproduct that cannot be avoided
harvesting low grade is very important
to the health growth and management of
our Timber and our Timberlands with the
everchanging markets across the board it
is already challenging with the limited
options we have lost so many mills over
the Last 5 Years it's important to keep
this biomass plants that we have now
operating the economic impact is
far-reaching
biomass and other low-grade wood is a
valuable and reliable energy resource
that goes further than you could ever
imagine in closing to just save few
Pennies on a utility bill it would
instead be losing Millions for the New
Hampshire
economy thank you again and I oppose
House Bill 219 and the future bill of
okay thank you very much seeing no
questions I would like to call next on
Chris Elms of the New Hampshire
Department of energy Mr Helms Mr Elms
said that he would not testify on this
bill but would make himself available
for
questions and I do have a question for
you sure uh yeah for the record Deputy
Commissioner Chris Elms of the New
Hampshire Department of energy so thank
you so we've been here now for gosh two
two and a half hours uh And We Have
Heard lots of testimony from the wood
industry and lots of testimony from the
hydro
industry so my question for you is is
there any way for you the department to
estimate since we're looking for ways to
save to reduce costs for New Hampshire
rate payers is there any way for you to
estimate what the effect would be to
remove class two from the
RPS remove class
one thermal and put it in class three
and then remove class one from the RPS
so that the RPS would now be class three
and class 4 Wood and hydro is there any
way you could either estimate the impact
of that or get back to
us I will take the latter option I think
uh it it would be difficult to do that
as we might be able to provide some
analysis on a variety of aspects uh of
that
question excellent thank you does
anybody else have a question for the
Department okay did you have one
representative rolds I guess well I
guess I'll try to make it a question
will it be possible while you're doing
that analysis that the chairman just
asked for you
to uh include the
estimated impact on
um businesses
municipalities school
districts across the state who
have
installed either solar or we don't have
much in the way
of we don't have any really building so
I guess it would be solar projects you
know at businesses at their schools
whatever so are relying on you know that
are relying on income from the their
sale of their renewable energy
certificates I feel like it would be
important for this committee to
understand that potential impact sure
and I would say on that uh you know both
the questions of cost and benefit are
are you know difficult analyses to do
especially in the specific context of
the New Hampshire renewable portfolio
standard uh you know when you look at
what uh there has been uh to incent the
change in the resource mix that we've
seen really just since the Advent of the
renewable portfolio standard obviously
there's been a major shift from uh you
know oil and coal to Natural Gas doing
large part to the economics of natural
gas uh we've seen a tremendous amount of
incentive and subsidy at the federal
state Regional level uh through uh both
tax credits and other programming um
those those benefits that we talked
about right there are potential uh
energy benefits reliability benefits and
then obviously we heard a lot about non
energy benefits that the New Hampshire
RPS specifically you know proponents
have talked about today whether it's
Timber or agriculture I'm I've made a
whole list dams water quality Public
Health whatever it is that's not
something I'm going to be able to
include in whatever analysis we have and
that's not something we would uh you
know look to assess uh and then even on
the cost side you know to the extent
that you know we talked about in our
presentation and I'll keep this quick
sorry Mr chairman um you know uh the
some of the the market effects of out of
Market spending and the price
suppression effects that lead to uh
maybe perhaps undue retirements from uh
non uh subsidized resources or resources
that don't receive out of Market um you
know how do you parse out how much cost
should be responsible for the renewable
portfolio standard for the costs of say
the keeping the Mystic generating
station online and the $450 $460 million
we spent uh just to keep that online
right so uh I can go back and look for
both the cost and the benefit uh
analysis I'm not promising you I'm going
to give you something that's going to
give you a whole lot of
specifics
followup yeah that was a long answer to
my uh question which was uh I didn't ask
you to do a cost benefit analysis I
asked you to if you could do an
accounting of the uh
Revenue that school districts
Municipal other and businesses private
businesses in this state uh would be
losing uh if we eliminate uh the RPS so
they have been getting selling their
wrecks into the wreck market and if we
eliminate it there'll be a loss of
Revenue so I just want to make sure
we're
accounting for that because loss of
Revenue stream to school districts
municipalities
counties would be uh loss of Revenue to
them which would have to be made up
through property taxes so I just want to
make sure we understand what that is
yeah and apologies and sorry for the
long answer because I think it was
getting to a point that maybe I didn't
make clear there but when you look at
what goes to incent say a private
business a municipality uh from
participating in distribute generation
in renewable energy whatever it is uh
there are a lot of factors so how much
of a a project that might receive tax
credits that might receive other state
subsidies that might receive a grant
that also then gets some gets to
participate in the wreck market and to
the extent that the New Hampshire wreck
Market impacts you know New England as a
whole you know I we heard testimony that
the RPS in New Hampshire is modest it is
modest compared to the spending that
you'd see in other states in New England
uh you know in Massachusetts the last
time I the last numbers I saw from their
variety of clean energy standards their
their estimate this was 20 22 was
between a billion And1 a. half billion
dollar a year and so when you look at
our total costs approaching 600 million
dollars it sounds like a lot but you
look at what Massachusetts is spending
and there's a lot there so there is a
degree to which some uh folks are going
to see major changes to the market and
and and uh if New Hampshire is one of
the only states that they can sell their
Rex in uh other resources are not going
to see major change because we just
simply aren't as big of a part of the
New England Market
okay thanks for that question uh
representative McGee has one thank you
Mr chair and thank you Mr Elms for
taking my question so my question is now
we're sort of picking again which pieces
of the RPS we may be able to get rid of
and we said class two which is solar so
my question is are we accounting
for
uh are we accounting for any goals in
terms of man side right the like the
value of having people generating energy
where they are rather than importing it
um for quite a while the the office of
energy planning had uh 10year strategy
plans that listed uh demand side efforts
Energy Efficiency um and uh you know
generating more energy than you need so
that it gets used by the person right
next door to you do you have any
Assessments in the department of energy
about the value of that because I think
what we heard here today from folks in
other classes is the down Downstream
benefits for New Hampshire um of the
other aspects of resources in New
Hampshire that they take care of as a
byproduct of the work that they're doing
either with Hydro or with with biomass
so is there any such information around
solar
adoption so uh there thank you for the
question it was a good question always
long no uh and and I'll just to the to
the second part first um you know there
are a variety of analyses that we do and
have you know our tene state energy
strategy does talk you mentioned demand
side resources does discuss sort of uh
you know those resources and where they
fit into our mix and obviously you know
in a variety of proceedings at the Pu
we've talked about you know the value of
distributed energy resources and uh
among other things uh I'm just going to
you know point out and I apologize for
not giving you the upfront uh a little
Preamble here this you know we're
neutral on the bill um the goals
associated with the RPS are are those
that are listed in 362 F right uh in
section one there and and you heard from
folks on those uh the Department's role
here is to implement what essentially
the legislature has been pretty clear uh
are the are the goals and requirements
so to the extent that those goals change
and if that's that's our reading of what
this this bill uh is is indicating right
we will implement it to the best of our
ability
follow up thank you so the I guess the
heart of the question is that we're
talking on this committee solely about
cost to the rate payer and trying to
find savings for the rate payer so does
the department of energy have any
information that can give us a sense of
whether or not the adoption of solar in
the state of New Hampshire is actually a
net benefit to rate
payers in the the context of the
renewable portfolio standard or or just
in general in the in the context that we
have today which is with the with the
RPS
included what we would be looking at is
is an economic uh net benefit to people
adopting uh solar in the state of New
Hampshire that you know means we don't
have to
import so if you look at um if you look
at the net metering proceeding that uh
went forward at the at the Public
Utilities Commission and is ongoing the
department uh you know we had a position
in that docket uh and and we argued for
a status quo uh on the compensation
levels for distributed energy resources
there um to the extent that you know uh
renewable energy credits are a value you
know I think I think as you've heard a
lot of the concern that folks have
expressed are those non-energy benefits
that go beyond obviously this the the N
metering being designed as Fair
compensation rather than a subsidy um
what what you're seeing here are a lot
of uh folks talking about benefits that
might exist beyond beyond those uh sort
of energy related
benefits representative Swanson has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
Elms uh probably to uh see if I can
break this down in Fairly
straightforward terms there was a
mention earlier about like
$1.98 a month it costs the average rate
payer let's round that to $2 a month and
there it's probably in here oh I'll
sorry I'll let you finish your question
I I do want to just sort of note on that
um you know I I think what we see here
in the RAF report is a sort of a per
kilowatt hour average and I think that's
I I'd have to go back and check with uh
with the smart folks but I think that's
done by essentially taking the you know
uh total total like cost and kilowatt
hour sales uh but when you break it down
by customer class I think if you look at
the the recent default Service uh
filings in uni till it's about 8 cents
uh excuse me 8/10 of a cent uh per
kilowatt hour uh 0.9 uh for Liberty and
eversource that gets you to about $70 a
year uh $5 a month $60 to
$70 for average residential repair okay
so say it's $10 a
month okay just if you can you break
down and it may be somewhere here but I
don't recall off the top of my head so
there are class one two three and four
recks
right okay so of say it was $10 a month
how many dollars to class one how many
to class two how many to class three and
how many class four would come back to
the rate
payer it's a good question uh so uh in
the uh RF annual report that we file
with this committee uh we filed it in
November of 2024 we do break down the
ACP revenues the alternative compliance
payment revenues uh by class and those
say essentially what we're taking in
from acps uh we don't break them down by
um by the uh total RPS costs uh in the
RF report I will check in with folks to
see to what extent we can do that or
would share that you know obviously the
RPS markets are
um you know Market sensitive and and so
there that might play into it but uh I
can try to get that information for you
thank you Mr El thank you Mr
chair okay thank you and seeing no more
questions we'll give the uh baton to
John Gage for the last word on House
Bill 219 FN thank you
thank you again chairman and committee
um J Gage and I oppose this bill uh I
think energy diversity is key uh to
energy Independence and markets don't
operate 100% efficiently all by
themselves they need some help um New
Hampshire is kind of known as the dnut
hole of Energy Efficiency and clean
energy in the Northeast um I was just
looking up the RPS percentages of other
surrounding states main is 80% by 2030
Vermont 63% in 2025 Massachusetts 40% in
2030 Connecticut 48% in 2030 Rhode
Island 100% in 33 and New Hampshire is
still 25% possibly zero in
um
we the energy Market does require
government intervention
um other states are increasing their
rpss and we may lose one the problem
here is the this we're sending a signal
to the market that New Hampshire is
unstable and we heard a lot of concern
from um from wood and and water power
suppliers about the impacts this would
cause on their businesses this is not a
good signal to send to businesses in New
Hampshire um representative Harrington
noted that if people want Renewables
energy they can choose it uh we don't
need to subsidize it um rap pairs are
not
stupid um rate pairs are participants in
a market that currently is experiencing
the largest market failure in the
history of humankind the US government
released a report last year that
estimated the cost of pollution from
fossil fuels to the US is $600 billion a
year um this is a subsidy we're giving
to the fossil fuel industry um
and I mentioned before the the heavy
thumb of Alec but it's also other front
group organizations that the coch
network billionaires pay uh to influence
policies because they know policies
determine the markets uh and our
choices someone said I sacrificed the
DAT to come here and testify uh because
I'm so
concerned well I started reading climate
science 10 years ago and I left my
full-time job at Oracle 6 years ago and
I've sacrificed six years of a full-time
salary and benefits because I'm alarmed
at our government's in action to address
climate pollution from fossil fuels RPS
is not all we need to do we need a
fredal price on pollution a carbon price
on fossil fuels but the RPS is a good
thing for New Hampshire for a diverse
energy source on local jobs so I oppose
this bill
okay thank you having no other pink
cards I think we're done so I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
219 FN and open the public hearing on
House Bill 567 FN and since
representative Harrington has left due
to a prior con uh commitment
representative JD bernardy will
introduce HB 567 to the committee so
representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chairman JD
Bernardi for the record Rockingham 36 I
am not a co-sponsor of this bill but I
am introducing it for representative
Harrington because he is not here I will
point out as I understand the bill it
does essentially one major thing which
is to remove thermal wrecks from all the
RPS system such that the only thing that
RPS uh reck will be available for are
production of electricity if if it if
the wreck is being used to produce uh
thermal energy that's not electric
generating then it's uh the the wreck is
to be removed uh it also looks at the
the uh the table that defines what the
wreck values for the various classes are
going to be in
2025 and Beyond and it it
uh
puts uh changed final numbers there
class one being 6% class two being
0.003% class three
1% uh and class 4 um
1.5% and that's my understanding of the
bill okay and you're not taking any
question you're not involved with it
right okay I get it so next up is
representative Lor coren from
Berlin thank you
representative thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for all hanging in there all
day um my name is Lori coren I do
represent Coos County 7 which includes
Berlin Whitefield Jefferson Kil Kenny
and Twin Mountain um there's nothing I
can tell you that you haven't already
heard in the last 3 hours um but this
would impact our local economy jobs
would be
lost um and tax
revenue that we desperately need
would disappear um I humbly ask that you
itl HB 567 thank
you okay thank you thank you for hanging
in there and have a safe right home
all right next up is Lisa
lenos thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee um I think there's been a
bit of a loss of perspective here and I
just wanted to give you some numbers I
know no one wants to hear numbers late
in the day but I think it's important
the RPS right now today the full RPS is
25% and it plateaus at 25% if you're if
current load current consumption in the
state of New Hampshire is 10.4 million
megawatt hours a year 25% of that is 2.6
million megawatt hours that's what we
need to meet across all classes class
one is the largest at
15% and then the others are
smaller the when we talk about um the
qualified facilities Department of
energy maintains a list of the qualified
facilities that are class one Class 2
class three class 4 and Class one
thermal and there are almost 8,000
facilities the vast majority of them are
small kilowatt scale solar okay so then
they're a handful of others many of
those are not existing in the state of
New Hampshire many of the projects that
are built the wind projects were not
built because of New Hampshire's RPS
they were built because of rpss in other
states that's where the energy is being
sold that's where their wrecks are being
potentially settled as opposed to being
settled here it's a very very important
point because I'm going to get to class
one thermal now um but I wanted to make
the point that a lot of claims that
we're going to lose all sorts of money
and New Hampshire's going to collapse
and we're not going to have diversity of
fuel it's not because so much because of
New Hampshire's RPS now talk about class
one thermal for years now since class
one thermal was put into effect in 2013
we have been told that it was going to
grow in were going to be all sorts of
opportunity every year since
2013 that that resource has never even
come close to meeting its mandate right
now its mandate is
2.2% as part of the two 10.4 million
megawatt hour load is coming in at less
than 1% every year it's come in at less
than
1% and it doesn't even appear I'm
looking out wreck numbers a number of
wck that have been settled as class one
thermal which can only settle in New
Hampshire New Hampshire is the only RPS
that supports class 1 thermal when you
look at the Rex it doesn't appear that
there's been new class one thermal
generation or qualification since 2018
2019 so it's not exactly
growing so we've been promised by Mr
nebling and others that class one
thermal is very important it's going to
make all sorts of money and it keeps
business is going and all in all that
but as a resource it's not really
delivering at all okay so I that's
really important so if it disappeared
today it might have an effect on in
small community of people a small
population of people and we could talk
about how we can maintain that but um I
just wanted to make that now now let's
talk about
biomass biomass falls into two
categories there's class one biomass and
there's class three biomass okay class 3
biomass are all facilities that were
built prior to 2006 and they are less
than 25 megawatts in size those
facilities were and most of the if not
all the facilities were built decades
ago sorry Mr chairman I'll just finish
this
comment they were built decades ago
we're talking about
maintaining old technology most of which
is not even meeting our needs it's
barely develop delivering at this point
and most of it was going to to
Connecticut which was built which was um
accepting class 3 um as class one in
Connecticut so it's hard to justify that
know
it just have one more comment comment
and I'll let it go you had asked the
question about whether what can we do
can we get rid of class one I have I
would like to respond to that I'll
respond to that in in writing but the
biggest impact would be on Berlin power
and possibly shillin Schiller the biomas
facility that's class one that will be
affected all of the other resources will
go someplace else into other parts of
the of the region and we'll benefit from
that because they exist but we won't pay
for it thank you okay thank
you so I'm going to call next on Robert
con the mayor of Berlin New Hampshire
and uh Mr con I know you traveled along
long way so I want to hear what you have
to say before we shut this down for the
day I appreciate it thank you uh
chairman and thank you uh committee
members for allowing me the time to
speak um as you clearly stated my name
is Robert Conan I'm the mayor of the
city of Berlin New
Hampshire I'm here today to oppose House
Bill
567 and the proposed House Bill 2025 in
New Hampshire house
bill 567 is aiming to eliminate useful
thermal energy from renewable energy
classes this could signicantly impact
both General economy and specifically
low-grade Timber industry in Coos County
and especially in the city of Berlin
where we're in a very delicate situation
with the Burgess
biopower Berlin has a notable biomass
industry which has been mentioned few
times tonight with facilities like the
bures biopower Burgess biopower relies
on thermal energy conversion for
electricity removing thermal energy from
renewable energy classes could reduce
the economic incentives for maintaining
and expanding these facilities leading
to less investment and potentially
downsizing
operations which can lead to job losses
and creating a downward economic spiral
which would come crashing down on the
local economy spending local businesses
and services
provided House Bill 567 would deter new
renewable energy projects and expanding
current projects this bill completely
removes class one and class three plants
from receiving renewable energy credits
from thermal energy it would have a dam
ing effect on Burg's biopower Burg's
biopower as we all know is anticipated
to be coming out of bankruptcy real soon
we've been doing a lot of work with them
if House Bill 567 is passed it could
force them into a liquidation where
they're coming out of
bankruptcy the city of Berlin cannot
afford another closure we have endured
two paper mills that had closed and
Isaacson structural steel what do that
stake for the city if Burgess biopower
is forced to close it's insurmountable
to think of what that would be for the
city and its
taxpayers roughly 20% of Berlin's
property taxes is covered by the Berlin
biomass
45% is with the Berlin Waterworks and
about 25% from the sewer department is
dependent on the Burgess biopower if
they fail because of removing them from
the class one it directly falls on the
taxpayers of the in Berlin not only will
affect the taxpayers but it will also
have an impact on local Energy prices
this bill will deal a significant blow
to the low-grade Timber industry which
we've heard from tonight not only will
it hurt the logging industry in the
North Country which is a major part of
our history in everyday life it will
also have a negative effect on forestman
management which we've also heard this
evening overall House Bill 567 could
lean to a damaging impact for the city
of Berlin threatening both economic
benefits derived from renewable energy
and specific market for low-grade Timber
which plays a Cru crucial role in local
forestry economics job creation and
Forest management this could
exabill
567 thank
you thank you mayor sorry to keep you
waiting so long appreciate you driving
all the way down here to talk to us
absolutely so can you give us
a a quick update on how things are with
Berlin and Burgess the these days so
Berlin we're moving along we haven't
quite set the tax rate yet because we
had to redo the payment in Lua taxes uh
with them which um I believe has been
approved by the bankruptcy court which
we're going to be sting that down to get
established um nobody kind of won in
that short-term pilot um but that's okay
hopefully we'll make it up on the long
run but things are well we have we're
moving forward
so as far as you know the plant uh has a
a chance to emerge from bankruptcy uh
intact yes sir uh they do have a chance
to come out out of bankruptcy and it
looks like
um they're going to do well I mean
cooperation with the city has been good
they've been in member good standing
with the Waterworks paying along the
whole way and in the sewer
department um but it's a very viable
option and think one last thing that
might be is they're looking at maybe who
might be operating it
but they're they've been operating this
whole time going through it so and what
is the status of the grant that Berlin
got from the
USDA oh the raise Grant sir yeah the um
melt snow on the streets yes yeah the
snow melt system uh as of now we're um
going through the Engineering Process uh
for it and hopefully we're going to
break ground late 25 early
26 excellent yes anybody else have a
question for the
mayor seeing none I guess
we're representative McGee has one yeah
I thank you for taking my question I
just like to emphasize or ask you to
emphasize it sounds like the economics
you've been working really hard on this
your local economics and you said you
did say it would be devastating and that
you can't afford another plant closure
and you mentioned couple of other uh
large plants that probably were major
taxpayers right for Berlin correct that
have closed so um so I guess can you
just punctuate that for us in terms of
what it would mean if these bills pass
and the uh so more or less what it would
be I mean I use the word insurmountable
uh yeah in my testimony and that's
really what it would be it's about 20%
of the taxes that the Berlin biomass
covers um I believe it was that I didn't
want to be misquoted about 45% of the
budget for the Brin Waterworks
department and about 25% for the sewer I
mean so you got to
think that's a lot of money coming back
on the taxpayers if if they're not there
you mean water rates will go the tax
rate will increase the sewer will
increase Berlin is in a very delicate
spot right now our back's not against
the wall but it will be pretty quick
again if uh this fails thank you thank
you
okay thank you I have to shut it down at
this point because we got to be out of
the building in six minutes so I am
going to recess the hearing public
hearing on House Bill 567 FN keep your
eye on the house calendar for the date
at which the uh public hearing will
resume it obviously won't be this week
maybe next week or the week after uh and
we'll see you everybody get out as
quickly as possible so the folks who
work here can go home